kotlin is the most popular programming
language for building Android apps and
it can also do a lot of other things in
this beginner's course Alex will teach
you kotlin from the ground up Alex is an
experienced developer who has created
multiple Android apps in this course
I'll cover everything you need to know
in order to be able to create another
programs or move to build apps on
Android I will start from zero by
downloading the software that we need to
write code to creating our first program
and then we're gonna move to more
advanced topics we'll cover things like
variables operators Loops arrays object
orientated programming generics Lambda
functions core routines
everything will be covered in depth with
great detail additionally I'll use
beautiful animation while talking about
a concept
for who is this course this course is
for complete beginners who have no
experience with programming and also for
experience programmers kotlin is perfect
for beginners because it's very
intuitive and concise
and if you already have a background in
other programming languages then this
course would be easy for you so let's
get started
now it's time to download the installing
ID and throughout this course I'm going
to use an ID called IntelliJ ID which is
an ID made by a company called jetbrains
now you may be wondering what is an idea
an IDs stands for an integrated
development environment and it's
basically the tool that you're going to
use writer code in and intelligent it's
like a text editor but a very
sophisticated one because it has a lot
of features like highlighting our code
showing real-time errors and suggestions
you can run and compiler coaches by a
few clicks in other words it's making
the process of writing code easier and
better therefore let's download IntelliJ
IDEA so I'm going to open my browser
and in the search bar to type IntelliJ
IDEA
press enter
and we click on this download link
and on the downloading page you're going
to see two options ultimate which is
paid so you need to pay in order to
download it and Community which is free
and the difference is that the ultimate
has more features and Community has less
features but Community is not for our
purposes also pay attention on the left
hand side when I'm currently recording
this video the latest version is
2021.1.2 which was released on the 1st
June of 2022. and if you look at the
system requirements here if you click on
that you will see that this IntelliJ ID
only works for a 64-bit version of
Windows so if you have a 32-bit version
of Windows this will not work for you
now if you have macro X or Linux you
should download the particular version
for your system and if you don't know
how it just tell me in the comments and
I've made two separate video and shall
show you how to do now I'm gonna
download the community version for
Windows
so click to download the community now
our downloading is starting on the right
hand side on the top and if you have a
different browser you'll see this in an
infrared place
so once the downloading is finished just
open this file I'm going to close the
browser now because I don't need the
browser and the installation will start
immediately
now it's asking us if you allow this app
to make changes to a device click yes
you need to click on next this is the
for the location or IntelliJ is going to
be installed you can keep the default
location or you can change it if you
want I'm going to keep the default
location so I'm going to click on next
and here I'm going to check this box to
have a desktop shortcut I'm going to
click on next now I'm going to click on
install and IntelliJ is going to be
installed on my computer
as you can see on the left hand side
IntelliJ already appeared
now let's wait until the installation
finishes
when the installation finishes just
check this run Intel GID Community
Edition and click on finish now
intelligently IntelliJ is going to open
now it's asking us if you want to import
IntelliJ settings so if you have the
previous version of IntelliJ ID you can
import the settings here but I'm going
to click the not import settings and
click on OK
now IntelliJ ID is going to open
and this is the welcome window of
IntelliJ IDEA and here on the left hand
side click on customize
go here to where it says color theme so
you can change this theme because the
default team is this dark team I'm Gonna
Change it to light because the IntelliJ
team is better for tutorials but you can
keep the dark team if you want and in a
separate video I'm going to show you how
to add more themes not just the ones
provided by IntelliJ ID
now click back on projects click on this
plus button where it says a new project
because we need to configure the jdk now
and now here we have jdk and we have in
red and angle brackets we have no JD no
SDK
and now here we need to add the jdk and
jdk stands for Java development kit SDK
stands for software development so
software developer Kint is the Java
development kit no matter how you call
it this thing contains the tools that
IntelliJ ADN needs in order to be able
to compile and run our programs because
without them IntelliJ edits like an
empty text editor so it needs those
tools in order to be able to work with
our particular programming language
which is kotlin now to download the jdk
and we use the Java developing kit
because code and Java are interoperable
and that means that you can use the
existing Tools in library which Java
already has in our kotlin project so
quickly here on this no SDK and click
here where it says download jdk
now
on this window we select version 17 not
version 18 because this is the latest
version 18. this change version 17
because this is the version which has
the long-term support and that means
that it will receive bug fixes and
updates for several lists to come
without you needing to switch to any new
version when that new version is
released for the average vendor we
choose Amazon Creator and
I'm gonna let the default location so
I'm gonna click download to download the
jdk now the jdk is going to be
downloaded
now the jdk has been installed and is
installed on our IntelliJ IDEA and now
we can create our projects but I'm not
going to create a project so I'm not
going to click on create I'm going to
click on cancel and in the next video
we're going to create our first project
and we're also going to talk about a
little bit the jdk and the jvm so see
you in the next video now it's time to
create our first project and there is a
traditional programming that our first
program should be to Output the text
tail over to the console and this is
what we're gonna do in this video
therefore I'm going to open IntelliJ ID
you should open your IntelliJ IDEA
on the left hand side make sure to have
project selected then click on this plus
button to create a new project
and here we have a few options the first
is the name and here you need to name
our project we need to give a name to
our project and the name of the project
should start with the capital letter and
if it has multiple words every word
should start to the capital letter
so I'm gonna call this uh on on this the
way of naming is called the Pascal case
so I'm going to call this uh this
project hello
world
and also you should not have y spaces in
your name
next we have the location and this is
where the approach is going to be
created you can change this location if
you want but I'm going to keep the
default location
next we have language and here you can
here you need to select the language
which this project is going to be
created so we select Catalan if you Java
is selected just select other B system
we select IntelliJ and next we have the
jdk the Java development kit and if for
a terrible reason it says here in angle
brackets no LDK just click on that and
go down here off down off to afternoon
it should say detected as jdks and you
will see the jdk down there you're going
to see Amazon correct or version 17.
just click on that and it's going to be
added here
next we have this add sample code and
what this is going to do as the naming
price is gonna generate some code for us
but I don't want to have that code
generated uh now because I want to that
type that code myself and I want to
explain that code then in the next video
we're gonna check that to generate the
code for us so I'm gonna click on create
Now to create the project
and here we have the tips you can keep
the tips activated because it's uh
useful information but I'm gonna check
this actually I'm gonna just close it
here we have those windows which says
there is a that is a plug-in update
installed
I'm going to close this
so what we have now on the left hand
side is called the project Pane and here
we have some folders which IntelliJ IDEA
generated for us but now I want to I
want to show you how to check for
IntelliJ updates because in this way
we'll have the latest features
throughout this course and to check for
IntelliJ updates you go to help
and to go down here where it says check
for updates and here you can check for
IntelliJ updates and you'll see a window
down here and if there is an update it's
gonna say that that there is an update
and you can install that that update
but now it's saying that
that you already have the latest version
of IntelliJ ID and plugins installed
because we have the latest updates but
it's good to check for this because in
this way we'll have the latest updates
so throughout this course
next just check if you want to check for
kotlin updates so for the programming
language you kotlin you go to tools
kotlin and go here it says configure
custom plugin updates and if there is a
new update you will see it here and
click on install and that update is
going to be installed
on IntelliJ IDEA so there is no update
because we have the latest update I'm
going to click on OK
now let's focus on the left hand side
and if you don't see if you see
something like this and you don't see
this in this expanded form just click on
this greater sign sign in front of his
SRC SRC stands for Source this is where
our source code is gonna go
then click on this greater sign in front
of Main and make sure to have the folder
kotlin selected on this folder kotlin
this is working out our code but first
we need to create a file
and the file is the thing where we're
going to put our code so we right click
on this go to new
and here we select on the right hand
side we select quoting class file
now we need to give a name to our file
and I'm going to call this file main
you'll see the reason for this later so
I'm going to call this file Main and
then also you should be in Pascal case
so if you start with the capital letter
and if it has multiple words every words
result the capital letter
and for the from these options that we
have here we select file because we're
going to create a setup file now press
enter
now the file was created for us as you
can see in the folder uh kotlin now we
have main.at have the file and also to
open the file for us let's uh
click there now if you don't have the
file open then if you have something
like this just double click on the file
and the file is going to be open for you
now
here now we're gonna type some code now
you need to type exactly what I type so
type fun
so while I am typing as you can see
IntelliJ is trying to help us and is
giving us some suggestions so he's
saying do you mean fun that and if you
want to fill in that photo you just
press enter Because I want to to to type
that fun keyword fun and it also added
the space so fun space
then you type Main
and next we need to put parenthesis and
as you can see display button now
appeared I'm going to explain
immediately why
and we put the left parenthes and when
we put the left parenthes the right
parenthesis is going to be added
automatically
so you put less parenthes and the right
parenthesis was added automatically then
we get outside of the parenthesis we
press space now we're going to add curly
braces and again we put the left
calibrates and the record library is
going to be added automatically because
IntelliJ is helping us
now we would inside the curly braces and
now we press enter
and it uh
added the curly brace on the third line
and also indented this line for us
now let's talk about what we have here
now what we have here is what is called
the main function and the main function
is the entry point of our program so
every program that you create
it if it first needs this entry point in
order to be able to compile your code
but let's take each part of this main
function individually to talk about
so first to have this fun and fun is the
key word for creating a function and uh
you can use fun keyword to create your
own functions but you're gonna see that
in uh in future videos
next we have Main and Main is the name
of this function functions can have
different names but main is a special
one as I said because main is the entry
point of our program every program that
you create needs and needs a main
function in order to be able to run your
code and in fact if I change the name of
this function to fun main let's say a
the play path button immediately
disappear because now we don't have an
entry point and our program can run so
this is a special function and functions
can have different names as I said and
as you'll see we're gonna create your
own functions
that you can create you can give
different names to your functions now
next we have parenthesis and you have
parentheses because
um functions can take parameters and can
do some work with that with those
parameters but our function doesn't take
any parameter but we still need to
provide the parentheses because they are
part of the syntax and we can think of
the syntax like the grammar rules that
you need to to to respect in a specific
language in order to be to be a to under
to be understood to be understood and in
the same way this is the syntax in the
programming it's like the grammar rules
in which the compiler as you will see
what is the compiler later
the compiler needs
enforces you to respect those
syntactical rules which is uh to have
parenthesis for a function in order to
be able to understand your code because
if I delete the parenthesis here
now we have an underline which says uh
expecting parentheses so it's it's it it
you need to respect the syntactical
rules in order for
your code to be to be understood next we
have curly braces and we have left curly
brace and right curl base and this is
called the body of the function so this
is where our code goes so
this is also called the code block
because because it's the block of code
this is what our logic our uh our
these are our logic our lines of code go
they are we Define them inside the the
the curly braces so this represents the
body of the function
and let's add some code and I'm going to
type print line here so because when we
need to output something in the console
so we type here print line
so we type print and while I'm dumping
you associate suggested and we have the
suggestion print line and we select the
first one to fill in for us and now we
go inside the parenthesis of the print
line
and we put double quotation marks and
inside the double quotation marks we
type hello
world
now we need to
we need to run this code in order to run
this code to compile this code we can do
it in uh two ways first you can click on
display button that we have here
or you can right click and you can go
here where it says runmen.kt and the
code is going to be compiled and let's
do it from here first so I'm going to
click on display button to run our code
and I'm going to see the console opening
down and you're going to see the text
hello old hello world outputted
so the console opened and we have hello
world we have the text that we type
inside this uh thing that we have here
this also function and we have this code
output now in the console the console
opened now I'm gonna I'm gonna close the
console to explain what this print line
is this print line that we have here is
a function also but is that the function
which takes some which takes input and
the input is this text and this function
the its job is to take whatever you pass
as the input and to Output that in the
console so this is what this print line
is doing and this is a function that we
didn't create we didn't type free fun
print line and then you call it this is
a function which is uh
build into quantity this is a function
which is already built by the kotlin
programmers so we just call that
function inside our code and we can use
you need you don't need to create this
function so this is the this is what
this print line is doing so it's taking
whatever you pass inside the parentheses
and it's outputting that in the console
so this is our discussion uh about uh
the first program which is to Output
some text in the console hello world and
uh now I'm gonna show you that I know
I'm going to show you an illustration to
understand what is uh
what is the jdk the jvm and the how
kotlin and Java achieves this
interoperability because Kathleen and
Java are fully interoperable and that
means that you can
have a Java project which you can add
kotlin code and you can compile that
code and everything to work fine and
also I'm going to explain what the what
the word compile means
and for that I'm going to bring an
illustration here
so this is the illustration and uh
let's talk about what we have here first
we have kotlin source code and kotlin
source code is the code that we wrote is
this squad that is meant to be human
readable so this code is the code that
we as humans can understand we can write
this code we can read this quad but the
computer does understand this high level
uh high level uh quote that we wrote it
needs something it need it needs machine
code it needs binary code in order to be
able to understand
and this is where the jdk comes into
action so
our continent source code again this
quad which is meant to be human readable
then it's when when we press on that
play button on that and when you press
on that play button on this button and
the code is compiled
what happens under the hood is that that
quoting source code is is uh taken by
the Java development kit the jdk and
through the kotlin compiler so the
controlling compiler acts like a
translator it takes that high level
human readable and writable code
it converts that code then into what is
called Java byte code and this is not
the final step as you can see in this
illustration this this is just the
intermediary step this is not uh
converted into machine code
then this Java byte code it's uh
taken by the jvn so it's sent to the jvm
and the jvm then takes that Java by code
and convert the jbox.java by code into
something which a machine which a
specific machine can understand but
let's
let's first explain why why kotlin uh
why the jdk takes this kotlin source
code and then it converts this kotlin
source code into Java byte code
and this is doing this because different
processors and if different operating
systems need different instructions in
order to understand your code so if we
are not will not to have this Java byte
code so if we had we'll uh compile our
code on a specific platform that code
can run only on that specific platform
but because our quadrant source code is
taken by the jdk and through the
quarterly compiler and is converted into
Java byte code
and the Java byte code then it's
it's uh it it's send it to the jvm and
jvm stands for Java virtual machine and
the jvm then because different platforms
and different operating
uh different platform and different
processors need different instructions
the jvm is the one which is doing the
hard work of figure out figuring out
what kind of instruction that specific
platform needs so it converts that Java
by code into machine code let's say
which a Windows platform can understand
then the same thing happens to Linux the
J the jvm receives the same Java byte
code and then it converts that Java by
according to machine code which a Linux
platform can understand and then is
doing the same thing
to a Mac OS so the make waves the jvm is
gonna is gonna receive the same Java
byte quad and it's going to convert that
Java by code into machine code which
Macos can understand so this is how uh
kotlin and Java can achieve this call
this thing called Write once and run
everywhere this is because the
the work of converting that machine code
which which a specific platform Cananda
said has shifted from the programmer to
the platform which has the which
implements that jvm so we just wrote Our
quad we run our code through the jdk the
jdk converted that code in Java byte
code and then the platform which has the
jvm
installed uh it's doing the work of
converting that Java by code that we
wrote into something which that platform
that specific platform can understand so
and this is why uh Java and Kathleen are
fully interoperable so you can add
you can add Java code to an existing
kotlin program and vice versa you cannot
uh you can add the Java you can add the
quota link code to an existing Java
program and that is uh that is possible
because uh the jdk is gonna is gonna
convert through the compiler
all of that code into the same Java by
code and then that code is going to be
run on the jvm and the jvm is going to
convert that into machine code and that
code is going to run on a specific
platform so this is how Java and kotlin
and this is why Java and collecting and
are fully interoperable because
they uh their core they are ultimately
converted into the same Java by code and
you can also achieve this right once run
everywhere because
that code then runs on the jvm Java
virtual machine which is doing the hard
work or figure out what kind of
instructions uh specific platform needs
in order to understand that code that we
wrote and in this way that hard working
has shifted from us to the people who
implement the jvm
so this is how the jdk and The jvm Works
under the hood
and if you find this confusing don't be
just this is just a relaxed discussion
about uh how the jdk what is the jdk and
what is the kotlin compiler because I
said our cotton I said previously that
our code is compiled when I said that
this actually what was happening our
code was taken by the
jdkn through the jdk was covered in Java
bytecode then it was sent to the jvm of
uh which is on my windows and then that
is converted into machine code and then
we see in the output hello world
so this is our discussion about the
first program how to create the first
program hello world and this is the
additional discussion about how the jdk
how the quartering compiler and how the
jvm works so see you in the next video
so in the previous video we created our
first program and even though it was a
simple program you should celebrate
because you created your first program
but if you want to make your program to
do something useful you need to store
data and in order to store data we need
to use variables and this is what we're
gonna talk about in this video therefore
I'm going to open IntelliJ IDEA
I'm gonna create a new project so make
sure to that on the left hand side you
have project selected click on this plus
button to create a new project
I'm going to call it variables it should
be in Pascal case if it has multiple
words language we have already
constantly selected for the build system
IntelliJ and also make sure to have the
jdk selected here
and now I'm gonna check this out sample
code because this is going to generate
the code that we typed previously
respectively the main function and the
print line to and the hello world
text is going to be now Auto generated
for us by because we check this box add
sample code and it's going to add the
code automatically for us so I'm going
to click on create
now
our project is ready to go and as you
can see here it generated some code for
us and this is similar to what we've did
in the previous video where we created
our we'll create our code ourselves but
we have some additional code and uh I'm
gonna delete this additional record
because it will make things confusing so
I'm going to delete this part
sorry I'm gonna delete this part
and also uh you have may have noticed
that uh here in inside this parenthesis
we now we have this args array and
string
we can delete this too because
it will make I think things confusing
and we're going to talk about what are
the arrays and all of that in the next
videos
now I'm gonna
all right now ready
now let's run this code to see
to see what is happening it's gonna
output that text like it did in the
previous video
you should open the console in a short
moment
and indeed it opened the console and it
output the text hello world like it did
in the previous video so I'm going to
close the console now also let's expand
this SRC
to see the file that it was created
automatically for us this time
and um
let's change this hello world text to
print another text let's say
let's print the
type your name there in my case is Alex
so I'm going to run this quad
and it will output my name in the
console
all right so it outputted Hello Alex
like we typed here
but um
it's what we have here is pretty pretty
inflexible it's a better way to be to to
do that it will be to have something to
store this name and then refer that that
thing here to call that thing here and
this will be a bit more more dynamic
and to do that we need to use variables
and variables are
are like some containers which can hold
data values
and
let's see how to create a variable okay
Let's uh put the the the code below
above our print Ln statement
and if you don't know what a statement
is a statement is of complete
instruction of execution
Now to create a variable we just type
the keyword far
which stands for variable
all right
next we need to give a name to our very
a variable to be able to refer it later
to call it later and I'm going to end
the naming convention around the naming
variable is called is called camel case
and that means that the first
letter in the name if it has multiple
words so start with the lowercase letter
so I'm going to type user
and the next word name with the capital
letter
all right next we need to provide the
type of the variable and that means what
kind of data this variable is going to
hold it's going to store to do that we
need to put colon and next we need to
say what type of data is going to store
what
what data is going to store and we want
to store text and to store text we need
to type here string
and string means that this variable is
going to store a single a sequence of
characters or text
now
we need to assign a value to this
variable and to do that we'll put we put
here equals
space
and because we express the cells here
that we're going to put text text or
string we put a double pair of quotation
marks and we type Alex
all right so now we create our variable
we
give it a name a type and with with also
sine of value to this variable next we
need to refer this variable down here
and to to to refer that variable I'm
going to delete this text first and to
refer the variable we put dollar sign
and after the dollar sign we start
typing the name of the variable user and
as I'm typing the IntelliJ is giving us
some suggestions and it said do you mean
this username variable and it also has
this V here for variable so I'm going to
press enter to fill in that for me
and if I
run this code
you'll see the exact
singer
Happening Here It outputted the text
Hello Alex but this time we didn't type
the text directly here which we we
stored the text in a variable and we
call that variable in uh in our
printerland I'm going to add a space
here
to make things more clear
now what we can do is to change the
value of this variable by
adding below of our variable typing the
name of the variable again user name
equals and now we can assign a new value
to this variable and let's put
let's put John here
all right let's run this code to see
what happens now now this time when this
uh this instruction is going to be
called it's going to print then the new
value of the variable which is John
so as you can see down here it output
the text hello John so we can change the
value of the variable after we assign a
value to it but what you can't do is to
is to type here username
equals 5.
and if you hover over here
it says integer literature does not
conform to the specific type string and
in other words it's saying that we said
explicit explicitly up here that is
gonna store only text and down here we
try to put a whole number an integer and
that is not going to work because kotlin
is a link language which is uh which is
called statically typed
and that means that it it will check the
types of the variable at compile time
not at run time and that means it does
it you cannot run your code if you
assign um a value to to a variable which
has a different type that done done the
type that you specify specified when you
record the variable this is why we get
this warning here
and if I delete this
now let's delete this
all right
okay
the next type of variable that
also actually not the next type the word
over the next way of declaring a
variable is using the keyword
file
so if you declare if you declare a
variable as Val Val means that we cannot
change its value after we assign a value
to it so if you try if you try to assign
a new value to our variable like we did
here up here it will not work so let's
actually let's actually just change here
let's put Val
okay and and after I did that you it
immediately underlying red username and
it says Val cannot be reassigned and
that is because if you declare if you
declare a variable as Val
you cannot change its value later it
will you can put a value to that
variable only once and that's all we
cannot change the very the value of the
variable later
so let's change this back to VAR
to have the ability to change the value
now let's look at another type of
variable so I'm gonna type VAR
again
I'm going to call it age
I'm going to put colon to specify a type
here and now we're going to use another
type which is int and int stands for
integer or for whole numbers now we need
to assign a value to it I'm going to
call I'm going to put you know 10 or you
know 20
all right so what we have now is a
different type up here we have string
and that means that we're going to we're
going to store sequence of characters
and down here we have integers and that
means that we can store
um only only numbers only whole numbers
and there are different type of numbers
which you're gonna look in the next
video
and if I try here to change this uh
to change this so first first let's
let's actually
let's actually print this uh
Hello Alex
let's type your
age is and here you put dollar sign
and we call uh the name of the variable
without the name of the variable age so
we press enter to fill in that for us
and if you run this code
now says hello John your age is 22. so
now it's using the value the values of
this variable in our printerland and we
can change for the variable also the its
value because it's declared as a VAR not
a Val so we can put here age equals
let's say 25
and if you run this code
the change is reflected immediately in
our code so now we see hello John your
age is 25.
what we can't do like in the previous
example with the username Here We cannot
put a string We cannot put hit
Alex
because we said explicitly here that
this is gonna is gonna hold only
integers only whole numbers so I'm gonna
delete this let's put it again to 25 and
the arrow error disappeared
all right now
let's look at what we have here because
we have this underlines this uh
uh great light out of our types and
every time you see something like this
that means that IntelliJ is trying to
say something to you and if you hover
over here
actually let's hover over over the type
it says explicitly given type it's
redundant here
and that means that uh it does not need
to we we don't know we don't need to say
explicitly here that is gonna hold
of um
sequence of characters it's going to
hold string because it knows this you
can because it quoting has something
which is called type inference and that
means that it can infer the type of the
variable by the value we assigned to it
in our case we assign some text so if I
delete the type here
now
is still working and if I as you can see
if I if I put here let's say if I try to
put your username
sorry username
equals to tree
is still treated as a
string because it inferior it it
inferred the type by the value assigned
to it and similarly this uh this thing
applies to to our
int type so if I delete this
is still working it's tilt it and it is
still treating this as a as an end so if
you try to put here
age equals to a text I don't know again
we have this yellow arrow unifarable it
says type mismatch required int and
found string and that means that it's
still uh
is still treating this uh variable as an
in because as I said it has something
which is called type inference and it
can infer the type of the variable by
the value assigned to it
all right this is uh our discussion
about variables there are more types of
variables and we're going to look at
that other types in the next videos and
collectively they are called data types
okay
you can remove the space if you want
so I'm going to end this video now and
see you in the next video
so while I was recording this course
jetbrains have released a new version of
IntelliJ IDEA
and you will see in the course when you
when I create a new project you will see
a different window it's not that
different it's slightly different than
this window than the window that you
will see when you download IntelliJ ID
which is this version now which has this
window and when you see this window here
you just need to specify a name here you
specify the location for the language
selecting here you select for the build
system IntelliJ and
you make sure to have the jdk here and
you also check this out sample code and
that is going to generate the main
function for you and you click on Create
and the project is going to be created
for you so I thought that it's good to
tell you about this and uh if you'll see
this window and if this window changes
in the future I'm gonna release a new
video and so I'm gonna show you how to
if they changed specifically the window
of creating a new project how to create
a new project with that window but for
now this is the window of the latest
version
all right so in the last video we talked
about variables and we seen there that
you can store different data in our
variables and we looked at two different
data types or types in short and that
was the string type and that in type and
the string type was used for storing
sequence of characters or text and the
in-type was used for storing whole
numbers and in this video we're going to
take take a deeper look at the integer
data type and we're also going to extend
our understanding to more
types for storing whole numbers and that
is the byte the short and the long data
types for storing whole numbers you only
gonna see what is the difference between
this uh these types now let's open
IntelliJ ID
I'm going to open my IntelliJ ID
on the left side make sure that project
is created selected click on new project
on the left hand side measure the cotton
is selected and you don't need to give a
name to a project again it should be in
Pascal case I'm going to type
bite
short
and
long
oh
now go down here and it's going to
select IntelliJ and make sure that the
jdk is selected click on next to create
a new project and click on finish now
our project is going to be created
and down here again a setting IntelliJ
is setting up our project on the left
hand side we have our
project pane I can expand this SRC to
see our file our main file that we
created first now it was
generated for us automatically I'm gonna
delete this code and here we have
something which is called the comments
or a comment but they're going to look
at comments in a separate video
so I'm going to delete this
sorry
okay I'm gonna add this
space here I'm gonna delete this
you can keep the RX there it's not gonna
affect your code in any way but I want
to make it consistent with my previous
videos but you can keep the arcs there
it will make no difference in uh the way
your code is compiled now let's add the
code that you had previously
and previously we had the we had a
variable of type string for storing uh
text specifically we store our name
there so I'm gonna type the VAR keyword
because
uh in the last video we we established
that you want to change this value later
VAR
and uh he didn't give a name to our
value I'm going to call it name like in
the previous video for the type I'm
going to choose string
and uh I'm gonna put equals and now
Center sign of value to it I'm going to
put again our text
all right
and down here I'm going to declare a
variable but this time I'm going to
declare it as a Val
I'm gonna type I'm gonna type for the
name H
and for the type
I'm gonna put int for storing the whole
numbers I'm going to put 22.
and we see in there that we can delete
the type here because cotton has
something which is called type inference
and that means that it can infer the
type of the variable by the value
assigned to it so we can delete this
type here
and our code is going to still be valid
and if I hover over here
if you look at here is still treating
this variable as type of string so
but uh in this video I'm Gonna Leave the
string type
I'm gonna delete this because we're
gonna look at the integer more closely
and
here let's uh
let's change this value let's change its
name to
number
and it's also going to be an INT and
then let's take a deeper look first
let's see what is an integer we know
that it's a whole number so you can
store whole numbers but what is it's uh
it has a range you can put whatever
value you want actually there is a range
there is a minimum and maximum value
that you can put in a in an integer data
type so and to get that minimum and
maximum value we type
I'm going to put a space here to make
what the code Mercury I'm going to type
Val I'm gonna type Max integer
value
and for the type I'm going to choose int
or you can let it infer the type
you can
I'm gonna actually put the type here but
you can let it infer the type if you
want equals and now we type int Dot
and Intel J is giving us some
suggestions here I'm gonna choose max
value
and Discord
on the right here is gonna give us
actually the entire code is going to
give us the maximum value in a integer
and if you don't if this seems confusing
in that and this uppercase so
uh you know you don't need to worry
about that for now you just need to know
that in this way you can get the maximum
value to out to be out with in our
console and for the minimum value we're
going to type Val
mean
integer
value
for the type I'm going to choose int
now I'm going to type again int Dot and
again I'm going to choose from here mean
value now to print these two values I'm
gonna just delete this text here
and I'm going to type int
eger or in
maximum
value
is
I'm gonna put dollar sign to get the
value Max
integer value
right
and below this code we're going to type
another println
and here you're gonna put
two pair of quotation marks again and
I'm going to type int
minimum value is
dollar sign
again IntelliJ is giving us suggestions
you're going to choose minimum integer
value
now let's print this uh let's output
this code to see what is the minimum
maximum value which can be stored in an
integer data type
and if you want you can add a space here
to make things more clear
all right and as you can see down here
when the console opened that the maximum
value is 2 billion and 147 millions and
so on and the minimum values to billion
147 millions and so on and these are the
minimum and maximum values which can be
stored in an INT so that means that you
cannot put a value which is which is
bigger than this
maximum value or the watch or value
which is uh uh which is bigger than the
minimal values and so if you try to
assign and to confirm that if you try to
assign here
a value which is bigger than the maximum
integer value so let's uh type
number and
now we may be spotted the problem here
if I try to put here equals
it says
Val cannot be reassigned so let's
declare this as a bar because I want to
change this value now
I'm going to put equals and I'm just
going to copy this
I'm gonna put it here
now if I increase this number by one
let's say that I put 8 here now it
immediately shows an awning and if I
hover over here
it says that the integer literally does
not conform to the expected type int and
you may be wondering
how this makes any sense because here up
here we said explicit that this
variable is going to store integers or
whole numbers and down here we have a
whole number but the problem now is that
this whole number is bigger than the
maximum integer value which can be
stored in an end which is 2 billion one
four seven million and forty thousand
forty three three thousand six hundred
forty seven but now we have a bigger
number and um
to to store this number need to use a
different data type or a different type
and gonna see in the next videos
precisely what type we need to use and
what type we gonna use for storing a
bigger number than the integer on the
integer maximum value all right
also it's important to know because he
said he says here now the integer liter
so you may be wonder what is this leader
the liter is the value that you assign
to our variable and it's called the
literal because you assign we assign the
value directly here so we don't have a
what is called a symbolic name here and
we're going to see what is a symbolic
name in the next videos now I'm gonna
edit this video now I'm gonna change it
back to seven
and also you can delete the types here
the code is going to still work
the code is going to still be valid
and if you delete the type up here also
because the type can be inferred
like we talked about
now
I'm gonna add this video now and see you
in the next video
alright so in the last video we looked
at the integer data type and we saw
there that you can store a minimum and a
maximum value in an integer and uh in
this video we're going to look at the
next three data types or types for
storing whole numbers and those are the
byte the short and the long and let's
start with the buy to see what is the
minimum and maximum value which can be
stored in a in a byte so I'm going to
type Val
my marks byte
value for the type I'm going to choose
byte
equals
byte that
max value
below I'm going to type again Val this
time I'm gonna I'm gonna call it my mean
my um byte
value
for the type I'm going to choose byte
we're gonna put equals I'm gonna type
bite that mean value and now to print
this to print the value of those
variables I'm gonna copy this to
printerland statements
I'm going to paste it below here
I'm going to change the text to byte
and here we need to call our variables
to refer all variables so I'm going to
type
my Max byte value just press enter to
fill that for you
and below here I'm gonna
type my
mean byte value
now let's print this uh two varus the
console to see what is the minimum and
maximum value which can be stored in a
byte data type so I'm gonna run this
code
now the console should
open in a short moment
all right as you can see the byte
maximum value is 127 and the byte
minimum value is minus 128 and in
contrast with those minimum maximum
values for the integer type you can see
that these two are very very small
compared to that now let's look at the
next
the next type which is the short and I'm
gonna do the same
the same
I'm gonna type the same code AS sorry
the same code that you had previously
but uh
so I'm going to put a space to make it
more clear I'm going to close the
console
so let's see the short type right so I'm
going to type Val
my
marks
short
value I'm going to put x equals
choose short here for the type
equals
short
Dot
max value right
I'm going to press enter I'm going to
type again Val
my
mean
short
short value
and for the type again short
equals
short that mean
value now let's copy this
actually we have already copied that so
I'm going to paste that here to print
the
print our minimum maximum values
so I'm gonna change this to short this
text
I'm gonna change it here to
and now we need to call those variables
because as you can see right now they
are gray out and if you hover over this
is the variable my Max short value is
never used and that's a clever way to
see when a variable is used or not
all right let's change it
let's change the name here because we
want to refer those variables
my Max short value and
here you're gonna type my
mean
short value
right let's print this to see now what
is the minimum and maximum you can be
stored in a short
all right as you can see down here it
output that the short maximum values
minus
000 70
167 and for uh the short minimum value
is minus 32 770 168 right and if you
look at the the previous data types you
can see that the integers the the
biggest is the is the type which can
store the biggest number but uh there is
one actually which is bigger than the
integer so I'm gonna type now the next
dot that I put you gonna look at and
that is the long which is um
much bigger than the in integer so I'm
going to close the console I'm going to
type the same code
I'm going to type Val
my
Max
long value
for the type I'm going to choose long
and we're going to put equals long I'm
going to put that marks value again Val
my
mean
long value
for the type I'm going to choose long
equals again I'm going to choose now I'm
going to type again long
Dot
minimum volume
now I'm going to paste that code below
here to Output our
variables to Output the minimum maximum
bar which can be stored in a long data
type so I'm gonna
so I'm gonna change this to Long
I'm going to change this text also to
Long
now I need to refer this those two
variables up here from up here
so I'm gonna
delete this I'm going to type my
marks
long value so I'm going to choose that
press enter
and here you're going to choose uh I'm
going to type my
mean long
value let's output this uh
code to see
let's run actually our code to see what
is the minimum marketing what you can be
stored in a long data type and as you
can see the range for the longest much
bigger contrast that with the the
integer data type you can see that it's
a lot a lot bigger this number so the
longest has a more is
has a range which is much bigger than
the integer and
I'm going to end this video now and in
the next video we're going to look at
how we can use those types and um what
are the relationships between between
them right
so I'm going to end this video now and
see you in the next
all right now it's time to use those for
uh data types for storing whole numbers
in our code so I'm gonna type some code
below of those prison Talent statements
I'm going to type Val
because I want this very well to be
immutable I don't want to change this
value later
I'm going to call it my number it should
be in camel case like our last names and
for the type I'm not Define explicit
data type here I'm going to put equals
I'm going to put the literal value 28.
and if I hover over my number
you can see that the type which was
inferred is an INT now I might be
wondering how this makes any sense
because this 28 can easily fit in a byte
or in a short on a long
and that is because the default data
type which is automatically inferred is
the integer so actually let's confirm
that this can fit easily in other data
types
by running our code to see what at the
menu and you can see that that number
can easily fit in any of those data
types from this list and
that is not happening because the
automatically as I said the default type
which is in third is the integer and if
you want this type to be a byte we need
to explicitly say explicitly say here
buy it
now if I hover over here you can see
that now it's a byte
and if I want to be a short
we need to type explicitly here short
so if I hover over here now this is a
short and if I want to be I want this to
be along I just type again here long and
for the long there are two ways this is
the first way to type
the the type explicitly here
sorry hover over here it's long or
we can put IL suffix at the end of our
number
but if I put a lowercase letter you eat
it immediately show this warning which
says use an uppercase L instead of fail
and that is because this can easily be
confused with one so I'm gonna put a
napper KSL
and if I hover over here
now this is a long even though this can
be
can be easy can easily fit in any other
data type
and if I delete this cell and if I
exceed the maximum value which can be
stored in an integer let's say I put 28
or something here
and if I hover over here
you can see that now it inferred the
type to be as long because now this
number that I have here exceeds the
maximum value which can be stored in an
INT and um you may be wondering now when
to use one or the other want to use the
byte I want to use the short when to use
the long and you will find the the
answer with the practice where with the
working with them but if I run this code
the byte and the short will be used in
very specific cases and most of the time
you'll be working with the integer data
type right
now I'm gonna end this video and see you
on the next video we're gonna talk about
the next
data types which are the floating data
types and those are types which you can
hold the numbers which have a fractional
part or decimals so see you in the next
video
all right before we start our discussion
about the floating Point numbers
respectively about the float and double
data type it's important to know what
are the difference between the data
types for storing whole numbers under
the hood because we know now that there
is a minimum maximum value which can be
stored in those data types and also we
need to know what amount of space they
occupy under the hood and let's start
with a byte and our byte occupy eight
bits right
so abide occupy bits and we say that a
byte has a width of 8. and a short can
store La J range of numbers and occupy
16 bits and has a width of 16. an end
has a much larger range as you know an
occupies 32 bits and has a width of 32.
the point here that each data type
occupies a different amount of memory we
can see that an internet is the four
times the amount of space that abide
does for example
it's not particularly relevant to you to
know these numbers but it come up as an
interview question and it's useful to
know that a certain type takes up more
space than others all right now let's
close our project because I'm going to
create a new project
now I'm going to click here on new
project because we have our previous
project here
all right on the left hand side again
kotlin should be selected for the name
I'm going to call it um
it should be in Pascal case
float
and double
all right here is Eric for the best
system IntelliJ and for the produce jdk
select the indicator I'm going to click
on next and I'm going to click on finish
now approach is going to be created
[Music]
right let's delete this code
we can keep the arcs and the array
string here I'm going to keep it to see
that there is no but there's not it's
not making any difference in our
code
I'm going to drain the I'm gonna delete
the print again statement
and I'm gonna
expand this to the left because we don't
really need the project pane
actually I'm going to expand it full
then click here to hide the project pane
all right
um
floating Point numbers are used for
storing numbers which have a fractional
part which have decimals so floating
Point numbers are used when you need
more Precision in your calculations and
you'll as you'll see in the next video
this uh
has a practicality now to
declare a floating Point number just
type
Val
because I want this variable to be
multiple
I'm going to call it my number again
should be in camera case now first
letter first
word starts the color case later and the
following Awards should start with
capital letters
and for for the type I'm going to choose
let's actually not choose any type let's
just put equals and try to try here to
assign a value let's put 2.5
okay
now if you hover over here
and if you look at what type this value
has
what type this variable has you can see
that the type which was inferred is the
double
so
if we want to change the type we can
put here
float let's say to be a float
but look what happens when we do this
it says that the floating Point
literally does not Comfort the safety
type float and that is because like you
know in our example with the integer the
type which is inferred which is
automatically assumed by kotlin is
double in this case so even though it is
set here explicit that you're going to
store a float because it types here a
literal value it considers this to be a
double so to solve this you need to
delete this from here
and put here at the end of our number
and F
now if I hover over here
now the variable has the type float so
this is how you declare a float variable
into put if at the end of the number of
suffix
and the
for the for declaring a double you can
just uh
type Val let's call it my
second
number
equals and if I put 2.5 here
0.5
now if I hover hover over here like in
uh like I said previously it
automatically infer the type to be a
double so if you don't specific I if you
don't specify a type the automatically
inferred type will it will be a double
because this is the
type which is uh inferred
for the floating Point numbers and this
is similar to the integer type because
there we've seen that the type which is
automatically enforcedent so here we
have the same thing
so this is how you can declare a
floating Point number and this is how we
can declare a double now what is the
difference between this the different in
the Precision in which
depression with a half and we'll see in
the next example in the next video
we're going to be talking about
operators and operations
what is the what is the Precision of a
float and what is the position of a
double and the float comes from a
floating Precision number and double
comes for double Precision number and as
the name implies
the the double data type has a more has
more Precision in our calculation and
you're going to see an example of this
in the next
video because you need to First learn
about operators and operations before we
we introduce any kind of operator here
even though we we've already used an
operator which is the assignment
operator which is this operator here but
we're going to talk about this in the
next video
so I'm gonna end this video now and see
you in the next video we're going to
start our discussion about operators and
also in that video you're going to see
uh that the float has a smaller
Precision than a double and the double
is assumed to be
it's assumed to be the default ibicos
has a bigger procedure so
I'm gonna end this video now see you in
the next video but before we end our
video actually let's uh print let's
output those values in our console let's
output the values of the variables in
our console so I'm going to type println
statement
below for code below the creation of our
variables and inside the parenthesis I'm
going to put the double pair of
quotation marks I'm going to type my
number
equals
dollar sign to get a value
the content of my
number
and
my
second
[Music]
number
we put equals
again dollar sign
not here
my second number now let's finish those
values
in our console
and as you can see output is 2.5 and 2.5
but if I hover over here
you can see that the type for uh because
it's explicitly given here is the float
if I hover over here this is the double
but let's see what happens if I delete
the fractional part and I just actually
you can uh you can put a lowercase if
lowercase f here or an uppercase F like
this if you run this code again
you'll have the same output
again now let's uh
delete the fractional part and just let
an F there and here let's also delete
the fractional part and it's
let's run our code and you may be
know what is going to happen now
printed 2.0 for uh my number because we
said exclusively here that this is a
flow so it prints the fractional part
but uh okay in the case of my number you
only output is the 2 because now this is
inferred if you hover over here as an
INT so one
solution to this maybe to type here
double
and try to see what happens and if I
hover over this hover over here says the
interior in the integer literally does
not conform the expected to tie double
and it's correct because this is assumed
to be a need so you cannot uh you cannot
even though it said exclusive here that
this is going to store doubles here we
put an INT an integer value
so if I delete the type here
let's say if I try to put a d here
actually there is no D for the double
there is no like in the case of the
float you know if even if I try to put
the uppercase there is no
uh way to add the suffix to our
variables the only way is to put
directly here to point zero and now
this is
inferred as a double
as you can see here
and if I run this
now it output the 2.0 and 2.0 in both
four variables
all right I'm gonna end this video now
and uh see on the next video
[Music]
all right so far in our course you've
only dealt with data types which can
store numbers but there are two
different data types which you're gonna
look at in this video which you can use
for storing a different type of data and
we're going to see what kind of data we
can store but those data types are
called the Char data type and the
Boolean data type but first let's create
our project let's create a new project
I'm gonna give it a name
I'm going to call it char
and
Boolean again it should be in Pascal
case
make sure for the build system that you
select IntelliJ and measure that have
the produce jdk selected so I'm going to
click on next to create our project I'm
going to click on finish
now project is going to be created
on the left hand side we have the
project pane
we have our code Auto generated for us
even though this code is gonna we're
gonna delete this code which is inside
the curly braces because you don't need
a squad so I'm going to delete this code
and let's also hide the project pane
because you don't need a project pay
and
let's see how we can declare a chart
data type and after that we're gonna
talk about
how where you can use the shutter type
in a specific case and what specific
cases you can use so I'm going to type
Val because I want this variable to be
mutable I don't want to change valid
value later
I'm going to call it my
Char value
again it should be in camel case
and for the type I'm going to put colon
I'm going to choose char
press enter
let's put equals and let's now assign a
value to this variable so this time I'm
gonna type
a single pair of quotation marks not a
double pair of quotation marks like we
did in our string data type and in a
chart data type we can store only a
single sum symbol and that symbol can be
a letter a number or an
exclamation point on the mark
so I'm gonna put here a d a single
letter D and uh you may be wondering now
what is this what is a specific case
when you where you can use a charter
value a specific case can be let's say
if you want to store the last key press
the bio user so this is a specific case
where you can use the charter data type
now let's print this value in our
console
to see that
it should be in a lowercase letters
pinterland
and uh you can print it by the usual or
you put here a double pair of quotation
marks and we type a dollar sign and hero
we type the name of our variable match
our value
press enter
I messed up the code let's delete this
now if I run this
the console will start in a short moment
and you're gonna see the output
of the letter d
right so the console opened and now we
have output down here the letter d
so this is the usual way how one of uh
referring a variable that but you can
refer the variable even
like this
by not putting the dollar sign
deleted the dollar sign and also the
the quotation mark at the beginning now
if I run this
it's going to still output the battery
so we will see that we have now most of
the letter A so this is another way of
printing the value even in a variable
but this uh
it's not really the usual way to do it
now
um let's take a look at the next data
type and that is the Boolean data type
and to declare a boolean.type we type
again Val because again I want this to
be multiple and and I'm going to call it
my
in camel case it should be
Boolean value
for the type choose
Boolean
and a Boolean a Boolean data type Can
Only Store
a true or a false or a false value
so you can only assign here true
or false
so if you type now let's put in those
values but this time I'm going to put
the parenthesis and I'm going to put the
quotation marks I'm going to type my
char
let's
my char
value equals
dollar sign
my chart value
and
my
let's type the name here
Boolean value
equals and let's put the dollar sign
my Boolean value now if we run this code
now you can see that my chart value
which is this text here
has this value which is the content of
this variable that we're referring here
and uh
my Boolean value which is our variable
the name of our variable has the content
of false so it printed here false now
Boolean data types the Boolean Atlas are
going to be used in our code a lot
because the Boolean data types can be
used for controlling the flow of the
program so you can in you're gonna see
that in combination with the if
statement without which you're going to
look at in the next video on the next
videos uh you can control you can
actually control the flow of the program
because usually the flow the program is
from top to bottom and with the for with
the the Boolean data type and with an if
statement as you'll see you can control
uh actually what
you can control to you can control what
parts of the code are
uh compiled or not
based on a certain condition if that
function is false or if that condition
is true
so Boolean dial types are going to be
used as you'll see a lot in our code in
your coding career as you'll see
so these are the
two
data ties that can be used for storing
either a single character or a or
a character and this is the data type
which can be used for storing true or
false which is called the Boolean type
also you
May so already that you can delete the
types yet because as we talked about
kotlin has what is called the type
inference so can it infer the type by
looking
at what value assigned to it so in this
case
you know it knows that this is a type of
chart so here you know you can see that
the type is a Boolean
all right but before we end our video
let's do a little recap
about the eight data types that we
looked at into throughout these videos
and the eight data types are the byte
short int and along those are for
storing the whole numbers
and the next two data types are the
float and double for storing floating
Point numbers for numbers which have a
fractional part decimals
and the next two ones are the ones that
we looked at in do this video and those
are the Char and the Boolean
and those data types are also called the
primitive data types because it has to
do with their call like that because it
has to do with how they are stored in
memory
and a string data type is not really A
Primitive Delta because the store is
stored a little differently also as you
can see
the string data type has a special
language support
so you can consider this eight primitive
data types as the building blocks for
data manipulation and in the next video
we're gonna look at those this data
manipulation but by looking specifically
at
what operations we we can do with the
those data types because
in uh throughout this this video we only
looked at how we can store values and
how we can output this those values but
in uh in a real real app you'll need to
to manipulate that data to other to
subtract something and we're going to
look at all of this in the next video
see you next
all right so far in our videos we've
only looked at how we can store
different values in our variables how to
Output them to the console but in a real
app you'll need to do some mathematical
calculations so in this video I'm going
to learn about that we're going to look
at operators so first let's create a new
project I'm going to click on new
project I'm going to speed up the
process now a little bit because we did
this already
a few times so I'm going to call it
operators
I'm going to select IntelliJ click on X
and click on finish
now our project is going to be created
in a short moment
again on the left hand side you have the
project Pane and we have the main effect
function and the
code Auto generator for us
now we're going to delete the code
inside the curly braces inside the
calibrations of main function because it
only Discord
and also I'm going to hide the project
pane because I don't need the previous
Pane and first let's declare two
variables I'm going to declare the first
variable as a VAR because I want to
reassign this value later I'm going to
call it um
uh let's say um
X and in a real app you should use more
descriptiveness because
the name of the variable should say what
the variable is doing anyway I'm gonna
put equals I'm going to assign a value
of five
and the next variable I'm going to
declare it as a Val because I don't want
to change its value later
I'm going to call it I I'm going to put
a value of 3 here
and next I'm going to decode another
variable this is going to be also
or Val I'm going to call it result
and we're going to store the
sum of 5 and 3 here and to do that type
here x
and this is the first operator that
we're going to looked at look at and
that is the add or the plus operator so
I'm going to put here X Plus
I
now
let's print this result I'm going to
type println
I'm gonna put the double pair of
quotation marks I'm gonna type result
the text
equals dollar sign
to get the value of the variable here
I'm going to press enter to fill that
suggestion for me and now let's run this
code to see what is going to Output
you're gonna see the output 8 here
because
five plus three is eight
the console should open in a short
moment
right so it output the result equals to
eight because five plus three is eight
now what we have differently here and we
didn't uh we didn't have we didn't had
previously is that now we're using a
variable the variables here and we're
not using liters like we have here five
and three type directly
and um
it's important to to clarify some
names here and first is the name operand
and open an operand is any object which
which isn't affected by an operator in
our case the operands are X and I
because those those variables are
affected by the operator plus because it
sums their values and then it puts these
values in the variable result so those
two variables X and I are called operand
also the if you had here little revolves
if we put it here let's say 5 and 3.
directly these two all are also called
operands so literals or variables are
called the operands any
any objects which is affected by an
operator is called an operand because if
you now if you
now you're gonna see also eight here but
let's change it back to
to I
and X
and there is another way to
to
output the value of x plus I by using a
placeholder what is called the
placeholder and to do that let's first
delete this line of code
and
this now is red because we don't have
the variable declared I'm gonna delete
what is inside the quotation marks I'm
gonna I'm gonna type here X plus I the
text equals and now I'm gonna put here
I'm going to put here dollar sign and
I'm gonna put curly braces
and inside the color braces I'm going to
type Let's uh click here to make it
clear
X
plus I
so this is called the placeholder and
you can use this and in a placeholder we
can only put
expressions and an expression is a
construct which evaluates to a single
value so in our case
X plus I evaluates to a single value
because it Returns the value 8 so this
is why we can put here uh X plus I and
uh
even though if you if you if if you put
something which you will not uh
be an expression here IntelliJ is going
to warn you and I'm gonna see uh in the
following minutes
um an example of that now let's out for
this
and you're going to see the same result
but now we have the different text here
we're gonna have we're going to have X
plus I so now I have X Plus PSI equals
eight which is the correct result now
let's copy this four times and to do to
make that easier we can press Ctrl D or
command D on Mac
so I'm gonna press Ctrl D four times
now let's change this to
minus because we're going to look at the
subtraction
now here we're gonna look at I'm gonna
look at the multiplication operator
which is an Asterix operator so I need
to put here inside the curly braces the
Asterix because these were
the expression is evaluated and the next
is the division so we're going to put
here a photo forward slash
so I'm going to put here also forward
slash
forward slash right and you know this uh
this operators for a month class this
one but the one that is not so well
known outside the programming uh it's uh
it's called the modulus operator
and the modulus operator is operator
which
um
gives us the reminder of a division so
the models operator is a percent sign so
put per second sign here and percenter
sign here
right
now if you run this code
all right so now we have the output down
here and we have X plus I see eight
because five plus three is eight x minus
I is 2 because 5 minus uh
3 is 2 x times Y is 15 because 5 times 3
is 15 x divided by Y and this is
interesting is 1 but because those
variables are of typing they're inferred
automatically to be of type in it
dropped completely the fractional part
here so we don't have here 1.6 or
something you have only the integer part
which is one and here we have the the
modulus operator and this gives us the
remainder of 5 divided by 3 which is 1
and has a reminder of two
now if you want to to have here the
fractional part you need to declare uh
one of the variable uh as a type as a
floating Point number and that can be or
or either a float or a double so then
I'm going to declare the
the I variable as a double so I'm going
to put 3.0 Here and Now
all the variables all the results here
are going to be are going to be are
going to be of type double so if you run
this
you're gonna see
the fractional part for all the
variables here
now you can see now we have wipe one
8.0 2.0
15.0 and here we have 1.6666 and 7.
now it shows also the fractional part
and uh for the reminder all we've we've
also have the fractional part here so
um now the type of the if you want the
type of the expression it's a double
because we declare here as a double this
variable I as a double and the next one
is wide then automatically you don't
need to declare also the ex as a double
it will be
um so if you want widen automatically by
the fact that it required the I variable
as a double
all right
and let's continue
and often in programming you'll want to
increase
a variable by a certain number and to do
that let's first
let's declare again the variable result
down here
let's declare it as a VAR because I want
to resign it
let's call it result
and let's put again X
plus I here
now if you want to increase let's say
the the value of the variable by 2 we
can type something like a result equals
result
let's say that I want to increase this
variable by 2. I'm going to put result
equals result Plus 2.
and
this equals operator is different from
a mathematical equals because this equal
separate operator is not saying that
result equals result plus 2 because I
think it's incorrect what this equals
operator is is also called it's an
assignment operator and what is doing is
that it assigns
first it adds to to our variable result
and then it store stores that that
result that result of the that
expression in our variable result all
right so let's print this value to see
what we have here so if I print this
you should see
10 here
not print
I'm and I'm going to put here result
equals
dollar sign
result
and in front this code you're going to
see 10.
right so you have 10 but let's uh let's
delete the
the fractional part here to
have the type of the variable as
integers so let's run this code again
so now we have 10 here result equals 10
and let's copy this called the
again four times
let's add a space
so now I messed up the code and if you
mess up the code like I did here you can
do you can undo this thing by going to
edit and click on undo paste or the
shortcut is Ctrl Z and you'll see the
corresponding shortcut in a Mac here on
the right so please press here and now
our code is restored here as you can see
so let's copy this again
foreign
and let's space this down so one
two three
four
all right now let's change this this one
to minus
let's change this to multiplication
which is the Aesthetics operator
let's change this to division which is
the follow slash
and let's change this to modulus which
is the percent sign
now if you run this code let's run it
from the top right right hand side now
what you're going to see is that first
we have 10 because of now
the result has a value of 8 because X
plus sign is 5 plus 3 we have eight and
now here we we're adding 2 to our result
and then we print that value in that
variable in our
in our console and that is gonna output
10. the next we
decrement that variable by 2 and we have
eight
next we multiply
that that uh
variable by tools so we have 8 times 2
which is 16 which is the result here
next we have a result divided by two and
uh
16 divided by 2 is 8 so you have eight
eight here
now
now we have result
modulus 2 and 8 modulus 2 is 0 because 8
divided by
by 2 has no reminder right
next you can see that we have all of
those underlines here and if you hover
over one of them it's gonna say
replaceable with operator assignments so
there is a shorter wave to write the
same thing that we have here or there is
an abbreviation to write the same thing
that we have here and here and here and
here because they are so often used in
programming they are there is a
abbreviation for all of them so let's
click on replace with plus and equals
replace with minus n equals
replace with the
multiplication and equals
with division and equals and with
modulus n equals here
all right so this is the abbreviation of
what we had previously or a short way a
shorter way to write the same thing so
if you run this code now you're going to
see that it's going to Output the exact
uh
values that you had previously so we
have 10 8 16 8 again and zero so this is
a shorter way of
abbreviating uh oh actually this is a
way of abbreviating what we had
previously because as I said they are
very very often used in programming what
is
all right now
another important thing to know is
operator precedence so first let's type
again a println statement
and I'm going to put the worker
recognition marks and inside the
quotation marks I'm going to put the
text to three
so this is the text three plus three
times let's say um
four
now
also inside the quotation marks let's
put a dollar let's put equals here
the text and let's put a dollar sign
here and now let's put curly braces
and inside the curly braces I'm going to
put three
plus three
times four
let's click here to make it clear times
4. now if you run this code
now
you see that it outputed 15 because
multiplication has precedence over
addition so it first
multiplies 3 times 4 which is 12 and
then it adds 3 to our results so we have
15. but like in a math class you can
control which
expression is evaluated first by putting
parentheses so if I put parenthesis here
now this will be evaluated first three
plus three and then it will multiply the
result by four so if you run this code
you're gonna see three plus three is six
times four
is 24.
so you're going to see 24 right now so
you can see that operators have
precedence but can control that
precedence using parentheses like you
did here so multiplication and division
have precedence over
additional and subtraction
all right there are two other operators
which can be used for increasing or
decreasing the value of a variable
exactly by one and let's look at this
operator
but first let's uh use our variable X
that we declare above
and let's assign a value of 0 to it
and to use the
increment and decrement operator this is
how they are called
let's use the printerland statement
first to
let's put a double pair of quotation
marks here
and
let's type
x equals and let's put dollar sign
and let's type here
[Music]
X
and to use the increment operator we
type plus plus
right and what this is gonna do is going
to increment
the value of our variable which now is 0
by 1. and there is another way to
increment the value for a variable by
putting the increment upper operator or
the plus plus operator in front of our
variable not at the end of our variable
so we can
type again a println down here
let's put the quotation marks and I'm
going to put x equals and now I'm going
to put dollar sign
plus plus X but this now is not working
because
dollar sign only works if you refer a
variable so to do solve that you're
going to put this in a
parenthesis
actually in curly braces
so let's put this in color braces and
let's put the
above one also in curly braces
not here
all right and uh both of both of these
increment increment value of x by one
they differ in
what
value they return
so the first first Returns the value of
x which is zero and then it increments
and the next increment operator which is
before the name of the before the
variable it increments the variable and
then returns its value so what you're
gonna see if you output this code is
going to be interesting so if what if
you output this code
let's bring it down you're gonna see
Zero and two and maybe wondering how
this makes any sense because you have
incremented the value here and uh that's
that does this happens because
this first Returns the value of x so it
returns varices and then it prints the
value of 6 which is zero and then it
increments so now the X has the value of
1. when the next printerland statement
is executed now it with the variable x
is incremented by one so it has a value
of one and now it will be incremented
again but it will also be returned not
like in the previous uh increment
operator which is the other end so now
it will have the value of 2.
okay
and there is uh the same operator is
available available for uh decrementing
so if uh if you want to
decrement
a variable exactly by one I can put here
x let's put equals let's put the curly
braces actually the dollar sign
curly braces and can put x minus minus
and let's print
just call the printerland function again
I'm going to put x equals
dollar sign again
curly braces and let's put now
the decrement operator which is the
minus minus in front of our variable
now you're going to see something
similar but in the inverse way
so now we have now we have two and zero
and let's explain uh this also so again
this printerland statements executed now
the X has the value 2 and it returns to
and then it decrements so it prints the
value of 2 and then it decrements the
value of our variable X by one so now we
have one
when the next printerland statement is
executive or function is called
now the value is 1 so and it first
decrements the value and then it Returns
the the the the value of the variable so
now we have zero because it was
decremented this is why you have uh 0
and 2 and 2 and 0 here all right
so you see above here that I declare the
variable as a VAR so I can reassign this
value down here to zero
right this is our discussion about
operators there are more operators but
in order to talk about the next
operators we need to first talk about an
if statement
so now it's time to look at comments and
comments are nodes that you can add your
code and they are ignored by the
compiler and usually they are they are
used when you want to add some
description about the code so what you
want to indicate what the code is doing
because you may roll some code and you
come to that code a few weeks later and
forgot what it's doing and by putting
comments you can you can see
specifically what that code is doing and
when in kotlin we have two types of
comments the first is so-called
end-of-line comment and to add an end
offline comment we put two slices and
here we put our comma let's say
here we are
doing
ope
operations
so this is another End of Line comment
and this is a text which you simply says
here we are doing operations and this is
uh as I said an end of flying comment
the next comment that you can use is so
called The Block comment and to use a
block comment we put slash
Aesthetics and now you can press enter
or you can put Asterix and slash to add
to to add the the next uh to close this
comment and you press enter and as you
can see it added automatically this
Aesthetics and slash or you can type
this yourself and here you can put some
text which can be some it can be
something which is going to say what the
code is doing so so those are the two
types of comments that you can use in
kotlin
The End of Line comment and the block
the block comment and you can also use
comments to disable some code so if I
put two slices here
now that line of code is going to be
ignored by the compiler so this is our
discussion about comments see you in the
next video
alright before we continue discussion
about operators let's first introduce
the if then else statement and uh
let's first start talking about how
usually our code is executed and usually
our code is executed from top to bottom
and that means that our code is executed
line by line and that is the flow of the
program but with an if then else
statement you can break the flow of the
program by imposing a condition and you
can say to the computer to execute a
particular section of quad only if a
condition is true
so let's see how we can do that so let's
first create a variable I'm going to
type Val this is going to be multiple
I'm not going to reassign this value I'm
going to call it it's
active and I'm gonna put equals and I'm
going to sign a value of Truth way so
it's going to be of type Boolean on the
next line I'm going to type the if
keyword and now IntelliJ is giving us
some hints here
I'm going to press enter and inside the
parenthesis we put our condition so here
I'm going to type is active the variable
and now I'm going to type equals equals
notice that here now we have two equals
and here we type true
next
we put a left curly brace and now we can
add the right curly brace or you can
press
you can press enter and the right curly
brace is going to be added automatically
by IntelliJ for you so if I press enter
now
you can see that on the line 40 we the
right calibrase was added automatically
now
let's type here a println statement so
I'm going to type println
press enter
and quotation marks and here we're going
to type the text the
user is active right
and uh
if you run this code
let's see what happens
and we get the output the user is active
which is the text that we typed here and
let's first talk let's first talk about
what we have here
and uh
the if statement
checks to see as I said to see if this
condition inside the parenthesis is true
this if this expression returns true and
it does that by checking to see if the
operands are identical or if they are
the same so it checks to see if the
content of the variable it's acted which
is uh true it's equal to true and that
is that sounds convenient but it's true
because
uh our variable it's active has a value
of true and here we're checking to see
if our uh if those two are equal or if
they are the same and that is true and
this expression returns true and in
effect
the code inside the curly braces is
executed but if I change this to false
so if I change this value and if I run
this code now
this condition inside the parenthesis is
going to be false and the code is not
going to be executed so you can see now
that you don't see any output because
this condition is false and because the
condition is false the code inside the
curly braces is not going to be executed
but uh if you want to cover the
part where the condition is false so if
you want to execute some code even
though the condition is false you can
type here else
and here you also need to put the
calibrases so I'm going to put the left
curly brace I'm going to press enter and
the right calibrate so that added
automatically
for me now I'm gonna type println
and inside the parenthesis I'm going to
put
the user is not active so now what is
going to happen is that this condition
is going to fail it's gonna be false
because the two operands are not equal
respectively is active and true
and is going to be executed the else
part in this case it's going to be
executed the code which is inside the
curly braces of the else so if you run
this code you're going to see the output
the user is not active
so as you can see now it says the user
is not active because this condition is
false this returns this Boolean
expression return false and it jumps to
the else part so this is how you can use
the else part
now what we can
also do is to add another if statement
below of our if statement to chain more
if statements to check for more
conditions but to do that we need to use
another operator which is the called the
greater than operator which is an
operator which you may know from your
math class
and
through that let's change for the
variable so I'm going to type here a
value of
100 to make it an integer and also I'm
gonna change its name and to change the
name of the variable go right click on
the variable go to rename
to refactor and go to rename
and now if you change the name of the
variable here is going to be change
every where where the variable is called
so if I look what happens if I delete
the name here
it's changed also on the line 38 we're
referring the variable
and now I'm going to call the variable
my number and I'm going to press enter
now the name of the variable it's
updated
and now this condition is not correct
you don't need to put a greater than
sign so I'm going to put the greater
than sign and let's check for uh let's
say if my number is greater than
150 and this is false now because my
number has a value of 100 so this is
going to evaluate to false this
condition this expression
now let's add here
another if state if statement so we're
going to put here else
if
and
inside the bottom test you're going to
put the condition and now I'm going to
type
again my number my variable
or variable
now you're going to put let's say
or greater than 90.
now this condition is true so
let's add Also the curly braces because
we need the
to put our code inside there
let's put here
open until then also
let's type here
greater
than
90.
and here let's also change the test to
greater than 150
and here you can put
all the conditions
here you can put all the condition
failed because the else part is going to
be executed only if all the condition
that we have here which is uh for that
my number is greater than 150 and this
is false my number is has a value of 100
and if our lcf condition also evaluates
to False only then the else part is
going to be executed so let's run our
code to see what
what if
statement is going to be executed what
part
so you can see that we now get we get
greater than 90 and that means that this
condition is true because it's true that
my number has a value of 100 and it
checks to see if my number is greater
than 90 which is true so it executes the
code which is inside the else if part
right
now the next operator that you can use
is greater
than or equal to so you can put here
greater than or equal
now
what is gonna check
to see is to
is that what is going to check is to see
if the number that we're comparing to
respectively my number
is greater than 100 or equal to greater
than 150 or equal to 150 so let's change
this to let's say um
um
100 and uh
49 so look what happens now
so now it's executed the this part the
lc4 because this is greater the number
greater than 90. but if I put here
greater
let's change the value of my number to
um 150 to see what happens
and now we get the output greater than
150 and this is correct because now this
condition is true my number is greater
than equals to 150 and uh
my number has the value of 150 it's not
greater than 150 but it's greater than
or equal to so it's equal to 100 150 so
now this condition is uh satisfied and
the code inside this curly braces is
executed which is greater than 150. all
right now I'm gonna end this video and
in the next video video we're going to
continue our discussion about
um those operators
right so now let's continue our
discussion about the next operators that
you can use in kotlin and let's start
with the less than operator and to do
that let's first change the value of the
variable my number to 100.
and to use the less than operator you we
put here a less than sign which you
probably know from your math class
now if you run this code
I should change here the text to make it
consistent let's type here
so now if you run this
now get the output less than 150 and
this is true because the value of the
variable my number is less than 150 so
this condition now evaluates to true
the next operator that you can use is
less than or equal to similar to greater
than or equal to operator and to use the
less than or
equal to operator we put here a less
sign and the equal sign
right and let's change the value here to
150 to make it clear
now let's change also the value of the
variable to 150
and let's also change the text here
now if you run this code you're going to
see the output less than or equal to 150
because
now the else if part
and the condition of the else if
statement evalues to true
because
now the the value of my number it's not
the it's not less than 150 because it's
150 but it's less than or equal to 150
so this condition evolves to true
right
the next operator that you can use is
called The Logical
not equal operator and that operator is
used to check if two operands
respectively to if my number let's say
or and 150 are not the same let's see
how we can do that and to do that to
type here
an exclamation mark and an equal sign
and this operator here which is going to
make a mark is gonna check to see if
those two operands respectively my
number and 150 are not the same
and only then the condition is going to
evaluate true
so let's run this code to see what
happens
so now we get the output less than or
equal to 150 because we still have the
volume 150 so it jumps to the lcf part
but if I change this to
let's say
100 now look what happens
now it execute the if
now this condition evolves to true
because now this operator is checking to
see if the two operands if the value of
my number the value of my number is not
equal to
150 and that is true they are not equal
and this is why you get here the output
but let's change the output to make it
clear let's type here
they are not
tickle
so if you run this code you're going to
see the output I are not equal because
that condition now Evolution so this is
how you can use the
logical not equal operator
also with the logical not operator we
can change the value for Boolean
expression from True to false and from a
false to true in other words you can
negate its value and to do that let's
first declare the code that we had
previously so I'm going to cut again the
Val variable
it's active
I'm going to assign a value of true
I'm going to type the if statement again
I'm going to put
the same condition
equals equals true
here you can put the left curly brace
and press enter we can add the right
color base if you want but it will be
added automatically for you
I'm going to type else also the left
curl base press enter I'm going to put
the text that you had previously
all right now if you run this code
you're going to see the output the user
is active because this is going to
evaluate to show their
are equal they're the same
let's expand this
so you see the output user is active
because this condition average to show
and before you look at The Logical not
operator how we can get the value let's
first see how we can write the same
expression that we have here
in a shorter way by abbreviating so
because you have noticed probably
that we have another underline here and
if you hover over here
it says that the Boolean expression can
be simplified so let's click here
simplify Boolean expression to see what
happens
so now we get if it's active and then
print then execute the code inside the
curly braces so this thing now does the
exact same thing that we did previously
it's so it checks to see if the value of
its active is equal to true so it's a
short way of writing the same thing
and uh now get the output the user
exactly but with the equal not operator
you can put
the exclamation mark
in front of our its active exp
expression and it's now now it's going
to negate this value now it's going to
change its value from True to false so
now if you run this code
not going to see the output the user is
not active because now this logical not
operator
switch is switching its value to false
so now this is going to be this will
evaluate to false it and it's going to
execute the else part that we have with
the user is not active and you can do
the same for a
false so if you put here false
now
let's actually
execute this without the logical not
operator to see what happens now this
will not execute so it will execute the
else part
so you see the user is not active but if
I put the logical not operator in front
of its active now it's going to change
its value from false to true and now
this will evaluate to true and it will
execute the
oh
code inside the calibration of the if so
now you see that it says the user is
active
so this is how you can use the logical
not operator to flip a value from false
to true or from True to false and you
can do this for for every Boolean
expression
that you use so you can put the logical
note operator in front of this
actually not in front of this
um you can put the logical not operator
generally speaking in front of any
Boolean expression right
so this is our discussion about
operators so in the next video we're
going to look how we can combine
multiple Expressions to create a bigger
expression which you sell for returns uh
true or false
value
see you in the next
alright so I deleted the code that we
had previously you can keep the code
that you have to use if you want but I
deleted to make things more clear
and in this video we're going to look at
how we can combine multiple Expressions
which in essence can return a Boolean
value which can be either true or false
and uh
let's start with the first
operator which is called The Logical end
operator but less vertical two variables
I'm going to declare a Val variable I'm
going to call it
it's playing
I'm going to sign a value of true sweet
so it's going to be of type Boolean
and on the next line I'm gonna declare
another variable also of all and it's
going to be called score
and it's going to have a value of 80.
now down here we'll type if
and inside the parenthesis to type is
playing
equals equals true so this is the equals
to operator I didn't then talk really a
lot about the equals operator but equals
to operator
checks to see if the two operands are
the same so it in contrast to the one
equal operator the one equal operator
assigns what's on the right to do our
variable which is on the left so in this
case assign truth or variable is playing
so or it's a sign 80 to a variable score
the equals the two equals or the request
operator is different because it checks
to see if uh what we have on the left or
what have on the left in and on the
right are the same or are identical next
and we know from the previous video that
you can abbreviate this you can write
this in a shorter way by putting just is
playing this will be this is going to be
equivalent to what you had producer
because as you can see it says that you
can simplify the Boon expression
and now
gonna you use the logical end operator
and use the logic logical end operator
with type 2 Ampersand science
and here we type score now I'm going to
use again the equals equals operator
this time we need to use it there is not
a shorter way to check for a
new type if score equals to 100.
all right
so this expression inside the pattern
this is going to evaluate to True only
if both
Expressions respective is playing and
score equals equals to 100 evaluates to
true so only if those two conditions
are true only then the code inside the
parenthesis inside the curly braces
actually is going to be executed so
let's say that in a real app here you
can add the logic to open the next level
but here we go just gonna output some
text so I'm going to type here
next level
opened right
and also I'm gonna add the else part
here
and we're gonna put
also printerland statement
and inside the part of this is going to
type
steel art
the same
level now if you run this code
you're going to see the output still at
the same level because
not those conditions are not both true
is playing is true but it's playing is
equal to true but our score is not equal
to 100 so this is going to evaluate to
false and the entire expression inside
the pattern is going to turn false so
it's going to execute Tails part
now if we change the order the value of
our variable score to 100 now both
expressions are true is playing equal to
true and score
and the score is equal to 100.
so now both of our expression are true
and gonna see the text Next Level opened
and I will see that it output the next
level opened
so this is The Logical end operator and
you're going to be using uh The Logical
and operator a lot in your
code
all right so now it's time to continue
our discussion about operators and going
to look at the next operator which can
be used to combine multiple expression
and that is the logical or operator and
the logological or operator evaluates an
expression or multiple expression in
this case to true if one of the
condition is true or if both conditions
are true so let's see an example of this
but first let's comment the code that we
have here because to make things
confusing
so go to code and select comment.light
command with line comment or you can
press the shortcut Ctrl slash
now let's equal to variables down here
the first the first is going to be a Val
I'm going to call it num1
I'm going to sign a value of 5 to it
second is going to be also Val it's
going to be called num2 and I'm going to
send a value of 3 to it or four
now I'm going to type the if Dental
statement I'm going to type the if
keyword inside the parenthesis I'm going
to put the condition first is if num1 is
greater than zero and now to use the
logical or operator we type two vertical
bars here
now we put our next condition or our
next expression and that is num2
is also greater than zero and we put a
curly brace press enter two
to add the right color base
and put also the else part
and inside the
calibrases of the if let's print some
text
let's say
the condition is true
all right now if you run this code
you're going to see the output the
condition is true because now both
conditions are true and The Logical
operator returns true if both conditions
are true or if one of the condition is
true so let's see if we change this to
-3
and now our second condition num2
greater than zero is false so now this
is also going to evaluate to true
because
The Logical operator returns through if
one actually with one of the
conditioners or if both Constructor so
now get conditional show but if you
change this to
also to -5 now our both both conditions
are false
now you're gonna see that it's gonna be
executed the daily spot because this
condition is going to be false because
both conditions both Expressions num one
greater than zero and num two greater
than zero are false all right so let's
change it back to five
now if you're on this code you're gonna
see
the condition is true because at least
one of the condition is true which is
this one normal and greater than zero
even though the number two condition is
false
all right and this is how you can use
the logical or operator
all right now it's time to see how we
can use the if Daniel statement as an
expression and that means that the if
Daniel statement can return a value
which can be stored in a variable so
let's see how you can do that
but first
actually skip this code that we have
here
and uh
to use the if Daniel statement as an
expression
we declare of
um
a variable first so I'm going to create
a Val
and let's give it a name I'm going to
call it let's say text
and to use the if then else statement as
an expression we put equals and after
the equals we put our if then else
statement
now
we need to assign a value to our
variable text to use it as an expression
and the value is going to be the last
expression in the in the curly braces so
here if I type the text let's say uh
this
is text
one
and
down here if I type
quotation marks this is text tool
now if I add a print Ln here at the end
and if I print the value of the variable
text that we declare above
let's put a dollar sign and if I type
text here
now you can see our variable it says
it's of type string
so if I run this code now
you're gonna see first this println
inside the curly braces which says the
condition is true
and
after that you're gonna see this text
being assigned to our variable text and
it will be output out output it down
here
by the printerline statement so you see
this is text
two actually I was wrong that condition
is false because it will have minus five
and minus three and this condition but
it's the false and the last the last
expression in the
in the curly braces is assigned as a
value to our variable now
uh
what you can also do is to remove the
curly braces but it's recommended to use
to not use the curly braces if you have
one only one statement uh
in your if Dental statement so let's
delete the printerland here let's delete
the curly brace here
let's also delete the calibrase here
let's delete the printerland statement
here and let's also delete the curly
berries here
so now this will work the same to work
like previously but uh
so now you'll see the same output
without the condition without this take
the control result because now we don't
have the printerline statement so now
get this text too because this condition
evaluates to false and it assigns this
value to our variable text then down
here it prints so
also you see that this uh they are not
aligned here this our variable and two
format your code you just go to code
and click reform reformat code or place
Ctrl alt L on Windows or you can um
use another shot you can use the
corresponding shortcut on Linux or Mac
so click on code
and now we're gonna see that our code is
formatted if you run this
now see this is text too but let's
change this to five
now this conditional overlay to true and
this expression is going to be is going
to be assigned or variable text so if we
run this
hmm
you're gonna see this now our variable
text is assigned the value of this is
text one because this condition is true
and inside this value to make things
more clear clear you can
use a
you can you can type your code something
like this
now this does there's everything is the
exact same thing as previously so if you
run this code now
you're gonna see that now this it says
the same thing this is text one
now you may be wondering what type this
variable is so if you hover over it this
is the it is of type string but look
what can I do I can put here a number
so if this condition evaluates to false
this is going to be assigned or variable
test so if I run this now
now get this text one and let's uh put
here -5 for the condition to be false
and if you run this code now
now I'm going to see five and you may be
wondering how this makes any sense
because
previously our variable was of type
string but if you have hover over here
now it says Vault text and the type is
this thing comparable anyway but what is
uh simply doing here is looking at the
condition it's looking first at the if
statement
and if this condition is true then it
assigns our text or variable and then it
infers the type to be a string right
if this condition is false then this
part is skipped and then it assigns this
value of 5 to our variable text and not
and then our variable is going to be of
type int so there is no case in which
both
value is going to be assigned to our
variable so this is why you can use here
text and here
an integer even though but if you
declare explicit here that this variable
is going to store only strings only
sequence of characters or text now he'll
get an earning because it says the
integral transforms the expected stream
so in other words we cannot put here
but a number because we said that
explains here that is going to store
only strings but if you omit the
type
that is gonna work
so you can decide not to
depending on the context what to choose
so this way of writing the internal
statement in one single line like we
have here it's okay as long as we use
the if the general statement as an
expression or in other words if you're
assigning a value to a variable like in
our case
but if you have multiple instruction you
know
also if you have a single single
instruction you can also omit the curly
braces but most of the time it's
recommended to use the curly braces
because that allows the those allows us
to execute more than on uh instruction
on the statement in your code and it
also makes the code more clear so let's
change this code
from an expression to just a new general
statement to
see why
so I'm going to change this
I'm going to add the curly braces
from other code press Ctrl
alt l
all right and low solution it is
let's delete this
text let's add to print Elena
statements here
foreign
now if you run this code
you're gonna see this part executed else
part because this condition is false
fault of our condition respectively num1
great is not greater than zero and
also num2 is also not greater than zero
so this is going to return false
and it's going to execute the else part
all right but now if you change this to
five and now one of the conditions is
going to be true and as you know this
entire expression is going to wait is
going to evaluate to true now because at
least one of the the expression is true
so if you run this code
now I see this condition is true and
also we see all our second printerland
statement this condition is running some
text
but look what happens uh
if I uh
let's say if I
delete the else part
right and if I delete the curly braces
here
all right
and now if I run this code
you see the now both statements are
executed but as I said if you don't use
curly braces you want just only one of
the
uh
statements in is going to be executive
so why you have both of these because
the first is if you executed as part of
the if statement because this one is
true and the next one is executed
because it's part of the code because
it's red from top to bottom but if
I change this to false and now I want
both condition both statements
respectively with this one and this one
to not be executed look what happens
now get this condition experience on
text so the first
instruction in our if the next element
is omitted because it's part of the if
the statement but the second one it's
executed because it's part of the code
so it's going to be red anyway so this
is why you need to always use curly
braces in this way
the entire code is also is gonna be
either executed or omitted so this is
our discussion about the external
statement and you should always use the
curly braces and for this part you also
you should use the curly braces
and um
only omit the calibrations if you have
only single one single statement or one
single expression if you want to use uh
leave the statement as an exception to
assign a value to a variable but if you
have just one single statement let's say
you have something like this
economy the curly braces like this
so now you can see that everything works
fine
so you can use it like this if you have
one single statement like we have here
you just print some text to our console
or if you use it as an expression so if
you
sort of value in a variable
so see you in the next video
all right now it's time to look at the
next control flow statement that you can
use in kotlin besides the the if Daniel
statement and that is the when statement
or the one expression but first let's
create a new project
I'm going to call it Ctrl flow
it should be in Pascal case
select IntelliJ click on next and finish
right now let's delete the code inside
the curly braces
let's hide the project Pane and let's
first declare a variable it's going to
be a Val
it's going to be called
alarm and I'm gonna assign a value of 12
to it
now to to declare when statement we type
here when
we put parenthesis and inside the
parentheses we put
our argument in this case is our
variable alarm
next
put space and we put the curly braces
press enter and now we put the
expression here so here I'm going to put
the value let's say 12.
now I'm going to put a minus sign and a
greater than sign so I have this Arrow
and here I'm gonna type print Ln this is
the code that is going to be executed
so and I'm gonna type the time is
dollar sign
alarm
let's press Ctrl D to duplicate this
two times
or three times
and let's change the last one to one
else
all right
let's change those values here to
and 14.
now let's run this code to see what to
get in the output and after that we're
going to discuss our code
so getting the output the time is 12 and
we get that because what is what the
when statement is doing
it's using this argument that we passed
here in this case it's our variable
called alarm
and it's comparing this uh the value of
this argument with all the branches that
we have here respectively it's going to
compare it with the expression that we
have on the left because on the left we
have the expression
the this Arrow sign is gonna is is uh
saying execute execute this code on the
right
if this expression on the left is true
in this case if our Allah alarm equals
equals 12 and it's true we have a value
of 12 so this branch is executed and it
executes the code on the right which is
this this the alarm is 12 but if I
change this to 7 now
and if I run this code
I'm going to see the time is seven and
if I change this to
let's say
13.
and here we have no 13 Dallas part is
going to be executed similar to our if
Daniel statement
you know get the time is 13. so it was
it was executed the else part now now
and we can combine those uh Expressions
by putting a colon and and we can
combine them and putting them on on one
single line so I can put here colon
I can type here
seven
and fourteen now
I'm gonna delete those two
now it will check to see if our alarm
argument has the value either 12
or 7 or 14. so
um let's change it to 14 to see
so now if you run this code you're gonna
see that
this will evaluate to true and this code
on the right is going to be executed so
again the time is 14. and if I change
this to 7
again this level is true because one of
those expressions show so yeah the time
is seven
all right
what you can do next is we can check to
see if a number is in a certain range so
we can put another
another expression here and and here I
can type
in
the in keyword is used to check to see
if numbers is to see if a number is in a
certain range and to declare a range we
type
the range let's say that I want to check
from
let's say uh
one
from one to ten we put two dots dot dot
10. now what this is gonna do is gonna
check to see if our alarm argument in
the in this in this case our alarm
variable is in the range from 1 to 10.
now I'm gonna put a minus sign and a
gray and a greater than sign to have the
arrow and here I'm going to type the
code that I want to be executing in this
case it's just a printerland statement
and I'm gonna type
the number
is in
the range
1.7
now if you run this is only from here
we get the time is seven because uh
the first branch is checked and this
branch is true and uh in effect it
executes the code on the right and the
next branches are left offs are not
executed to and to change that let's put
this first so let's copy this
now if you run this code
now get the number is in range one two
ten and it's true our seven is in the
range from 1 to 10. what you can do is
also you can use the logical not
operator so I can put here
The Logical not operator which is an uh
exclamation mark
and this now will negate this value so
if you run this code now you'll get the
output 7. the time is seven so now we
get the output
the time is seven because this this
switch is this value from True to false
and execute this uh part
now
let's delete this
what I can also do is that we can put
curly braces so I can put curly braces
press enter
the same here
and
here
also
and it's recommended to use the
calibrases only if you have multiple
statements in your code in our case we
have one one single statement which is
this printerland which outputs some text
to the console and the the when
statement as I said can be used as an
expression so I can type here a Val
let's say your text and I can assign the
when expression to our text variable now
we need to give back a value to our text
so instead of printing this text I can
delete this
let's put it like this
now the last expression in our block of
code which is now we have a single
expression but you have multiple
Expressions say that we have here
another print Ln
let's say some text
so similar to our if then else
expression the last line of code the
last expression is going to be assigned
to our variable text now let's print
this down here
torque console so let's type println
and let's put director here text
now if you run this code
now I'm gonna see the text the number is
in the range you want to
10 because it checks to see if this
expression on the left is true then it
executes the car the code inside the
curly braces which is this expression
and because now we're using the one as
an expression it assigns this expression
this text or variable text then it
outputs that value with the print line
down here in our console so you get the
number is in the range one two
10. all right now but what if I want to
put here a less than sign so you what if
I want to put here if
is less than seven our alarm argument I
can do that the only way to do that is
by uh let's delete this now let's put
seven
not here
let's press Ctrl alt L to format the
code all right
now the only way to put a greater than
sign or less than sine or greater than
equal or greater or less than equal sign
is to delete the argument here but let's
first delete the curly braces to make
things more clear
so let's delete the curly braces
let's delete this now because here we
have two lines of course so we need to
use curly braces this is why I deleted
the penalion there and again you should
always use curly braces if you have
multiple lines of code but in our case
we have a simple line of code which is
the text on the right which is going to
be assigned to our variable text and
it's going to be output in the console
so always use highly braces if you have
multiple lines of code all right all
right now this is more concise and more
clear and let's say that I want to check
to see if our alarm is less than say 10.
um to do that we need to delete the
argument here
all right and now what can I do is I can
put here
our
alarm variable and here I can put less
than
or equal to 10. so now here we have a
Boolean expression on the left
sorry
so now we have a Boolean expression here
on the left
and this will check to see if our alarm
or variable alarm alarm has a value
Which is less than or equal to 10 which
is true we have a 7 here so now if you
run this call
but let's delete this because we need to
have now Boolean expression here because
here we cannot uh here we have just
literal types so here I need to put
let's say if let's type alarm
equals equals
or two vertical bars
alarm
equals equals
seven
so now if you run this code
now you get the output the numbers in
the range 1 to 10. because now this on
the this expression on the left is true
and it executes this text uh
it assigns this expression to our
variable text and it prints down here
the that value so you get here the
number is already one to ten
but uh
this condition is also true so if I swap
those two so if I put this one below
because as I said if one uh one of the
expression evolution true the next ones
the the one which are below so this in
this case this one is true or not be are
not going to be executed are skipped it
only executes this code and the
subsequent ones are omitted so let's put
this
below
it's good to remember this
so now if you run this code
now get the time is seven because now
this level is true even though this
below is also true because our alarm is
less than seven because this available
is too true it executes the code which
is on the right which is assigning this
expression to our text and then it
leaves the one expression it's not going
uh down to execute the next one so it
breaks uh like there and it stops it
actually stops right there and it's not
executing the next branch
so this is our discussion about the when
statement statement and the one
expression see you in the next video
now it's time to start a discussion
about null ability in kotlin but first
i'm going to create a new project I'm
going to call it null
make sure to have the language
culturally select it and for the build
system IntelliJ also make sure to have
the jdk selected here and I'm gonna
check this little box to generate the
main function for us and that code that
comes with the main function so I'm
going to click on create to create a new
project
now our project is going to be great in
a short moment
so we got our project created and we get
a log you get our main function Auto
generated here for us because we check
that box so I'm gonna delete this
because I don't need this code
and I'm going to hide the project pane
so what is a null value a null value is
basically when you assign to a variable
nothing synthetically speaking you
assign null to it but what that means is
that you have a variable which has no
value which has no memory reference and
if you try to do some other arithmetic
operation with that variable you're
getting an impossible scenario where you
have nothing try to do some work and
that will throw a null pointer exception
and this is particularly bad because the
null pointer exceptions are only thrown
at runtime and not at compile time so
you could have your program working well
and having no problems and at some point
you try to I don't know press a button
and somehow somehow that
pressing of the button is using that
variable which has another value and
then it's going to throw an old normal
pointer exception and your app will
crash
and kotlin aims to avoid the and to
eliminate the null pointer exceptions
and null values that is not to say that
we can't have a null value in a kotlin
but is very hard to have one so let's
see why so what cotton has done to make
null values and implicitlyn all
pointerizations very hard to get
it first made all its styles by default
non-nullable and that means that you
cannot assign null to it so if I declare
here a variable called text I'm going to
declare the type explicitly so it's
going to be a string
and if I assign null so to assign Alto
where we'll just type the null and we
have the null cured
we can't because this variable by
default and all the variables by default
are non-nullable and that means that you
cannot assign a value so if you hover
over this underline it says null cannot
be a value of a non null type string but
what if I want to assign null to it what
you if I want to have null for some
reason
in that case you go at the end of the
type and you put question mark and that
means that now you have a nullable type
that means that you can assign null to
this variable so if I put question mark
here
now I can assign null to this variable
so this is
how we can assign an altar variable by
putting the question mark at the end of
the type because that is saying to the
compiler hey I'm gonna let I'm gonna let
me to assign now to this variable so
to avoid that underwriting red now if I
try to print this so if I put here print
line
and I put here text
what do you think we're getting the
output
and output to get null you know you
don't get null pointer exception so now
if I hide this and let's say that I want
to get the length of let's say of the
text so let's say that I assign here
some text
well actually let's put the name here
name
unless and if I try to get the length
here so if I put here
dot length
I have an underline
which says only save and we have this
question mark that or not or asserted
and have this this operator Cults are
allowed on a nullable receiver of type
string so it's saying that we can
we can only get because you this this
variable can have a null value but we
know that it doesn't but the compiler is
saying to us because we said that this
can have null is saying to check first
that this variable is not equal to null
and then try to get its length and let's
do that in the Long Way first so let's
delete this
so Alex actually just copy this
and we type if
we put parenthesis if
text not equal to null
then I'm gonna output this one we're
then going to get its length so we're
gonna type here text
not the length so now that the compiler
is happy because it's it's uh it's
ensure that is not gonna have no because
we checked here especially that this
variable uh should have you should not
have null in order to get the length so
now if I run this
I get four so this is the length so we
have four letters here and I go I can
also add the else part
which is which is gonna say
the very
well it's not so if the variable is not
the else part is going to be called
so now if you run this
will get also four but I'm gonna assign
I'm gonna reassign this variable so I'm
gonna change it to VAR first
so we put here VAR
and put here text equals null so now our
variable is null and this check is going
to fail and it's gonna execute the else
part so if I run this code
so we get the variable is null because
now on the
on the third line we assign nullity so
this if fails and is executed there spot
but as you can see it's a lot of code
just to check to to check and imagine if
you have multiple variables to check to
always check for this that the variable
is not normal then print its length and
there is a shorter way in kotlin to do
that and we saw as a suggestion how to
do that previously so if I press Ctrl Z2
um undo our code so if I press still
pressing now if I hover over this error
that we had previously which says
only save call so and you have this
operator and this is called the
safe call operator and if I put here
just a question mark
this is equivalent to having if which is
checking to see if the length is null if
and if the length is null then it's
going to say null or and if it's not
null it's gonna just output four so now
if I run this so this is equivalent to
the if that if the the if statement that
you had previously so you have four
so what if I should and if I assign null
so if I type here let's change this to
vardy First
so if I assign here text equals
null
we'll simply get null
we get null but what if I want to get
that null pointer exception for whatever
reason what can I do well the compiler
or it helping is helping us also there
so because if I delete that save call
Operator which is just a question mark
that and that is basically saying
hey if this text is not null then output
in the console then get then get the
length and then output that in the
console if it's null just say no so this
is how the save call Operator works but
if I delete this as you can see there is
another
operator and is
and is this operator which is uh two
exclamation marks and this operator is
basically saying
hey if this variable has null then throw
that exception but if it's not null just
output don't just output the length so
if I put two exclamation marks here
but for whatever reason it's not the our
text that length is not getting the
length and I think this this is because
we assign to our text variable here null
it it can't it has a prep it has a pro a
problem with inferring what type this
variable is even though here is saying
that it's a string so we should
we should be able to call that length
and to avoid this you just put null at
uh when you declare the variable so we
assign here null
so we put here null
now if you run this because you have the
two inflammation Mark operator now this
will throw that null pointer accession
that I talked about
so we get exception thread main so it
doesn't matter what trademark is now I'm
gonna you get Javas like the null
pointer exception so this is the
the null pointer exception but if we
assign down here this variable text
equals
some text
and now if we run this code
you get nine because this is the length
of this so
this is how you can use this operator
the next operator that you can use is
the Elvis operator and to show you how
that works I'm going to delete this code
now I'm going to declare another
variable up here so I'm going to call it
text two
we put equals and we type text
now to use the Elvis operator we put a
question mark and the colon
and now we need to uh
type something on the right of the
office operator so we put here some text
I'm going to explain immediately how
this works so I'm gonna type here
some
text
now what the Elvis operator is doing is
saying
if this variable text is null then
assign what is on the right to this
variable text to
if this variable text is not null then
assign what is to this variable to our
variable text to our variable text to
and now let's uh
let's type here text too
and less the little length
so now if you run this code
let's actually put something more
discrete like
the variable
null
so if you run this code now
we get a variable is null because
it checked to see to to see if this
variable on the left is null and if it
is if it is now it's gonna it assigned
this to to a variable takes two and then
I'll put that in the console
but if this is not null then it's gonna
assign what is on this would what do
whatever value this variable has to or
variable takes two so if now I put here
text equals
this variable is not null
now if I run this
now this well this will evaluate to true
so it's gonna
assign whatever value is on the left or
variable text to a variable text to and
we're going to see in the output the
variable is not null so we want a
variable to X2 has now the value
assigned from our for each variable so
this is the shorter way of writing let
me show you how we will write this in
the longer way so you in the longer way
you will have something like this so
let's delete this quad
actually
yes let's delete this quad
will have a variable called
text
tool and
it's gonna have an empty string
so we would what we will have to do
without the Elvis operator we have to
first check if text
not equal to
is not equal to null
then I'm gonna call our variable a text
to
and we're gonna assign a text to it
else
we're going to assign to our text to
variable the text
this variable is null so this is the
longer where we're doing of what we did
previously so if I press Ctrl Delta
format of code now if you run this
you'll see the the same amount of the
variable is not null
so we get a variables not now and this
is the longer way of doing the same
thing so if I assign here
if I assign actually if I delete this
and the variable will have null
let's press Ctrl Z
if I run this
foreign
part is executed so our variable takes
two it will be it will have the thesis
variable this variable is null that
takes assigned to it and then it's going
to Output that in the console so this is
the longer I was doing what was of what
we had previously so if I press Ctrl Z
to have the Elvis operator back
so that was the longer way of doing what
of what you're doing here in one simple
line of code
so this is our discussion about nullable
types and uh I hope that you got a lot
from this video and see you in the next
video
right now it's time to start a
discussion about functions but first
let's create a new project and I'm going
to speed up the process now a little bit
because we already did this a few times
so I'm gonna call it functions should be
in Pascal case
select IntelliJ click on next and click
finish
all right let's delete the code inside
the curly braces
let's hide the project Pane and let's
start by saying that until now we have
written our code only inside the main
function and occasionally we have called
The Print line function to Output some
code to the console but as I said at the
beginning of our videos you can create
your own functions in kotlin so let's
see how we can do that so go down here
at the end of our main function at the
end of our enclosing curly brace
and to declare the function we type the
keyword fun
we put space next we need to give a name
to our function and the name of the
function should say what the function is
doing and generally it's a verb I'm
going to call this function say hello
and it should be in camera case next you
put parenthesis because functions can
take input to work with it
and next you put
curly braces because this is what we're
going to put our
instructions for our statements this is
going to put our logic now let's add the
print Elena statement here
foreign
and now let's run this code
now
as the input we don't see nothing here
because if you hover this say hello
function it says
function say hello is never used because
in order for that this in order for this
function to be used you need to call it
from main function and to call it from a
function we type here
the name of the function you can type it
entirely you or you can type start
typing you know IntelliJ is going to be
it's going to give you some suggestions
so press enter to fill and fill in that
video and also press Ctrl alt L to
format the code
now let's run our code
now you're gonna see that it says in the
output hello because the main function
executes in what's inside the curly
braces and uh on the line two it sees
that we have a function that we're
calling here a function executes it
executes the the say hello function the
code inside the say hello function in
this case it's a simple printl and a
statement and then it outputs that to
the console and it acts as the
the code it finishes the process because
you don't have anything else below for
say hello but what we can do is put
another say hello here to call our
function again and now we're gonna see
the output
hello two times because now we're
calling the say hello function
first on the line two and second the
line three so it will be executed two
times so you can see that in this wave
functions are reusable
and are separate chunks of code okay
which can be can be reused and you'll
see that they can be used in specific
cases now
as I said functions can take input and
to make a function to receive some input
we need to Define what is called the
parameter and to define a parameter we
type the name of the variable first I'm
going to call it name
and we need to explicitly provide the
type here
so for the type I'm going to choose
string and we need to explicitly provide
a type here because is there there is no
way for the type to be inferred here
because uh
the value that you're gonna pass to this
say hello function is going to be here
so it's impossible to know to what the
kind of value are we going to pass to it
so this is why you need to explicitly
say what data this parameter or this
variable is going to store so let's
delete this second say hello
now
let's change the text that I have here
in the println Let's uh
let's refer the parameter name so put a
dollar sign and start typing name
and you can see that has this P4
parameter and press enter now what is
going to happen now is that this say
hello function is going to be called
it's going to be executed from our main
function
and the code inside the say hello
functions is also going to be executed
and specifically it's going to execute
this uh this uh text that we type here
to be outputted it's going to execute
the hello and then it is going to
execute uh what what value if we have
passed
as an argument for this parameter and uh
if you don't know what an argument is
the argument is the value that you pass
to the
um
to the function so in this case up here
we need to pass
some text so I'm going to put the name
here
not here
it should be in a double rotation marks
and you see that we have a hint here
which says which is which says the name
of the very of the name of the parameter
which is name now what is going to
happen now is this this say hello
function is going to be called
and this value that we passed here is
going to be used in our println
statement where where
we're referring now which is uh here you
here we're using the name and it's going
to use that value and that value is
going to be outputted down here and
let's run the code to say
now get Hello Alex because now it's
using the value that you pass here as
the as an argument to the parameter name
and it's using that value down here
where a
we type the printerland statement or
function now functions can take multiple
arguments multiple arguments and to do
that we need to Define
I should say that you can Define more
parameters for the function and a
function contain multiple arguments and
to Define another parameter
we put the
comma here
and we type the name of our parameter is
going to be age and we need to provide
the type and I'm going to provide the
type as anything yet because as an
integer because it's going to store
whole numbers
and
you're gonna put an exclamation mark and
I'm going to type your
age is now we need to refer the
parameter age and
also need to provide the value for that
parameter
now if you go up here now it says that
you need to provide a value for the
parameter has age it says no value pass
from for the parameter a so here you
need to type on a value for our
parameter that we Define so let's say
22. all right now if you run this code
now those parameters that we Define here
are going to use the values the argument
that we type here inside the our
curly braces or
how it's often called the body of the
function or the code block so it's going
to use the values here and here
now another important thing to know is
that you can not change the value of a
parameter so if you type here age equals
let's say
30.
not gonna if you hover over here because
you have an underline it says Val cannot
be reassigned because those parameters
are are declared as valves as variables
false so that means that they are
immutable we cannot change their values
the only way to use the variable which
can have is value changes to declare on
so if you declare here a variable I'm
going to declare it as a VAR to change
this value I'm going to call it number
and if I
assigning healer value of 50 now I
as you know you can change now his value
to let's say 70.
and you can also assign the
parameter here
to our variable number and now we can
change its value because input number
and can put another value here
all right
another important thing to know is that
this variable that we Define here also
the parameters are scoped inside the
function say hello in other words they
cannot be referred or accessed outside
of the calibration of the say hello
function so if I try to access that
number variable here
is not working
if I try to access access here on the
main function let's say type number
I can because it's scoped inside the say
hello function it exists only inside the
say hello function the same thing with
the parameters age
or a name
so
in this way you can see that functions
can be very useful because they are
chunks of code which are reusable and
flexible and
to see an example with this let's
declare another function down here let's
call it the
let's type the fun key or let's call it
get data
and this function is going to mimic the
real function in a real app which can
get some data from the internet of
course that you're not going to get some
other internet but we're gonna uh mimic
that behavior so here I'm gonna Define a
parameter let's call it data and for the
type let's choose string right
let's put the curly braces and here
let's add the print Ln segments and here
you're gonna print
your data is
and
I'm gonna refer the parameter data
all right now what I can do up here is
to define a Boolean variable it's going
to be a Val I'm going to call it has
internet
connection I'm going to assign a value
of true to it
now I can put an if statement here now I
can check to see if that
expression is true so I can put TV
equals true or
use the shortcut because it's better
here I'm going to put the early braces
and now I'm gonna call the get data
function only if this condition is true
so in our case it's true the but in a
real lab that can be can be false so in
that case you can do something else as
you can assume we're gonna let's also
other else part here
and here we're gonna call another
function which can which is going to be
called in the case that there is no
internet connection all right so
above here you can personal logic to get
the data from the internet well because
this is a simple example gonna type here
directly
some text let's put some data
and uh for the else part in the case
that there is no internet connection
that variable is false we can declare
another function down here
to oh and I'm going to call it fun
show
message
and this is not gonna have any
parameters it's gonna have only simple
println statement
and it's going to say that uh
there is no
internet
connection
all right so now let's go up here now
and now we're gonna call
the
show message function
in the else part
now if you run this code
you're gonna see
Hello Alex which is our first function
up here on the line tool your age is 22
and next to see your data is some data
because it executes the say hello
function then it declares this variable
and it checks it checks to see if this
condition is true and this condition is
true and it executes this function get
data so this is why you get your data is
some data but if for whatever reason the
user has no internet connection let's
say you assign a value false to it
to this
now this function is going to be called
show message
so this function show message now is
called and the code inside the show
message function is called which is
printerland with this sprinterland
standard which says there is one
technical connection area lab you can
have some logic to show a dialogue that
there is no internet connection and you
can see that in this way with functions
you can divide your
code in different chunks of
different different chunks of code which
can be called in very specific cases so
in this case
we only call our functions only in in
the case that we have internet
connection or in the case that we don't
have internet connection so in this way
we have divided our code in different
chunks of code which can be called in
different uh specific scenarios and in
this way
we can write a program because if you
just put your code all of your code in
the main function and you execute that
code from top to bottom you you cannot
create a program like that so this was
an additional discussion with the get
data and show message and I hope that
I'm not confused you a lot so see in the
next video
all right so in the last video we've
seen how we can create functions how we
can call our functions how we can Define
parameters to our functions how can send
the data to our function as arguments
now it's time to see how we can return
some data from a function but let's
first read the code that we have here
to make things more clear
and the code inside the function the
main function
all right now let's
Define another function I'm going to
type the fan keyword space and it's
going to be called get Max
and this function is going to return the
maximum of uh two integers
so I'm gonna Define here a parameter I'm
going to call it a in a real aperture
those more descriptive names
is going to be of type int and the next
one is going to be called B and it's
going to be also of type int
I'm gonna put the
curly braces and I'm going to press
enter
now to get the maximum value between
these two numbers we type here we have
here Val
Max
and here we type an if expression so we
type if
a
greater than b
then we're going to assign a to our Max
variable else
I'm going to sign B and in the case that
the two numbers are equal B is going to
be assigned to our
Max
variable
now in order to return this uh to in
order to return this
value to our function we need first to
to say to the function what kind of data
is going to return and to do that go
here at the enclosing parenthesis and if
you don't have spaces here or you
wondering about how to
have the proper formatting you just
press Ctrl alt L and the code is going
to be formatted all right and here we
put a colon
and here we we Define why what type of
data this function is going to return
and in this case it's going to be an
integer so we put in here
and this is similar to The Way We
declare a type for a variable now
if you could if you go down here now you
see that it says
a return expression is required in a
function to block body so now we need to
return this uh
now you need to return some data that we
Define here in this case we need to
return an integer and to return the
maximum value to our function we type
here return the keyword return
and our value which is our variable Max
and press enter
now if you call this function in our
main function
get Max and now let's also press Ctrl
alt L to format the code
and here we let's say that we type two
arguments for our parameters let's say
that put five
and nine now if you run this code
now you're gonna see in the output
nothing because uh in order to
in order to get this value need to
retain this value to capture this value
in a variable and to do that we Define a
variable in front of our get Max
function it's also be a Val
I'm going to call it Max
and we're going to assign the get Max
function to our variable and that is
going to return
or a maximum number
now you now you may see that you have
two names we have the same name here in
the same and that is not a problem
because this variable marks that we have
inside the
the get Max function exists on inside
the the get Max function is scoped only
here this is why you can use the same
name here so if I try to type here also
Max to declare variable which is going
to be called Max I can't because
it says completed declaration because if
you
because the compiler doesn't know if you
assign a value let's say to this it will
not know what variable to to to call
because you have the same name but uh
up here is not a problem because this is
in the block of the main function so it
exists only here and this exists only
here now
we have called our get Max function and
this function is going to return the
maximum of these two values which is
nine now we need to print this value not
console and to print this value just
type here println
and we're referring our
Max variable
now if you run this code
you're gonna get nine because uh our get
Max function is called the two the two
arguments are passed to our function
then the code inside the auto get Max
function it's executed it Compares these
two two numbers and if a is greater than
b then it assigns eight or Max
a Max variable or it's gonna if that is
not true is going to assign the value of
B and then it returns that max value to
the to the function which is called so
if this function returns that value here
and and here we retain we capture that
value which is returned from the get Max
function our Max variable and then we
print that Max variable with our println
function or a statement and then we see
the output in our console 9 right
another important thing to know is that
after we type the return call or the
return keyword the
the function is lift the function is
stopped there so if we add the
other text here let's say we add here a
printerland
and we type here some text
we see that this is highlighted and it
says
that is this is a reachable code because
after we typed our return marks our
function is
stopped is lived and it's not executing
any any code below of of that return
color or of that return keyword right
another important thing that you can do
with the return keyword is that you can
return from a function without returning
any kind of value and in that case it
will have the same effect and that means
that it will leave the function right
there even though we don't return any
kind of value so we I can type here
return but let's uh
the list here the type
because now it's expecting a value to be
returned and now this will have the same
effect it will leave the function right
there and it will not execute any any
kind any line of code below of our
return keyword so if I type here
a println statement
and I put some text here
as you can see this has the same effect
if you type the return keyword in your
function it will stop the execution of
the function and every line of code
below of the return keyword is not going
to be executed so it's very good to know
this also
another important thing to know is that
you can we can only return a single
value with the return keyword so we
cannot return here to two integers let's
say and also we cannot have two returns
in the same function let's say if I put
here also return marks
I can't because this is also a reachable
code but I I can have two returns
two returns calls if they are rich in
different branches so if I change this
if expression to an if
statement so if I type something like
this
if let's say
a greater than b
let's add the curly brace now
we type here
return
a
else
return B
so now we have two returns but they are
never reached together
they are they are always reached
separately so this is why you can use
here two returns because they said they
are rich always separately so if you run
this code you're gonna see the same
output
so you C9 so this is another way to to
write the same thing that we had
previously that but it's recommended to
use a
to use uh what we had previously because
with uh specifically it's better to have
enough expression
another way to to write to the same
thing but in a more concise way and
let's undo the code that we have that
you had previously
so let's press Ctrl Z
so now I have the code that help briefly
now if you hover over over this Max it
says variable use only in formatting
return can be in line so if you click
here in line variable
now this thing does the same thing that
it it was doing previously but this is a
shorter way to write the same thing so
now it returns a if this condition is
true otherwise else part the else part
is called and it returns B so we have
the same thing but
written in a shorter way
all right another way to write the same
thing that we have here is by using what
is called the single expression function
and to do that we can remove the curly
braces
we can put our code up here
you can remove the first curly brace and
you can also remove the return keyword
and here you put equals
and this now does the same thing that
the code
the previous code that was doing but
this is a more concise way and it's
recommended to use this only if you know
that you know you have in your function
a single expression or in other words if
you know that you have a single line of
code and you can also remove the type
here because the type can be being
inferred
and again only use this if you know that
you have in your function a single line
of code and in that case you can you can
skip the return keyword but if you have
multiple lines of code you should always
use the curly braces and the return
color the return keyword
all right so this is our discussion
about how we can return a value from a
function
all right so now let's continue a
discussion about functions and now it's
time to look at what is called function
overloading and let's say that I want
here to pass not to integer types but
two doubles to be compared so let's say
that type here 6.5
and 9.6
now this will not work because it's
defined here explicit that the
parameters are of type int so we cannot
pass here double
and a solution to this it may be to
create another function the different
name and to define the parameters as
doubles but that does not make a lot of
sense because
we we are doing the exact same thing so
does not make sense to create a new to
create a function with a different name
so
what you can do instead is to
let's change it back to integers
is to duplicate this get Max function
and do that you can press Ctrl D or
command line on Mac some press I'm going
to press Ctrl D here
now what I can do is change the types of
the variables so I can put here instead
of integer I put double
and here I can put also double
let's add the space to make things more
clear now if I pass here
let's say your 5.6
and 9.7 now you see that we have an
error
so if you run this code
all right so we get in the output 9.7
and this is called this uh is bigger
than 0.5 or 6 but now it's using the
second function which is the function
which has the parameters as of type
double and you can see that this
function now which is using the
parameters as integers is gray out
because the compiler can figure out what
function to use by the argument types we
pass here so in this case we pass here
doubles and it knows that it has to use
this function which has the types which
has the parameters Define as type of
double right
another way to overload the function is
to best also press Ctrl d
is by changing the number of parameters
so I can put here let's say
also integer
also releases so let's pass another the
third parameter now and this is also
going to be an integer it's going to be
called C
gonna be of typing
all right now let's change this logic to
any statement so let's delete the if
expression let's put the curly braces
all right so let's change this now
so you can type it here now if a greater
than equal
to be
and a is greater than equal to to C then
I'm going to return a
so now we're using the return keyword
else if now
putting here an lcf
B
is greater than equal to a and
B is greater than equal
to C
then return B
else C is going to be the bigger value
so put here return C
all right let's press Ctrl
alt return B here
right so I need to put here the type
this will get that error right now
everything is okay
oh so from here is the problem
all right so now
if you run this code let's change this
to let's say
five
seven
and 10.
now if you run this code
you see that the two functions above our
big gray out
and I was going to use the third one
which has third parameters
all right so when you get to get in the
output 10 which is correct so if you
change this to test let's say if we put
here
let's put here
three and if you run this code
now we get 100 and this is correct
all right so this is our discussion
about function overloading and you can
use function overloading every time you
know that you will do the same task but
with different type of parameters or
with a different number of parameters
also you may have noticed that we have
another line over uh over if over the
statement so if you hover over here
says that the return can be lifted out
if so if you click this
you can write it in this way so or we
can keep it in the
previous way but because this is uh
underline that means that kotlin
recommends to use it in this way
in this way
so see you in the next video what we're
going to talk about default parameters
all right so now it's time to look at
another features that you can use with
functions and that is called default
parameters and let's first declare a
function
so I'm going to declare it down here at
the end of our enclosing curly brace for
main fun I'm going to call it send
message
let's put the parenthesis and inside the
parenthesis I'm going to Define two
parameters the first is going to be
called name it's going to be of type
string
and this second one is going to be
called the
message and it's going to be also of
type string
now let's uh
you take the cloud the curly braces
press enter and let's print those
parameters in our console so let's put
the printer line here and inside the
also uh while I'm typing while I'm
pumping this printable anime since that
this println function is a function
which is overload referring to our
previous video because you can see that
it can it has the same name but it can
take different types of parameters here
so it has in this thing which is any
bytes or Char long so the print element
5 function that you've used throughout
our videos is overloaded this is why you
can pass different uh
different types of of data to it now
let's type here
println
quotation marks inside the quotation
mark we're going to type name equals
dollar sign name
so now it's going to print the
argument values that are going to pass
to this function as parameters now let's
call this function here
so let's type send
message to
format our code and here I'm going to
pass a name let's say
Alexa and
the message let's say
hello
now if you run this code you're going to
see in the output
um the name here is going to be this
argument that we type here which is
Alexa and the message is gonna be hello
so we have this but let's say that for
whatever reason the user doesn't want to
to send any kind of message but we still
need to use this function what you can
do then
one way is to remove this parameter all
the way but uh that is not the
good because you still need to use this
function with those two parameters the
name and and the message so you know
let's say that if the user doesn't pass
any message we can Define here what is
called the default
param a default parameter so what you
can assign here a default value for our
parameter so I'm going to put here uh
just the double quotation marks or
or you can put some text here but let's
put just the double quotation marks
which is just an empty text so if now I
don't pass a message here
now we're still gonna work because as a
value for this parameter is going to use
the default value that we defined here
all right so let's run this code to see
now
how it works
so now get name Alexa and message equals
empty because m double quotation marks
without any text is an empty text now if
I want to pass here now
the message now you can pass here the
message
and now our default value is going to be
replaced with the argument value that we
typed here
so now I'm going to see name Alexa
message hello
all right you can do the same thing for
uh for the name so here you can Define
let's say that the user doesn't want to
to type a name and we can define a
default name let's say user
yes
now let's say that I delete both
arguments here
and I just have an empty
function if I run this now it's going to
use the default values that you type
here respectively user and this empty
string so now get name user and message
now let's put back what we have so let's
put here
Alexa
let's put our message here again
now let's run this code again
now what we can also do is use what is
called named parameters and let's say
that I want to
to pass a parameter only for the second
second let's let's say that I want to
pass the argument type for only for the
second parameter that we Define here
respectively for our message
so if I delete this now I'll say let's
say that I delete the
the argument for our name
and if I want to pass the value only for
the message
let's put in the quotation mark because
the string
let's say I put the message hello here
now you can see that the hint is named
so it's using the first parameter that
we Define here another second so what we
can do now to pass a value to only to
our second parameter because as you can
see it's using the it's assigning this
value that we type here for this
parameter and to solve that you can use
what is called the name parameters so
with name parameters you can type an
argument for our parameter irrespective
of the order in which they are defined
so in our case we have the name for
Define and then the message so to use
that you can
type the name of the parameter let's say
message now you see that you have this P
message and it's equals to A String so
that means that you need to pass some
text here
and now we can pass here
hello
and now this is gonna work because now
we can pass a value to our parameter
irrespective of the water in which they
are defined here
right so now I get name is this default
user and the message is hello and we can
do the same for uh
for the second one which is name so I
can put now here name
and I can type here
let's say Alexa
and if you run this
now get Alexa
is the name and the message is hello so
with the named parameters this is how
they are called a name arguments we can
pass the value
to our
parameters irrespective of the order in
which they are defined in the function
so in our case name is first defined and
you saw that that when I try to use a
the message to assign a value only for
the message it's what it was using the
first parameter because this was the
word in which they were defined
but with this named parameters you can
change you can you can type an argument
irrespective of the word in which they
are defined and you can put this in a
multiple lines to make it more clear
like this let's say
so this is our discussion about
named parameters and the default
parameters but before we win the video I
should say that to the default
parameters we cannot only type literals
values like we typed here some values
directly we can use variables or you can
use a function which can return a value
so I can Define here a function let's
say fun
send the
text it's not going to have any
parameters it's gonna return a string so
I'm going to Define here a string as the
type of return and here gonna type
return and let's type some
text
now we can call this function here send
and now this value which is returned for
this function send text is going to be
assigned to our parameter message so now
if you run this code
Let's uh increase this a little bit
so now if you run this code you're going
to see that the Now the default value
for the part method message is the
return value from our send text function
so you can see now that we have
okay so let's change it here to no value
for our message
so now if you run this code because
there we have an argument passed so
let's not passing on the northwest so
now it's using the value that we was was
passed as the default
value for our parameter which is this
return value from this function
now because here you have one single
line of code we have one single
expression we just return some text or
function we don't have multiple
statements in our function we can write
this as a single expression function
and you can remove the calibration you
can write this as a single expression
body like we did in a previous video so
you can put it just equals and you can
remove the
type here also so if you run this code
now I'm gonna see it to the output for
the parameter message some text which is
the value which is returned from this
function from the single body expression
function right
so see in the next video
all right now it's time to look at the
VAR Arc keyword and how we can use the
water keyword with functions but first
let's declare the function below of our
enclosing
calibrase of our main function so I'm
going to type here the
fun keyword to declare a function
I'm going to call it sum because it's
going to return the sum of all the
parameter that we're going to Define so
I'm going to Define here some parameters
for it's going to be called a it's going
to be of type int
a single second is going to be called B
also in
third is going to be called C
also an end
the final one is going to be called the
alternate
and this this function is going to
return the sum of all of those
parameters so we need to Define here the
return type
which is going to be an hint
a whole number and now we can put the
curly braces and here we type return
a
plus b
plus c
Plus
d
and this is going to return the sum of
all the parameters that we Define here
or the values that is going to be passed
as arguments to this function and you
can write this as a single expression
function if you want so you can write
this uh like this if you want
this will have the same effect
but I will I will write it with the
curly braces because it will make things
more clear so let's undo this
right now let's call this function here
sum
let's press Ctrl alt L to format the
code and let's pass some values here so
I'm going to type here five
six seven
and
10.
all right if you press shift Ctrl p on
this you're gonna see that the type of
this function let's press again
the type of this function is an ins so
this function returns an integer so it's
it's an expression that means that we
can put this instead of putting storing
um
uh the return value in a variable we can
put this direction a printerland
function so you can type here print
area
and we can put the function inside here
because that function is of type in so
it's going to return
the sum of all the arguments that we
type there
so now if you run this code
we got we get 28 because 5 plus 6 Plus
7.10 is 28. now if I want to pass
another parameter here let's say that I
want to pass another number here I can't
because I am limited by the number of
parameters that we Define here of course
that I can Define another parameter here
but what if I want to pass 10 numbers
for 15 numbers or 100 numbers in that
case it will be very tedious to write
all of those parameters and and to solve
that you need to use what is called a
varg varag keyword and Avada keyword
allows us to pass more than one
parameter actually more than one
argument to our
parameters so to declare a Vari keyword
we type here
we type here far ARG so this is the
keyword varag it stands for variable
arguments
now we need to define a name for this
bar Arc I'm going to call it numbers
and we also need to specify a type what
kind of values this varag is going to
store
now this return keyword is this
variables here are red because they
don't exist
now if I want to
but first let's say that I want to type
here another parameter now now you see
that we have no problem so I can type
here whatever
number of numbers I want and there is no
problem as you can see now
to to
sum the values which are stored in these
viral numbers we need to use something
which we didn't cover yet but we have a
separate section which I show you how to
we need to explain this thing that I'm
going to use now and that is Loops
because now we need to Loop through our
numbers and to add our numbers to a
variable so we need to use what is
called a for Loop so to do that first we
declare a variable
I'm gonna call it um
let's say uh result
I'm gonna assign a value of zero
now to use a for Loop we Type 4
and again I'm gonna go into more detail
about this in uh the separate section
but now we need to use this because
there's not another way to to sum up the
values inside the varag numbers
and here we need to define a name for
our variable so it's going to be called
number
and now we use the keyword in
and now we're referring the
parameter the varag parameter which is
defined up called numbers
all right
now we here you can put the curly braces
and inside the cutter blazes we're going
to type
numbers
result
and now we're going to use that
abbreviation which is plus n equals
plus equals
number n
now here gonna return
the result return
result
all right so let's explain what we have
here so first we declare a variable we
assign a value of 0 to it so it's just
type int
next what this for Loop is doing so this
for Loop is doing what is doing is
executing
um a line of code multiple times so it
executing is executing uh uh what's
inside the curly braces until the it
finishes to it finishes the to Loop
through all these numbers which are
stored in the varark number so it first
assigns uh the first the first number or
number here
and it loops and it has that it adds
that number to a result then it does
that again and again and again until it
finishes so then it reaches uh the final
number five and in that case also gonna
sign
from our numbers uh the number five to
our number and then that number is going
to be added to our result variable and
when it finishes uh that looping when it
finishes that thing is gonna return the
result it's gonna return all the values
which are which were been added to our
result variable
so now if you print this
now I get 85 and probably this is the
result of this calculation so this is
how you can use varag numbers what are
the keyword to store more than one
single more than a limited number of
parameters defined
bio and another short shortcut to to
Loop through this is using a for each
Loop so we can do something like this
but this time let's say that I want I
don't want to return something
so let's see that I delete this
and I I can type here actually numbers
four
dot here to put that
each
and here we type print Ln
again this is a more complex subject
which is going to be covered in the next
videos so here we type print Ln
and we type it
all right now let's uh
let's call our sum
let's define some numbers here let's say
that I type here
one
four
all right so if you run this code
now you can see that every number in
that
that we defined here is printed one by
one so this number this for each which
is also a loop it goes through all of
these numbers it and it prints them one
by one and again we're gonna look at uh
for the for Loop and the four each in
the next videos but I had no other way
to show you this example without using
them but if you feel confused by for the
for each or the for Loop don't worry we
have a separate
section which in which you talk about in
detail about this for now we need to
only the only thing you need to know is
that you can
pass an indefinite number of parameters
of actually you can pass it an
indefinite number of arguments to our
varag numbers because this allows us to
to power to to pass uh
an indefinite number of values so here
you see that we have one four five six
seven eight nine five seven and six
numbers that we have here so this for
each is going through all of them and it
prints
them one by one so
see you in the next video
all right now it's time to start our
discussion about loops but first let's
create a new project
I'm going to call it loops
select IntelliJ click on next and finish
right a project is created let's delete
the code inside the color braces
let's hide the project pane
and let's start by explaining what Loops
are and why you need to use them
so Loops allows us to execute a piece of
code multiple times without
you writing down every line of code
manually so
let's say that I want to print
10 numbers in the console or 20 or 50.
instead of printing instead of typing
that code manually move line by line
which will be very tedious you can use a
loop and you can put that code in a loop
and in that code in the loop it will be
executed repeatedly until
a certain number is reached so let's see
how we can define a loop to define a
loop we type here
four this is the first Loop that we're
gonna look at because there are other
loops
so this is the for Loop we press enter
inside the parenthesis we type I this is
convention you can put whatever name you
wonder
now we put here in this is the keyword
in and now let's say that I want to loop
from
one
and from 1 to 10 and to do that to type
1 dot dot this is a range
one to ten now
I put a curly braces
and inside the pre the curly braces and
I'm gonna put the code that I want to be
executed
10 times so I'm gonna type here println
and I'm gonna type the value of I at
each iteration and uh
we can put it like this you can type
here uh
you can put in the quotation marks and
you can do the placeholder
you can put I
so now if you run this
so now I get
is one two
until 10. so it what is doing is is
looping through this range until it
reaches 10 then it stops
now uh you can write this I like I did
here using a placeholder where you can
write it like this
I've run this code it will have the same
effect but will not have the taste
before here
so now you get
one
until 10.
now there are other other very
variations to use this range and one of
them is to use until so let's uh command
this code
so let's press Ctrl slash
right now let's type 4 again
and now I'm gonna
I'm gonna call it also I here you can
put whatever name you want
and instead of now I'm going to put also
again the in keyword and instead of
putting the dot dot to Loop to arrange
I'm gonna put
one until
10.
all right
now I'm gonna add the printerliner
statement
and here I'm going to type I
and
this will have the same effect with the
thing with a single difference that 1
until 10 is is gonna exclude ten and one
uh
using the range.10 it will include 10.
so if you run this code
we're gonna see that you will not have
10 here because 10 it is excluded when
you're using the until
so now as you can see we have one until
nine and then it's excluded because now
we're using the until
so if you if you're using the range
which is uh dot the last number is going
to be included but if you use the
until the last number is going to be
excluded so it's important to know that
this two respectively the until and the
range can only count upwards
so we cannot put here 10 until 1 because
the first number the number of on the
left needs to be smaller than the number
on the right so we cannot put 10 until
1. we can only count upwards you can
only put one until 10 or
1.10 so
to Loop backwards we need to use
another thing so let's comment this code
also
now to Loop backwards we Type 4
again in the paradise you put the I here
you can put
whatever if you want
in
so here you can put whatever name but
the convention is I issues now I'm going
to put in and now I'm going to put down
first let's put uh
down
down to
one
let's add the curly braces
the printerland
and let's put I here
now this is gonna this is gonna count
downwards now it's gonna it's gonna
count from ten to one so if you run this
code
now get 10 9 so it's counting it's it's
counting backwards right another thing
that you can do is that you can
introduce an arbitrary step so let's uh
let's comment this code also
let's add below another call
another for Loop so here I'm gonna type
four
parenthesis
let's put I
and let's use uh done TL
so in
one
until
10. so now I can put a
an arbitrary step so at uh at this
arbitrary step that number which
is that is that is at dotted arbitrary
step is going to be skip so I can put
here step
to let's say
so now I'm gonna put the quarter Blazers
to have the some code executed I'm going
to put println
and let's put here I
so now if you run the squad
I get one three five seven and nine so
you can see that uh
at the second iteration the number is
Skip so we have one two is skipped now
we have then we have three four three
and four skips and so on so you can put
this arbitrary step if you want so let's
comment this code also
and let's add the first code that we had
here
to
to talk a little bit more so let's put I
in
one
let's put the range Dot 10.
and curly braces
you're gonna type println
hi
now if run this code
we'll get the same output that as at the
beginning of the video so get one
until 10 inclusive now again what this
uh loop is doing is going through this
is going to this to this range from 1 to
10 and it's executing the code inside
the curly braces 10 times and when it
reaches 10 it stops and it executes the
next line of code below here that
because here we don't have any line of
code our
program X is exited and is finished so
this is our discussion about for Loop
there are other Loops which can Loop
which can loop as long as a certain
condition is true not as long as a
certain number is reached so we're going
to look at the next Loops in the next
video
see you next
all right now it's time to look at the
next two Loops that you can use in
quadrant and those are the while and the
Dual Loop
but first let's open our previous
project called Loops because I'm going
to type my code there so open your
previous project and here I already have
deleted the code that we had previously
here but if you have the code delete it
and let's start our discussion about the
while loop
so first I'm going to type
while
this is this is how you declare the
while loop
and here you can press enter to fill in
the the wallykid on the parenthesis for
you or you can type manually the while
and the parenthesis so I'm going to
press enter to fill that for you fill in
that for me
and next you put a space and you put
curly brace here so I'm going to put the
left curly brace and press enter and the
radical base is going to be added
automatically as you can see on the line
five now
a while loop Loops as long as a certain
condition is true in contrast to the for
Loop which Loops for a specific number
of time while a loop Loops as long as a
condition or an expression is true so
this gives us more flexibility in a
circumstances or you don't know for what
specific number of times we want our
code to be repeated so
we put our condition inside the
parenthesis here
and as long as this condition is true
the code inside the current base is
going to be executed repeatedly so let's
see how we can do that so first let's
discard a variable here
I'm going to call it number and I'm
going to sign a value of 0 to it
and here I'm gonna type while number
is less than 10
inside the calibration I'm going to type
the println function
and we're going to Output the value of
our number and then we're going to
increment the value of a number so I'm
going to put number I'm going to use the
increment operator plus plus
let's put a space here to have things
more clear now if you run this code
you're going to see the numbers from 0
to 9.
so what is happening how this works
first
with the color variable with a sine of
value of 0 to it next we Loop using the
while loop and first the while loop is
checking to see if this condition inside
the parenthesis is true so it checks to
see if the value of our variable number
is less than 10 and it's true because we
have zero then it executes the code
inside the curly braces and it outputs
the value of our number in the console
using the printerland function then it
increments the value of our number
and then it Loops again but now the
value of our number is one so now it
will compare again if
the value for number is less than 10
which is true it will loop again it will
output its value it will increment this
value so now we have two and so on until
it reaches nine when it reaches 9 it
will increment the value it will it will
print it will output the value in the
console it will increment this value
then it will check again to see if this
condition is true but now the value is
going to be
10 because not it was incremented when
it was nine
and this condition is going to be ever
it's going to evaluate to false and the
code inside the cutter base is not going
to be executed this way we don't have 10
here and it executes the code that comes
below of our while loop but because you
don't have any code
the program is terminated
and you can write this thing in one
single line but it's recommended to use
this form only if you know that you have
one single statement in our Loop so if I
can delete this
this tool
and I can put here directly number plus
plus and because this Returns the value
it increments the value and it Returns
the values and expression I can
I can run this code and it will have the
same output
but if I delete the increment operator
out after the
variable and if I put it before
now I'm gonna see a different output
here because this increments the value
of
of our number then it decrements the
value of our number and this is called
prefix in increment increment so this is
called prefix incrementing and the the
previous one let's press Ctrl G
this is called postfix increment so this
is postfix because it's the end of our
variable and uh if you put the
incremental operator at the beginning of
our variable is called prefix oh
increment anyway
let's press Ctrl Z to have the code that
I had previously and the curly braces
now look what happens if I delete the
increment
if I don't increment all variable now
now uh let's just talk what is happening
because we don't increment the variable
and the variable always has the value of
zero this will always be true and it
will execute the code inside the current
places forever so we'll have what is
called an infinite Loop so if you run
this code
now you can see that it prints 0 forever
because this condition never ever has to
to to false so let's stop this by
pressing on this uh
Red Square so now the process the
program is terminated so this is why you
need to increment the value of our
number because we want that condition to
be false at some point in the in the in
the in the future
next
let's say that I assign here 10.
so if I run this code now this condition
is going to be false because 10 is not
less than 10. and the code inside the
curly brace is not going to be executive
so now we have no output here because
this condition is evaluates to false and
is not executing the code inside the
calibration but there are certain
situations where you'll want to have
your code executed at least once even
though the initial condition the initial
uh condition or there is expression is
false so if I delete the curly braces
and the code inside the curly braces
here
now to to do what I said if to execute
the the code even though the condition
is initially set to false to execute the
code at least once you need to use a do
while loop and to use a do while loop
you put here at do press enter to add
the calibrases and we put our while at
the end of of our enclosing curly brace
of Urdu and here inside the calibration
or I'm going to put our printerland
function
and I'm gonna output the value of our
variable number
so now if you run this
now get 10 because this executes the
code inside the curly braces until at
least once and after that it comes down
here and it checks to see if this
condition is true or false and if this
condition is true it will repeat the
code
but if the condition is false it uh it
will not repeat the code but the
important aspect here is that it will
execute the code inside the curly braces
at least once irrespective of our
condition if the condition is true of
order false in our case is false
so these are the three Loops that you
can use in a kotlin the for Loop the
while loop and the do while loop now
it's time to see how we can use the
continue and the break keywords with
those Loops so let's press Ctrl Z to
undo the code have the while loop back
because I'm going to start the while
loop and to see how we can use the but
you can continue cured with the while
loop
let's bring this up a little bit
so let's first look at the continue
keyword and the continue keyword can be
used to bypass a section of code so
let's say that I want to skip the number
seven in our Loop so I can type here if
our variable number
equals 2 so 2 equals seven let's put
curly braces press enter toward the
right calibrase continue
so now what this is gonna do is when it
is gonna reach the number seven and this
condition is going to be true it's gonna
call continue and it's going to bypass
the code that comes below of our if
statement so if you run this code
look uh what happens
it happens nothing because uh here our
number has a value of 10 so this
condition is false so the code is not
executed so let's put here zero
now if you run this code
so we get 0 1 2 3 4 5 and 6 but uh
and you see that I save at seven it uh
it skips the code but why I don't have
the next numbers this is because uh
unintentionally we created here an
infinite look so let's stop this and uh
to explain
so what happens here is that because
um we said we say here explicit to
you to check here explicit we check here
to see if our number is equal to seven
then we're gonna continue and in other
words you're gonna skip the code which
comes below of our
of order is the then statement then this
code is never called so this code is
never called the printerland and more
importantly the increment operator is
now never called on our number variable
and because of that
because our variable is not incremented
here either when it's gonna loop again
it will have again the value 7. so this
condition or the in the if is going to
evaluate again to true and it's going to
call continue again and because this
code again is never reached Discord and
the values no not not incremented it
will still have the value seven so this
is gonna evaluate again to true so it
does this forever and to change that we
need to put our
number
and which is incremented before our reef
and that is going to solve the problem
so now if I
Let's uh
now
if I run the code let's increase this
now get one two three four five
and seven is skipped then 8 9 and 10.
because now when this condition level is
to true it will continue it's not going
to print the code it's not going to be
executed below of our if and it will
come back to Loop and now it's going to
increment the value and the value is
going to be
8 instead of 7 this is going to evaluate
to false and the continue is not going
to be called it will print the number
eight and it will do the same for it it
will increment the value again and then
we'll have 9 and so on so this is how
you can use the continue keyword and you
have to be careful where you put your in
uh your whatever incremental variable
because I you saw you can easily get
intro infinite Loop
now you can have a more complex
expression here so you can put here if
number is greater than let's say 2 and
number
is less than eight
now if you run this
look what happens
now get one two and then we get 8 9 and
10 because what this condition now
checks is is if our number is greater
than 10 and less than 8 then continue
then skip that number so this is why the
numbers between 2 and 8 are skipped
because we call continue on on them and
if you hover over here you see that it
says the two comparison should be
converted to a rain check so you can
write the same condition that have here
using a range but this is different from
a range that you you've used in a for
Loop in the sense that this is now
checking to see if our number is in the
range 3
from 3 to 7 so if you run the squad
now I have the exact same output but now
we are using the range to check to see
if our number is in the other engine if
this is the underage we call continue to
skip that
um
the next thing that you can do is you
can
break the loop you can stop the loop
using the break here so I can say here
again if number
equals equals let's say seven
call break
so I'm going to type here break
now when this condition is going to vary
to true it's gonna call break and the
loop is going to stop it's not going to
execute any line of code after that it's
gonna stop it's gonna leave and it's
going to execute the code which comes
below here but in our case we don't
don't have any code
so you see that we have one two three
four five and six and when it reaches
seven it breaks and it nuts is stopping
the loop it's not printing the value and
it executes the loop so it terminates so
foreign
and we can do the same thing with the
for Loop so we can use the four we can
use the continue and
and break with a for Loop so you can
type here four
let's say I in let's create the
let's say
zero
to 10 let's create this range
let's add the curly braces
now I can say here if
I
in
let's say three
to eight
then continue
let's put in the volume
let's type here println
let's print the value of I here
so now if you run this code
so we have our first Loop which Loops a
to six and then it breaks because you
call break there then it's using the for
Loop it Loops it loops
from 0 to 10 but because here we're
checking to see if our number is in the
range three to eight and skip it you get
0 1 2 and then the numbers uh the three
and uh the numbers between the three and
the numbers between 3 and 8 inclusive
are skipped here so we have 0 1 2 and
then the numbers between two and nine
are skipped and we have nine and ten
and we can use also the brake keyword
with the four I can put here if I equals
equals seven
break
[Music]
so now if you run this code
now you get 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 and when it
reaches seven it breaks similar to our
while loop so this is how you can use
the break and continue cured with the
while and for Loop and you can use the
brake and continue cured also with the
Dual Loop
next we're gonna look at how you can
Nest Loops within each others and we're
going to look at an example using the
while loop so I'm going to delete the
code of the for Loop and the printable
statement there
I'm going to delete the if then
statement the break yard and I'm going
to bring the printerland function up
there
down here I'm going to declare a
variable it's going to be a VAR I'm
going to call it I and I'm gonna assign
a value of 0 to it now in inside the
while loop I'm going to type another
while loop here I'm going to put a
conditional while I is less than 5
we're gonna increment I and we're gonna
print and output the value of I in the
console but let's put some text here to
make uh clear what Loops what Loop is
looping so I'm going to put three
asterisk signs here
I'm gonna type the dollar sign and I
so now if you run this code let's also
change this condition too
less than five
so if you run this code
now we get first you get one then we get
our code inside of our inner while loop
which is the three asterisks and get one
two three four five then it Loops again
but let's take this chord line by line
to explain what is happening here
so first decade is variable call number
assign a value of zero to it then we
Loop using the while loop the outer loop
and it checks to see this condition
issue and is true zero is less than five
so it executes the code inside the curly
braces and it increments the value of a
number by one then it outputs the value
of our number in the console so you get
here one
then it declared this variable called I
and then it starts looping inside our
outer loop while using the inner loop
while so it Loops here five times
so when it finishes it goes back
and now the value was incremented by one
it will check again if the condition is
true it will uh execute the code inside
the calibration to increment the value
now so the it will have two it will
output that value so now we have two
here
and then it will loop again five star
five times using the inner loop and it
will do the same thing for the next
round and the next round until you get
to
5. when
we'll get to five five will be not be
less than five and this condition will
evaluate to to false and the code inside
the caliber is not going to be executed
right
and you can use the break keyword inside
the inner loop so I can say here if
you can put it above here so you can say
if
I equals equals zero
then break and now you can put the break
and continue cures in one single line if
you want you can avoid the curly braces
so now if you run this code
now get one two three four five because
now uh when it reaches the inner loop it
breaks immediately what every at every
iteration in the outer loop so when it
comes down here it will check to see if
the conditions through is going to be
true but when it gets to the if
statement it will break it will stop the
loop so it will execute only the Outer
Loop
and with a break keyword you can
not not Target only the loop so with
with this break keyword we stop you stop
only this while loop that uh
that we are currently that is currently
the nearest Loop but there is something
which which is called labels and with
labels you can Target an outer loop so
it can break the outer loop here so you
can break the while loop which is here
and to do that we we give to our while
loop a label so we type here a name I'm
going to call it outer and we put at
now here you can put break and now I'm
gonna type
add
and you put outer and this this should
be a single word
now if you run this look what happens
now get one because it breaks the outer
loop so it first evolves this condition
it increments the value of our number it
prints the value of a number and then it
goes in the Inner Loop it checks to see
if this condition is true it's true then
it's checked to see if I is equal to 0
which is uh true then it breaks but now
it's not breaking this Loop this inner
loop
it's breaking the Outer Loop so it's
breaking this Loop so this is why you
get only one and the code is not
executed because it breaks the outer
loop and the code our program or code
it's terminated because about down here
we don't have any code so this is how
you can use labels with the break
keyboard to Target an outer loop and the
labels can be used also with the
continue keyword and in other Loops that
we've looked at so this is our
discussion about loops what you can do I
should say is that you cannot Target
with the labels and inner loop from an
outer loop so you cannot
we can give here a name to a label to
our inner loop but you cannot Target our
inner from our outer loop so this is our
discussion about loops and the next
video we're going to do a challenge
all right so now it's time to do a
challenge using all the knowledge that
we have accumulated so far and I'm gonna
use the previous project to put my code
there but if you don't have the previous
project you can create a new project and
give it whatever name you want and type
your code there so I'm going to open my
previous project
I'm going to delete the code inside the
main function
now what is the challenge
the challenge is to
create an arbitrary range of numbers
then we need to find a way to go to that
arbitrary range of numbers
and to determine if a number is an even
number or if a number is another number
and based on that if the number is an
odd number skip that number
but if the number is an even number then
output a number in the console
additionally should create a way to
count all the even numbers that you
found in your range and display the
total number so if neither numbers
um at the end of your program
so try to do this solution and after
that you can watch my solution to this
so first I'm going to decide I'm going
to declare a variable call number
I'm going to assign a value of 1 to it
next I'm going to declare another
variable but this is going to be a Val
it's going to be called last number
and it's going to have a value of 20.
now I'm gonna Loop using the while loop
and in the parantes you're going to type
while number
is less than equal to last number
then you're going to put curly braces
now I'm going to increment our number
now here you need to add the logic to
determine if a number is an even number
or not and to do that I'm going to add
the function at the end of our enclosing
curly brace of our many functions so I'm
going to type here the fun keyword
now you need to give a name to our
function it's going to be called is even
number
I'm gonna put parenthesis and it's going
to take a parameter called number of
type int
this function and it's gonna return a
Boolean value true or false this
function so you put colon and we type
Boolean then you put curly braces and
now we'll add the logic to determine if
any number is even or not so you type
here if
and now inside the parenthesis we put
another set of parentheses
and here we refer our parameter number
that we have defined above and here we
put the modulus operator because the
modulus operator gives us the reminder
of a division so we put a modulus
operator 2.
now outside our inner parenthesis we put
equals equals zero then we put curly
braces
and return true
else we're gonna return
false now how this logic works
so
our num our number parameter which is
defined here it's going to take an
argument let's say that it's going to
take an arbitrary number
then he's gonna check to see if that
number divided by 2 has no reminder if
it's and if it has no reminder then that
number is an even number because the
because even numbers when they are
divided by two they have no reminder
and if that is the case if the reminder
equals equals to zero our number is an
even number and it's gonna return true
and their spot is not going to be
executed
now let's add the logic here
list user function here because as you
can see now it's uh gray out it's not
used so let's type here if
and in the parenthesis you're gonna type
is even number our functions we're going
to call our function here and we're
going to pass a parameter to it called
now I'm going to pass the parameter
we're going to pass an argument and the
argument is going to be the variable
that we Define above as you can see you
have the V there so press enter to fill
on that for you let's press Ctrl alt L
to format the code
now
if we press shift Ctrl p on this you're
going to see that this is a Boolean
expression because this returns true or
false so we can put the logical not
operator in front of it to change its
value to switch his value from True to
false and from and from false to true
so let's put curly braces
and here we're gonna call our continue
quick keyword down here I'm gonna add
a printerland
which is going to Output the the number
in our console
next we need to add the logic to to
count the total uh the total even
numbers which are found so I'm gonna
declare a VAR it's going to be
even numbers
counter and I'm going to assign a value
0 to it and here we're gonna increment
our even numbers counter
so now if you run this code
we get 2 4 6 8 10 12 14 16 18 and 20. so
these are the even numbers that they are
that they found that the our program
found in is correct but let's add a
print line at the end of our Loop to
print the total number of numbers of
even numbers found so let's put println
here and let's put let's refer our even
numbers count here
you have a numbers counter so if you run
this
let's put some text actually let's put
this in curly braces so let's type here
total
number of even
numbers found
equals
dollar sign
now if you run this
now you get total numbers of you know
when even numbers found this 10 and this
is correct so in an output correctly or
even numbers and it show that the total
number two newer numbers found this 10.
so let's now think about how this logic
works here
so let's look at the if statement that
we have here so what is doing in this
thing here so let's take an um an um
specific example a specific number to
store to see how this works so let's see
that here we pass four and it's gonna
use the logic to determine if this
number is an even number and if that
number is any of a number is going to
return true so this
this function which is a Boolean
expression is going to return true and
then we're gonna negate this value gonna
change this value from True to false and
continuously not gonna be called and the
code which comes below which is uh our
variable which uh counts how many even
numbers uh we have then it it increments
then it outputs that number in the
console so we have our even number four
output output it in the console
but if you pass here 3 that the number
is not going to be an even number
because has a reminder and this is going
to return uh false and because of here
you put the logical not operator that is
going to be switched to true
and the continue that's going to
continue keyword is going to be called
and our code Channel which comes below
here which is uh our variable even
number counter is not going to be
incremented
and our number respect to our number
three now it's not going to be outputted
in the console so this is how this works
so this is our solution to our
to our challenge of course you can
simplify this so if you hover over here
because you have all of those underlines
you can see that says remove redundancy
if statement
so this can be simplified to this this
does the exact same thing it is going to
return true if this uh divided by 2 has
no reminder otherwise it's going to
return false and this can can be
simplified even further because if here
we have a single expression and we know
when we have a single expression we can
write our function as a single
expression function so I can remove the
curly braces here
you can remove
the bully return type you can remove the
return keyword
I'm gonna put the equal zero and this
now if you run this code
this will work
the same
so we have the same output here
now I use the function here because
we've talked about functions in our
previous videos but you can remove the
function completely and add the logic to
determine if a new number is even or not
directly in the if statement so you can
put here
if
let's put parenthesis our number
now we're going to use the modulus
operator tool
not equal
to zero
then continue and this will have the
same effect so if you run this code
this will work in the same way
so we have the same code here because
this does the exact that the function
did previously it will check to see if
this is a new number if this is any of a
number
the
this is not going to be true because
hero checking to see if this is not
equal to zero and our number is equal to
zero so this condition inside the
parenthesis is going to be false the
continue is not going to be called and
the our code below is going to be called
our even number counter is going to be
incremented and our number is going to
be output in the console so this does
the same thing as previously
and we can do this challenge also in the
first of the four Loop if you want
so you can type here four
I in one
to 20 then execute the code inside the
curly braces and here you can
check if
parenthesis again if I present
2 not equal to
zero
then call continue
then
else is gonna execute the code which
comes below here
which is let's first
assign a value for your to a even number
counter to zero
because where when we're gonna enter in
the for Loop we should have a zero to
not have the previous value which was
20.
so let's put 0 here and here you can
increment or even number counter
plus plus and we're gonna print our even
number so I'm going to print I here
so if you run this code
let's run it from here
but let's add the printerland to make
things more clear so I'm going to add
here print
let's put
quotation marks and here I'm gonna type
total
number
phone
using four
Loop
r
let's put the dollar sign now let's
refer our even number variable
now if you run this
now I have the exact same output but now
we're using the
first you're using the while loop then
you're using the photo clip so let's
let's add the printerline statement
between our
Loops to make clear which Loop is
looping so let's draw the print line
here
and let's type here
now
we
so we are
looping
using the
four
Loop so now if you run this
to make more clear which Loop is looping
so now as you can see first the while
loop Loops then we have our printerland
which
says that now our while loop our for
Loop starts looping then we loop with
the for Loop
then at the end
we output the total number total number
of even only fever numbers found with
the while loop we have 10 then we output
the total number found the total number
of even numbers found using the for Loop
and r10 so our code works perfectly well
and
uh this do not does not represent the
the best
the best way to solve this challenge of
course that you can
find a totally different way a better
way to solve this so
this was my this was just my way of
solving the problem
so see you in the next video and how I
hope that you enjoy this challenge so
now it's time to start a discussion
about the race but first let's create a
new project I'm going to call it a race
for the language select kotlin for the
build system IntelliJ make sure to have
the jdk selected and check this little
box at sample code to have the main
function Auto generator for us and click
on create
all right now let's delete the code
inside the calibrases of the main
function
let's hide the project Pane and let's
start our discussion about arrays and so
far in our videos we've only looked at
how we can store only one single value
in a variable and that is very useful
but what if you have a large amount of
values that you want to store in our
variables let's say that you want to
store
30 or 40 different
values in our variable of a certain type
of course that you can declare a
variable for each of one of those
values then and then assign it to the
variables but what happens if you have a
1000 or 10 20
values in that case uh it will not be
practically possible to write each one
of those variables and then assign a
value to it in a colon help us here
because it provides us arrays and an
array allows us to store more than one
single element in a variable name so it
allows us to store more more elements in
one single variable name
now to declare an array we type Val
hero type
names
next we need to provide the type and the
type is going to be an array
and IntelliJ is giving us some
suggestion there so press enter to fill
it in that for you and now we put angle
brackets and inside the angle brackets
we're going to put what kind of data
this array is going to store so it's
going to store string or text or
sequence of characters
then you put equals and here we don't
type political value here we have a hero
type of function call and here we type
array of
and now we put our elements inside the
the parenthesis of the function called
separated by comma so I'm going to put
three names here so I'm going to put
John
Steven
and Megan
now let's uh let's see what we have here
so first we have the Val keyword next we
have a name for our variable and the
name is names then we have the type and
the type is an array which means that
you can store multiple values in our
variable and next we have angle brackets
and string and this means that this area
is going to store text or a sequence of
characters it's gonna store only strings
and then you put equals we have the
function called array of and then we put
our elements of type string which is
those names separated by comma but
because cotton has Type inference here
you can delete the type
and the type is going to be inferred in
the same way it was it was inferred
previously when I when you just declare
a simple variable so now the type is
still inferred as an array of strings
and now it's a good moment to introduce
type hints but we need to activate the
typings from settings and to do that you
can go to file
and click on settings or you can press
the the shortcut that you have here for
our particular system and for Windows is
Ctrl alt s so I'm going to press Ctrl
this
and here we go to if you have something
like this you go to editor click on this
greater arrow in front of editor
and then you go down here where it says
what it says inline hints click on on
this Creator are in front of inline
hints and from
those options select kotlin
and here you go to types and select
select local variable types then click
apply
and okay
now what you have here on the right of
our variable name is a hint so it's not
real text this is just there to remind
us what kind of type this variable has
and in our case is an array of string
and my suggestion for this to keep those
scenes activated because in this way
you'll always see what type of variable
is without explicitly declaring the type
so this is not uh this is this is just
there to help us to remind us what kind
of type a variable is
now let's say that I want to Output a
certain element in the array in the
console
to do that we cannot just type here
println and pass names because you need
more to be more specific than that we
cannot pass the array here and to get a
specific element in the array you need
to know that the elements in the array
are stored at indexes and the index of
an array always starts at zero so the
first element is stored at the index 0
and to get the first element we tab we
type here
square brackets and you put 0 and that
if you press Ctrl
if you press shift Ctrl p on it
it's a string because that is going to
return as the first value in the array
which is uh John so if you run this code
we get John but let's put some text here
to make it more
clear that this is the first element so
let's type first
element now let's choose the dollar sign
because this now is a placeholder and
let's put the curly braces around our
our element
and the quotation mark here now if you
run this code
you get first element John let's put
here some
so get the first element John because uh
John is stored at the index 0. and in
the same way
John is stored at the index 0 Steven is
stored at the index one and Megan is
stored at the index two so our index
starts at zero the index of an array
always starts at zero and you can
replace
a specific in an element in the array
also using the index operator so you can
type here
names again
square brackets zero
equals so now I'm going to assign a new
value to our element stored at index 0
which is now put here
the value
Alex so now if you run this code
now get first elementalics because
John was John which is at index 0 was
replaced with the value Alex so now we
have Alex Steven and Megan but what you
can't do is you cannot get an uh element
at neither and an index that doesn't
exist so we cannot get here let's say an
element of the index 4. because if you
run this look what happens
we get
an error which says array index out of
bond extension index 4 out of bonds
bonds for length 3. that is because the
index 4 doesn't exist and here we try to
access that value and that value at that
value and that index doesn't exist and
this is called the runtime error because
this error is is called only one while
our app is still running so you don't
have here an error like we have for uh
here we don't have a compile error which
you saw in our previous videos that is
because
the size of an array is not known we
tell our compile time also it's very
important to know here that the size of
an array is fixed so this will always
have the size three and uh the only way
to add new elements to it is to put the
elements directly here but there is not
another way to let's say that I want I
can put another element in the array
down here we can only replace elements
and then in the next videos you're gonna
see that there are other arrays
which are more flexible in the sense
that they can grow and Shrink we can add
the or remove elements from those arrays
but for now uh we're gonna look just at
the for this array
so let's change this back to zero to
don't have that error
and um
to avoid this kind of Errors you can
check to see what is the size of the
array in other words to see what is the
number of elements stored in Array using
the size variable so let's do that so
I'm going to add the printer lens
statement below for first one so I'm
going to type here println
and here I'm going to put the text the
size of the array is
and here I'm going to put the dollar
sign curly braces now I'm going to use
our names array
and you're going to put that
size
and this is gonna give us the size of
the array or or it's going to give us
the another words the number of elements
which are stored in this particular
array so if you run this code
you're going to see first output the
first element is Alex
and then you're going to see the size of
the array is 3.
so we get first element Alex and the
size of the array is three and this is
very important to note that the size of
the array is always one times greater
than the last index in the array so we
have an array which starts as index 0
and and ends at index two
which has a size of three so very
important to remember this to avoid the
crashes and your programming and of
course that you can put other data types
in our array so I can declare another
array here also Val
called
numbers
and we can use the array of again
and here I can pass some numbers
and now you see the type is an array of
Fint or an array of integers or whole
numbers and you can also mix types here
so you can put here
numbers and strings
so now we have another and this which is
between our angle brackets you don't
know you don't need to understand this
for now but this allows us to have array
of two types respectively of type int
and of type string and you can post also
a chart here if you want
let's say a so we can create an array of
any type if you want
so this allows us to
to put to mix our types in in the array
and because we've looked at loops and
how you can use loops
you can use Loops to Loop to this array
so I can put here
let's say that I want to use the first
array so I can put here four
name
in names now I'm going to refer our
array of strings
then
print
print A lender name
so now you see that we have this type
hint for our name variable that we have
here of course this can have whatever
name you want now if you run this you're
gonna see our three names outputted down
here in the console
so now we have Alex Stefan Steven and
Megan because uh now you're we're using
the for Loop to Loop through our array
names
and uh
this is interesting but what if you want
to Loop through our array numbers which
is a mixed array we have numbers and
strings and charts we can refer it here
let's call it
I
in
and now you see the type that was
inferred for the eye is this comparable
that we have here
so this
is going to Loop through our mixed array
so we put here I
now if you run this
you're gonna see our
numbers and in our name one and our
chart output down here
so now we get
first element Alex which is a
printerland statement then the next
print line statement the size of the red
then you have our
numbers in our numbers array
and then we have our name one and our
and then we have our chart
so this allows us to to Loop through our
mix arrays but what if I want to
to Output
only if I want to Output in the console
only the integers in this mixed are
equal numbers to to do that and this is
a
good good
way to introduce this keyword and with
this keyword we can check to see if
a literal or a variable is supposed
certain type so I can put here if
I
is let's say an INT
then and only then I'm gonna output this
value in the console then I'm going to
call our printerland and I'm gonna post
our password I variable to our println
function
now if you run this you gonna you
gonna see in our Loop only
the numbers here only the integers
because
this is keyword is checking to see if
our right is of type integer and this is
going to return true or false in our
case it's going to return true for our
for all of our numbers that we have here
so we have four five six seven and four
again
and you can check to see if this is a HR
I'm gonna see in the console only our
single element a I'll put it down here
so we have a or you can check to see if
this is a string
this element that We're looping at this
particular iteration let's say so if you
run this you're gonna see in the console
only name one because only name one is
of type string
so I get name one so this is very
important to know that with the is
keyword you can check to see if a
variable or a literally is of a certain
type or if it's not and based on that
too to just to do some
in our case you output that value in the
console if that condition is true
so this is how you can use the is
keyword and the for Loop to
to the for Loop to Loop through our
array and these keyword to check to see
if an element in our arrays of a certain
type or if it's not and let's change our
array numbers to a different name
because numbers is very specific it
implies that we only have numbers in
this array
but we have a mixed type so we have
multiple types in uh our array don't
have only numbers
and to do that instead of changing our
numbers array and everywhere in our code
where you're using the this variable we
can right click on it
go to refactor and click on rename or
you can click shift F6
now if I change the name of our array
numbers it will be change everywhere
where you call this variable so look if
I delete now the name the name is also
changed in our line of Code 9 we're
using in the loop so now if I change
this to let's call it mixed
elements
if I press enter now this will be also
changed everywhere or we call our our
variable respectively on the line 9 here
so now we have our our
array numbers change to mixed Elements
which is more uh descriptive because it
implies that we have an array of mixed
elements
so now it's time to do a challenge using
the knowledge that we have about arrays
but first of all I'm going to delete the
code inside the curry base of the main
function because I have the previous
project opened
now the challenge is to create a
function which is going to take as an
argument an array of integers then you
need to figure out a way to determine
which number is the biggest number in
that array then we need to return that
number to the function
and you need to create another function
which is going to do the same thing but
it's gonna figure out what is the
minimum number stored in that array and
then it's going to return that value
and third you need to find a way to
combine those two function in just one
function which is gonna
return the maximum value stored in that
array if you want or if you don't want
it to return the minimum value so try to
solve this Challenge and then watch my
solution
now let's solve this challenge
so first I'm going to create a function
which is going to be called the find
marks this function is going to return
the maximum value
and it's going to take us and I'm going
to Define here parameter and an array so
here I'm going to type a name for our
array is going to be called numbers
n is going to have the type array
of int of integers and it's going to
return an integer
now here I'm going to declare a variable
it's going to be a VAR and it's going to
be called Max
and in this Max variable I'm going to
store the first value in the which is uh
which is past which is in the which is
in the array so I'm gonna type here
numbers
square brackets
and I'm going to use the index 0 to get
the first value in the array then
I'm gonna Loop through this array
so
for number in numbers
then here you're going to check to see
if our
number
is greater than our first value which
was stored in the array or max value and
if that is true then I'm gonna store
this value which is now
greater than our than our maximum value
in our Max variable so here I'm going to
put Max now it's going to be equal to
this number which is found to be greater
than our previous max value
and at the end of this loop we're gonna
return
the maximum value
and we're going to do the same for the
finding the minimum value so I'm going
to copy this code
and this is going to be called find mean
but uh here gonna change a little bit
the logic let's call this variable mean
and you're going to change the condition
to less than min
[Music]
now let's call those function in our
main function and let's pass summaries
to see how it works
so first I'm going to declare a variable
it's going to be a Val and it's going to
be called Max
and now I'm going to call our find Max
function and here I'm going to pass an
array and I'm gonna I'm gonna pass the
array directly here so I'm going to type
array off and I'm going to pass some
arbitrary numbers like
then I'm going to create another valve
this is going to be called mean
now I'm going to call find
Min and here I'm going to also
call our array of function and here I'm
going to Define some
arbitrary numbers again
now I'm going to Output those value in
the consoles so I'm going to add
printerland here
I'm going to type max value is dollar
sign
and I'm going to refer our Max variable
defined above
another println
now let's run this code it's
get max value 7 which is correct this is
the biggest number then we get the
minimum value is 4 and this is also
correct so our code Works uh perfectly
well now the next thing is to combine
those two functions that we have here
let's
increase this now we need to find a way
to combine those function in one single
function which is going to also return
the maximum and minimum value but only
if I want to return to be returned so I
can determine if I want the minimum
value to be returned by that function or
if I want the maximum value to be
returned by that function so I need to
find a way to combine those two
and to do that I'm going to delete our
second function
I'm gonna delete the code inside the
this function
and I'm going to change the name of this
function to
find mean and Max and now here I'm going
to define a parameter which is going to
be a Boolean uh which is going to have a
Boolean type so I'm gonna call it
I'm going to call it search
Max
and it's going to be
a Boolean
all right
now
based on that Boolean value if is true
if I want to search the maximum value
here I'm going to type an if statement
so I'm going to put if search marks then
I'm gonna
add here the code to search for the
maximum value the first let's define um
a variable here is going to be also VAR
let's be called gonna be called
Max and uh it's also going to have the
first value in the array
which is also adding the zero now if our
search marks is true then we want our
maximum value to be search and return so
I'm gonna add here to the code to to do
that so I'm going to type here a for
Loop
which is going to go through our numbers
array
and here I'm gonna add the
the if statement which I'm gonna check
to see if our number
is greater than our Max then I'm gonna
assign our
our
number Tower Max
now I'm gonna go down here and and here
I'm going to add the else part so if
this uh
argument which is passed to our
parameter search Max is false so I don't
want to search for the maximum value
then that means that I want to search
for the minimum value so I'm going to
put here else now I'm going to add the
code to search for the minimum value and
for this you need to Define also
variable here
it's going to be called mean and it's
going to have the value of Max I'm going
to explain a minute how this works
now
here we're going to gonna also Loop
in our
numbers draw numbers array
and you're going to check if we
essentially we have the same code that
we have in our find the mean function so
here we're going to search if our number
is less than our mean
then gonna sign
our number to our mean
also I need to return this value
at the end of our Loop so here we need
to return
Max
and here you need to return mean
now let's press Ctrl alt L to format the
code
now let's delete the
those the code that you have here
let's delete also this code now
here now I'm going to put our fine Min
and Max function directly in the
printerland statement so I'm gonna type
here uh or to put in a variable for so
let's put in a variable first
so I'm gonna
Define a variable he's going to be also
a map it's going to be Auto Max and here
you're gonna type find
Min and Max
now here you need to pass an array first
so I need to pass
we need to call our array off we need to
Define some numbers here let's say uh
40.
50.
now we need to pass
an argument to our parameter search maps
which is going to be either true or
false so first I'm going to pass through
here
now if we print this value if you output
this value in the console
let's say that we type here
the marks
equals to dollar sign I'm going to refer
our variable
now if you're around the squad
we get the maximum value is 100 which is
correct now let's duplicate this code
that we have here and let's try it for
Dominion value
let's call it mean
and let's add the printerland uh
statement down here
let's type
domain
values
dollar sign mean
now if you run this code
and let's pass here to false
let's run this code again
now get the maximum value is 100 which
is correct
and the minimum value is 20 and we did
this with our find Min and Max function
by combining our two previous functions
and the our code on the networks okay
now it's time to
have a discussion about how this code
how this code how this solution to my
challenge works
so now let's see how our logic inside
our find Min and Max function works so
firstly we declare our function find the
minion marks then we declare two
parameters which is one is numbers and
is of type array of integers so here
we're gonna pass only an array of
integers
and the second parameter is called
search marks and it's a Boolean so you
can pass here only true or false then
we're going to say to the then we say
here that this function is going to
return a value
next on the line 9 we declare a variable
which is called Max
and we assign using the index operator
the first
element in the array in our Max so in
this case we're sine 20 in our Max
variable and then we declare another
variable called mean and we assign our
marks in our mean but our Max has the
value of 20 because we assigned it here
so this variable mean is also is also
also having the value 20. so both have
have the have the value 20 at the start
then we check to see if our search marks
parameter is true or false and if it's
true then I'm gonna execute the If part
and if part works in the following way
first we Loop using the for Loop through
our numbers array
then we check at each iteration if our
number let's say if 20 is greater than
our Max so if 20 is greater than 20
which is going to be false so the code
inside the calibration if it's not going
to be executed
then go for the next iteration so here
now we're gonna see it gonna check to
see if our number respectively 40 is
greater than our Max which is 20. and
this is going to be true and because of
that the code inside the calibration is
going to be executed so now we're going
to assign to our marks which is now is
20. our number which is 40. so now our
Max variable has a value of 40. and
we're going to we're going to do the
setting for the next for the 50. so this
condition is also going to be true so
we're going to assign it to our Max 50
and so on and so on
until it reaches 100 which is uh which
is going to be also true this condition
is going to repeat true and I'm going to
be assigning
100 to our Max
value of course that if we had another
number here let's say two is going to
Loop for that number also and this
condition is going to be false for that
because our number two is not going to
be greater than Max and it's going to
exit it's going to exit the loop it's
going to tell it's terminate and it's
gonna return the maximum value which is
100 like we saw in our
output in our console and at this point
when we return our max value the
function is left so it's not executing
any line of code
besides our
return Max is not going to execute the
subsequent code which comes below but if
our search marks is false it's going to
execute the else part so in this case
it's gonna search
for the minimum value so here we have
the same for Loop we search you go
through the
through all the numbers but here not
checking to see if our number is greater
then marks you're checking to see if our
number is less than our minimum number
so you check to see if our let's say uh
let's say let's take 20 30 40
is less than our minimum value which is
20. and that is going to be false so
this code is not going to be going to be
executed inside the calibration of the
if and it's gonna loop again and now
it's gonna check for the fourth and
that's also going to be gonna be
um
false so and so on so and so on until it
reaches 100 which is also going to be
false the loop is going to execute and
it's going to return 20. of course that
if we put here two
let's say now the minimum value is going
to be 2 because it's going to Loop for
another iteration and now one is going
to compare C4 number
respectively two
is less than our mean which our mean
previously was 20 that is going to be
true and it's going to assign our 2 to
our mean so if you run this code now
now you're going to see that the minimum
value is not 20 but it's but it's two
and after that we return this value to
the function which is called
so now get the minion values 2 which is
correct so this is how this uh code
works
and see you in the next video so now
it's time to start a discussion about
object orientated programming and
particularly in this video we're gonna
look at classes and objects but first
i'm going to create a new project
I'm going to call it op
for the language select Catalin and for
the build system IntelliJ make sure to
have the jdk selected and also I'm gonna
check this little box because this ad
sample code is going to add the main
function and that code for us
so I'm going to click on create to
create the project
now I'm going to delete this code
and I'm going to hide the project pane
now what is object oriented programming
object orientated programming is a way
of writing code in a sense in the way
you think about the real world so in the
real world we have objects
which can interact with it with each
other and which can do stuff but the
objects in the real world
have two major characteristics first is
the state so another the state of an
object in real life is represented let's
say that we think about of a car
the state is represented by the color of
that car by the number
of Gears that car has by uh by the brand
name of that car so this is the state of
a car the next thing that real life
objects have is functionality
so objects can do stuff so let's take
again the example of a car
a car can move a car can stop a car can
switch gears so
objects in real life have this uh though
this those two characteristics is those
two major character characteristics
represented by the state and the
functionality and the aim of object
orientative programming is to construct
objects using code in the way they are
they in the way they are in the real
life
but uh to do that let's say that you
want to build an object an actual object
in real life what you first need to do
the first thing that you need to do you
need to create a template or a
construction plan for creating that
object in which you're gonna Define the
generic things that a car has
and in programming you will do the same
thing but instead of using a piece of
paper or uh or a something
on on your PC to draw that that template
in programming you're going to use a
class so the class is used to create the
template which then is going to be used
to create an actual object an object
which is going to have a specific State
and a specific functionality
so um
in a way you can think that
the real world serves here as a model
for us to write code
and in this way in by combining uh the
state and the functionality in one
entity and have an object and as you can
see you can also have
like in the real life objects
communicating with each other you're
gonna see that this is really powerful
because you can you can model your code
in a more dynamic in a more you know
more create creative way so this is what
we're gonna do next so first let's say
that I want to create an object of type
car
and to do that we go down here and we
need to Define as I said the
construction plan the template for
building an object and in this case
we're going to build the car object so
we're going to Define what is called a
class and type the keyword class
now we need to name our class I'm going
to call it car and the name of the of
the
class should start with the capital
letter and if it has multiple words it
should be in Pascal case
curly braces
and press enter now inside the color
braces we need to define the state and
the functionality as I said for the
objects that are going to be built with
this template
and to do that we need to use variables
first for the state or
or in the context of object orientated
programming and more specifically in the
context of
classes they are called the classes and
objects they are called properties
and we Define them like we Define a
simple variable we Type R and the next
the first thing that that a car has is a
name or brand name so we're gonna type
name
but we cannot keep this variable
uninitialized we need to provide the
value to it and I'm going to put an
empty string
for uh for now so it's gonna have the
default value an empty string
the next thing is the model what kind of
model this car is so it's going to be
also a string I'm gonna assign an empty
string
the next property is going to be called
the color it's going to be also an empty
string
and the next property is going to be
called doors so this is going to store
the number of doors that a specific
object which is going to be built with
this template is going to have and we're
gonna put zero I'm gonna put zero now
we need to Define some functionality for
this class and for the objects for an
implicit for the objects that are going
to be built with this class
and um I'm gonna add two functions first
one is going to be called move
it's not going to take any parameters
it's gonna just output some text to the
console which is going to say that the
car is moving so we put quotation marks
the card is moving
now I'm gonna Define another function
call stop
also it's not going to take any
parameters it's gonna just outpost on
this the console it's gonna it's gonna
say that the car has stopped
now
we have the template we defined what our
car is gonna
have now we need to create an actual or
object an actual and specific object
using this template and to do that to
firstly declare a variable
and it's going to be a Val and I'm going
to call it car one so so our object is
going to be stored in this variable car
one
then you put equals and we type car and
now we have some suggestions and we have
our car that we Define below our car
class so we press enter then we put
parenthesis
so now we have created an actual object
a real object real in the programming
sense
and
which but now this actual object was
also this is called the instantiation
because we created an actual instance
but we don't need to bother with these
names for now
so we created an actual object using
this template that we have below but the
the properties of these specific objects
are those properties that we Define here
those default properties and to Define
some specific profit some specific
values to these properties that this car
object that created has we need to type
car one
dot so this is called informally dot
notation
and now we have some suggestions so we
have our properties that we defined for
a car
and now we type car one dot and we
choose the name
and now I'm going to assign a value to
this name I'm going to be called Tesla
so now our car one
object that was created has the property
name
Tesla now we do the same thing for the
next property for the model car one dot
model
press enter
and you put we put here s blade so the
model
next we also type car one
Dot now we're gonna assign a value to
the property caller
it's going to be red
next we type also car one and we Define
for the property names for the property
doors also value so we're gonna put here
four
so now our object R1
has for its property for for its
properties some specific values
respectively have for the name Tesla for
the model as played for the car for the
color red and for the doors 4.
so now let's output the property values
of this object that we created in the
console and to do that we put our
println function down here we put
quotation marks inside the parenthesis
because I'm gonna add some text here so
I'm going to type name
equals we put dollar sign then input
curly braces and inside the calibration
type
car one dot
name
and this is going to return the
the value of the property name for the
car one object that we created
respectively is going to return Tesla
let's press Ctrl d three times to do the
same thing for the next properties and
here we put car one dot model so this is
gonna return the
value of the model property
you're gonna put color
and here
I'm gonna type doors
now if you run this code
we get name Tesla
actually let's change the text here to
model to match the property name
model
color
endorse
so now if you're on this
we get the name Tesla Model is played
color red and doors 4 and those are the
values of the properties of this object
that we created here with our
template car
next what you can also do because in the
class we Define the two function we can
call those functions on this object that
we created
and to do that we also use the dot
notation we type car one
dot move and this is going to call the
move function
which is inside the car one
object
let's also
type car one dot stop to call the store
function so now if you run this code
we get uh
the values of our to our properties and
then we get the car is moving and the
car has stopped so the car one dot move
and car one the stop is calling the
functions
on this object that we created here now
let's uh
also add inside the functions
the name of the card that is moving so
he to do that with here dollar sign
inside the class
and we type name
and this is gonna reference this
property name that is defined here
let's also do the same thing for the
stop function let's type name
and now what this is gonna do because
those functions are in they are they're
living inside this object that we
created here car one and this object has
the name Tesla when those functions are
going to be called
they they gonna they're gonna say that
the car
and the name of the car which is in our
case for our objectives Tesla is moving
and then it's gonna say
the car again Tesla has stopped because
they are calling this uh specific object
that we created which has uh those
specific values for its properties
all right so now if you run this quad
we get as expected the car Tesla is
moving and the car Tesla has stopped so
the functions are called on this object
that we Define here and it's using the
property values that we Define for this
object
but as I said with uh you can create as
many objects as you want using the same
template and let's do that let's create
another object so I'm going to type here
Val
Car Tool
let's put equals we type car and then we
put parenthesis
and this create is now another object
but we need to Define some values to its
properties because now the values for
the properties are the default values
that we Define inside the class
respectively the empty string and the
zero
and to do that we type here car2
dot name
so now we are calling the properties
for the car 2 object and now we Define
some values to the cut to the properties
of the car 2 object so they are
this here is not overending
the value that we have here because
this
thing that we have here it's a distinct
object in memory uh from this object
they are this thing distinct objects and
they have their own properties with
their own values and their own functions
and now let's put here Ford
let's put the car to that model
let's put Mustang
let's put
car to that
color
blue
and for the doors let's put two
car two that doors
equals to two and let's output those
values in the console so let's output
the values of the properties for this
second object that we created in the
console and to that to do that I'm going
to copy this code
I'm gonna paste the paste it below here
and now I'm just gonna change
the
the variable to car two to to call to
call the properties on the cartoon
object so we put here car2
so now we're calling the properties
values on our car to object
and now if
I run this code
now we get name Ford Model Mustang color
blue endorseful and the first part is
from the our SEC for from our first
object which is named Tesla Model let's
play The Red Doors 4 and the Carter
slice movie and the cards has stopped
but let's add a space here
to make a clear uh to make a clear which
to make uh clear that this is the output
for the second object to make things
more clear and to add the space we put
here a printerland
statement we put quotation marks and we
put a backslash
n and this is going to add a space
between our println statements so it's
going to add a space between those
statements and we uh and those so now if
you run this code
let's increase this
we get the name Tesla so this is our
first object model let's play it called
Red Doors 4 The Carter size moving
because we're calling the functions on
the first object and the character has
stopped and then we get name Ford Model
Mustang color blue Doors 2 and we have
our space because you put here this
backflash and which adds that space for
us
let's um decrease this
and let's also call the functions the
move install functions on the second
object so I'm going to type here car2
that move
and card two dot stop
so now if you run this
let's
right click and just click on run
main.kt
now get
our first object which is with this uh
value for the value of the value for its
properties and then we get the two
functions called on our first object and
um
we get in our second object which is
values for its properties and then we
get the card for this moving and the car
Ford has stopped because now
um
we're calling the functions on the this
second object and this second object has
the value for the properties has has
different values for its properties so
this is why you get the card for this
movie and the car four has stopped again
they are different
objects they are distinct objects
created using the same template the same
construction plan
and
I'm gonna end this video now and see you
in the next video
so in the last video we saw how we can
create a class and then how we can
Define some properties and some
functionality to that class then we use
that class to create two objects and
then we defined for those objects for
the property of those objects some
values but the way we we Define values
to the properties of the object is to
call the the object and then the
property of logic and then we assign a
value and this is okay but if you have
more than than four properties let's say
you have 20 or 100 properties that will
be very tedious to write each one of
them and then assign a value
and a better way is to use what is
called a Constructor and as the name
implied The Constructor is used to
construct the object and the Constructor
is called at the time when we create a
new object so at the time of line we we
type this line of code when you finish
to type this line of code The
Constructor is called immediately so
that is the
the time where we need to pass the
values to our properties and to do that
we go down here where we Define our
class
we put
at the at the end of our
end of the name of the class we put
parenthesis and here we Define some
parameters the way we Define parameters
for functions
and the first one is going to be called
name it's going to be a string
the second one is going to be model
also string
the next one
color also string
and the last one is going to be doors
and this is going to be an integer
no we need to
assign whatever value values pass to
those parameters to the properties of
the class here and to do that just
delete the empty string here and type
name
and as I'm typing you see that we have
name and it has this p and this P stands
for prop for a parameter so you're
saying do you mean this parameter that
we Define up here and then we press
enter to fill that for us
then put we type here model
color
and then
doors
now if you go up here we have some
errors because now the the
when you create the object the objects
is expecting for its Constructor some
values so if you hover over here inside
the parenthesis it says no value fast
for parameter color Doors Model and name
so if you and if you look down here you
see that it has this public Constructor
so now what we need to do is to pass the
value that you passed down here to to
the properties by calling the
calling them on the object is to pass
them directly in the Constructor and
then the values the arguments if you
want are going to be assigned to the
properties so I'm going to put here
and you have this hint name Tesla
then we put a comma
so we have the again the hint which is
very helpful so for the model we put a
splade
and then for the color
we put red
and for the number of doors four
all right so now this is more concise
and now this is doing the exact thing
that we did previously but this is more
concise and we're using the Constructor
to pass the those values to the
parameters that we Define here and then
those parameters going to be assigned to
the properties respectively with those
properties name model core and doors
you're gonna see what is the difference
between the properties and parameters in
uh in the next video now we have also an
error here because
this also express some values to its
Constructor so instead of putting those
values here we put up here
Ford
Mustang
blue
and
two
now we can delete this
because we already passed the values for
this second object for its properties
now if you look at the codes the code is
more concise and more and easier to read
now if you run this code
you will have the same output
because the code
works well
so now if you look at the console let's
increase this a little bit
let's scroll up you have the name Tesla
Model let's Place color red doors4 the
cartridge lights moving the cut Isla has
stopped so you have the same output as
previously and down for the second
object we have
we have a
the name Ford the model Mustang the
color blue Doors 2 and the Carphone is
moving in a car 4 has stopped so our
code works well now let's close the
console but if you go down here you'll
see that you have this um
this uh the properties colored so if you
hover over them it says the property is
excretely assigned to parameter name so
it can be declared directly in
Constructor
now what is saying here in other words
is that we can put the properties
directly in the Constructor so you don't
need to define the properties down here
and then assign the value that is passed
to the parameter to the property and
the difference between the properties
and parameters parameters is that the
properties respectively those that we
Define in the in the header of the class
inside the parentheses 0
in the Constructor
is that
the properties are not uh storing the
state of of the class they are mastering
the state of the object there they are
only here to to get whatever value we
pass here
so whatever value you pass here
and his job is to only get that value
and assign it to the property name so
only the the variables which are
declared declared inside the class are
storing ultimately the the state of that
object so uh if I delete let's say if I
delete this here
now we have an error here because the
property name um it says on our result
reference name create member property
card.name and that is because the
property name is not declared it's not
exit it's not it's not a it's not uh
it's not a characteristic of a car we
didn't Define a property name because
here the parameters the parameter name
is only there to get the value and then
pass the value to the property
but we can let's press Ctrl Z to put the
code
back
now the error disappeared because we
have the property declared but because
the only thing that we do here is to to
to get the value that is passed to the
property as an argument here and for the
next ones and then assign it to the
property we can put those directly in
the Constructor so to do that we just we
can hover over here and
let's hover over
and click on this light bulb and click
move to Constructor so now you have this
you have the same
the same thing the same thing but the
only difference is that we have this VAR
keyword in front and that is responsible
for changing the
changing the parameter into a property
so
let's do the same thing for the next
ones
move to Constructor
and now we don't have that error that we
don't have a property for our class
because never because they have the VAR
so if you put the VAR or the VAR keyword
before declaring the the the parameter
it is going to be converted into a
property
so now those are properties of our class
car so they are storing actually they
are storing the the value that you pass
to to them
for the project that we create so uh
it's not like previously where you have
the property the parameter and then the
value is passed to the property inside
the class
so now if you run this code
foreign
we have the exact same output
the only difference now this that this
is uh more concise we have the
properties declared the right directly
in the Constructor so we don't have
declare the parameters and then we
assign the value that is passed to those
parameters to properties so you can
declare the The Constructor like this if
you want so the question may arise when
to use properties and when to use
parameters and to to
to answer that question
um you have you need to have in mind
that if you want to do some if you want
to do some work before you assign the
value to the property
because in our case uh the value that is
passed here to the to the
property in this case is directly stored
in the property so we cannot add some
validation to check to see if uh I don't
know if this name is if it starts to a
specific letter or if it's if it's an
uppercase or because the value that is
passed
that is passed as an argument to the
property there I say property because
they are there there are no declared as
properties it is directly stored as uh
as a the state of the object so
if you want to to do some work before
you assign the value of the property you
need to declare it let's say let's say
that you want to Let's actually delete
this and I'm going to declare it as a
parameter so let's say that you want to
to to trim the space that is passed so
let's say that I put some spaces here
let's actually press Ctrl G to see what
is happening if I don't do that
all right
I press Ctrl Z too many times so
let's let's again Paul let's put some
spaces here so now if you run this code
let's run it again
[Music]
now because the value that is passed
as an argument here to the object car
one
is passed directly to the property so
it's stored in the property and we we
don't do nothing with it we have also
the space but if you want to to delete
that space currently we can do that
because the values pass directly to the
property and there is nothing that we
can do from that point
and to to change that we can declare the
the property that is defined here the
property name as a parameter first
and we can declare it down here
we can declare down here now the
property
and we can put equals and now we we pass
the the
parameter to the property so it's a sign
name here
but before before that value is assigned
to the property name we put that
stream
and that is going to remove the spaces
so that Rim is a function which is part
of the string class because the the data
the all the data size that we looked at
are also classes so you can call
functions on them the way we called
functions so not our on our objects
so name that trim removes the space so
in this case it removes the space that
we have here
and after that it's assigning the value
to the name property so now if you run
this code now now we have the space but
if you run the code
so let's go up
run the code
now as you can see the space is removed
because
we pass the value to the
parameter now name then the parameter
name trims.space and after that it's
assign the value to the property name so
in this case so in this can be a
scenario where you can uh where you can
declare the instead of declaring
directly here the property can declare
as a parameter but what do what what you
can do if you want to add more code than
just one line of code in that case we'll
need to use what is called the
initializer blocks but
um we're going to look at the
initializer blocks and uh other things
in the next video because this video is
long enough so see you in the next video
so in the last video we looked at
Constructors and how you can use
Constructors to construct your objects
and it was an alternative to defining
the values to the properties of the for
particular object
and we've also looked at how we can
Define the this Source I should say it's
also called the primary Constructor that
we have here the parenthesis and then
the parameters or the properties
and we've also talked about how we can
Define parameters or Constructor and
then how we can convert those parameters
directly into properties and I've also
talked a little bit about how and when
to use
parameters and properties but in this
video we'll continue our discussion
about parameters and properties and
specifically going to look at how we can
execute more than one line of code when
the object is created because
now when the object is created and we in
the last video we trimmed this space
that we have here
you can execute only this line of course
so if you want to add more line of
course here to do some
um to do a more complex validation we
can't because here we can put just one
line of code
and to add more than one line of code of
code they need to use what is called
initializer blocks and the initializer
blocks are as you'll see some blocks
where we can put our code and you can
put more than online so forth you can
put as many lines of code you want and
that code is going to be executed when
an object is created on an instance of
our car of our of your class is going to
be created
so um this is what we're gonna do in
this video also I should say that you
can declare the class in another file
not just in this file like we did here
so we can open now the project pane
you can go to SRC go domain
go to kotlin
and here on kotlin you can right click
select kotlin class file
and from here make sure to select file
and I'm going to call this file classes
because you're going to put our classes
respect we're going to put our card
class but you can put more classes there
and uh
we're just going to copy this class that
we defined here
Ctrl C
and paste it here
now I have an error because this is
declared two times here and here and we
just delete it from here
and now the arrow disappears
and if you run this code
we get the same output because our code
works
perfectly well now the only difference
is that now we will put we put our class
in a different file and my suggestion is
for you is to put the class if you want
in a different fly file
because in this way you have the code in
when I'm going to organize the way
because here you have your class here we
have the code the objects that we
created with that class
and so on
no
for this video I'm gonna use I'm gonna
create a different class and
to do to do that I'm gonna declare
another class but I'm going to declare
it down here and I'm going to delete the
code that we have here
because we're going to use a different
class
and the class is going to be called user
so it's gonna represent the
the use and end user object so we type
here class
user now we create the Constructor the
primary Constructor we put parenthesis
we Define the parameters or the
properties for uh now I'm going to
Define directly the properties here so
we type here
keyword to have the property declared
VAR name
string so it's going to be we're going
to be store stacks
VAR
last name also string
and uh
VAR age this is going to be an integer
so this with this class we're going to
create some user objects I'm going to
put curly braces
and for now we're not gonna put any code
here so let's create a user so let's
type here Val
or let's call it user you can give it
whatever you want
so let's create a new object now so we
put
you type your user and then for the
parenthesis because I'm going to put
we're going to pass the values to the
Constructor here Sony to pass a name I'm
gonna type Alex
last name
no binka
and for the age 23
so now we created a new instance a new
object using the using the cluster to
Define below
but what if I want to to pass to to the
to the name
to the name name property only the the
names which starts with the letter A
in that case we need to declare this
property as a parameter first we need to
declare here the parameter and then to
declare the property below and before
before we assign the value that is
passed to to the property we need to do
some validation and if that argument
that is passed to the
parameter is starting with the ale
letter then you're going to assign the
value to the property name otherwise we
don't do that so to do that we need to
use initializer blocks because we're
gonna type more than one line of code
and the initializer blocks are used in
conjunction with the primary Constructor
so when we create a new object like we
did here the initializer blocks or the
initializer block is going to be called
immediately when the object is created
and to use an initial initializer block
we just but first let's declare let's
change this to to a parameter so let's
delete the VAR keyword in front of
the variable so now we have only a
parameter here now let's declare the
property down here
and now here we need to Define an
explicit type declaration so we need to
put here the type string because as I
said
um we're not going to assign the value
to the property directly here in one
line of code we're going to assign the
value to the property inside the
initializer blocked after we do the
validation respectively after we check
to see if the name that is passed to the
objects that we're going to create with
the class
starts with the letter a and if the the
name if the argument doesn't start with
the letter A then we're going to assign
an empty string and we're gonna output
something to the console so this is why
we need to provide here the type because
I'm not gonna
assign the value directly here so it
cannot infer what kind of data is going
to store
then you press enter
we type init
and here we have a suggestion we have
the unique keyword and then we have the
curly braces press enter
and now here we're gonna add our
validation and here we type if
parenthesis
now type name so now we're referring the
name parameter defined above here so if
name or the value that is passed to the
name parameter
first we're gonna
um
lowercase dot name
and to do that we type here name dot
lowercase because I want to have both
cases so if
if the user passes let's say a name of
the lowercase letter then we're gonna
check to see if it starts with OTA but
if the user passes the the name of the
an uppercase later we also want to check
to see if if that letter starts with a
and to cover both cases we lowercase the
input we lowercase the name so all the
lowercase all the letters then we put
here another Dot
starts with an input here
a
and if that is true
then we're gonna assign whatever value
was passed to the name parameter to the
name property
and we cannot type here name equals name
because now it's referring the
parameter here and to refer the property
that we Define here we need to use what
is called the disk keyword so the disk
keyword is used to refer them
properties of the class so it are here
this
so we're saying this name so now we have
this name and we have a different we
have this V variable here
then put equals
name so now we assign the value that is
passed to parameter only if that
valuable only if that value pass to the
parameter starts with the letter A then
we're gonna assign the name to the
property name
else if that is not true
put curly braces
and now we need to cover the else part
because if this is not true we also need
to pass a value to to the name proper
the name property cannot stay without a
value so we need to pass those over here
else we're going to put this
dot name
and I'm going to put
user so I'm going to put the user
text if the if the the name doesn't
start with the with the letter A
and we can also output some text.com so
we put println here
and we'll type the name
doesn't
start
with
the letter
a or
capital a
so now if you create a new object here
so we type here Val let's say for friend
we create a new object so we type user
now we need to pass the values to the
Constructor so you put here a let's say
uh
John
let's put
Smith
30. now because the the value that you
pass here to the parameter name doesn't
start with a letter a and start the
letter j
this value validation inside the
initializer block is going to be false
and then it's gonna it's gonna execute
the else part and it's going to assign
to the property name the user text and
it's going to Output the name doesn't
start with the letter A or a but if that
is not uh if but if it's true if it
starts with the letter A then this line
of code is going to basically the base
part n is going to be a sign it's going
to assign the value to the property
so now if you run the squad
we get the name doesn't start with the
letter A or a and it's correct our name
starts with the letter j
so if I put here let's say
Andhra
let's change this to
oh let's see here also
Smith
now if I run this
now we have no output because the this
the initializer block is is called
and the If part is evalu is to true and
it's assigning the the name
Andra to our name property so let's add
the print and then down here to see that
that is correct so print
let's print the value of
of the property name for our friend
object and we put here
and here we type
dollar sign
you put curly braces and you type friend
Dot
name
so now if you run this let's close
get name under let's put comma here
let's put
colon here
so our initializer blocked is called the
code inside the initializer block this
execute it and then this if check
average to true and then and then it
assigns the name Andra to our property
name but if we I put here John
let's type it like this let's say to see
that it's working because we lowercase
the letters
okay the name doesn't start with the
letter A or a name user so the
initializer block is executed
immediately when the object is created
and
the code incidential log is called it
checks to see if it starts at the lower
it starts with the with the letter A
and if not then it is assigned to the
property name user so we have this we
have user here
and then it outputs uh
this
text to the console so this is how we
can use the initializer blocks in
conjunction with the primary Constructor
and you can also put more initializer
blocks and the order in which you put
the initializer blocks matters in the
sense that the word in which you define
the initializer blocked is is going to
be the word in which they are executed
so the word in which you define them
it's important but most of the time I
think you'll you use only one
initializer block to put your code so
this is our discussion about initializer
blocks and in the next video we're going
to look at um
because
we talked about the primary Constructors
there is a another type of Constructor
which is called the secondary
Constructor of this secondary
Constructors
and we can also look at the default
parameters because you can put you can
we can Define default values to the
properties also the parameters of the
Constructor so we're gonna do that we're
going to do that in the next video
I'm gonna end this video a little now
so now it's time to start a discussion
about secondary Constructors because
besides our primary Constructor that we
Define and that we talked about in
Cotton you can Define multiple
Constructors and those are called the
secondary Constructors
now you may be wondering why you will
need secondary Constructors
and to answer that question we need to
consider the user class and those user
objects that you can create so let's say
that an user
only provides its first name and for the
property is last name and the age
doesn't provide any value in that case
you will need the you need a way to to
Define some default values for those
properties in case the user only
provides the first name
and uh
if let's say the next user does provide
the the first name and the last name and
the age in that case you're gonna use uh
the the primary Constructor but if it
doesn't provide those uh those values
then you're gonna use the secondary
Constructor but to make this more clear
lists uh let's add the code and we talk
we talk about was while I am writing the
code so let's delete the initializer
blocks that we have here because you
don't need this code
and let's also put the property now
let's define the property in the primary
Constructor so let's just put here a
VAR the work here in front of the
variable
let's also delete this printalian
and um
let's delete the values here
for the last name and the age so now as
you can see we have an error because
it's expecting here the
um it's expecting an argument a value
for the last name and for the age and to
solve that problem we just go down here
and we type Constructor so this is the
keyword for declaring the secondary
Constructor
and we press enter to fill in that for
us and we put parentheses and now here
in the parenthesis we Define the
parameters and I am specifically saying
parameters because as you will see the
secondary Constructors cannot declare
properties they can only declare
parameters because
anyway Let's uh so let's define here the
parameter so I'm gonna type here name
let's put here the type of this variable
is going to be a string
now if you hover over here
it says primary Constructor called
aspect insert this call so what all the
secondary Constructors need to do is
they need to call the primary
Constructor because ultimately the
primary Constructor is the one which
declares the property the properties for
the class and stores the values for uh
of that Pro of that property and to do
that to put here
colon
we type this
so we put colon this type that this
keyword then you put parenthesis
and
to the disc call we pass the name so
this name that we defined here
and for the next two values we're going
to pass some default values so here I'm
going to put user because let's say that
because as I said in the beginning this
user is gonna not it's not gonna provide
the last name so let's put your last
name not user last
name
and for the age let's put
let's put let's say zero
all right now
what this is going to do is now if you
look up here don't have an error so
let's uh so now we don't have that error
because now it's using the secondary
Constructor is passing the value here
Alex to the secondary Constructor that
we Define here and here we Define only
the parameter and the value that is
passed as parameter then
is passed to this to the primary
Constructor because by putting colon and
these and parenthesis we're calling now
the primary Constructor
and is the primary Constructor the one
which
ultimately declares the property and
stores whatever value we send to him in
this case we send
the value Alex and for the last name we
uh we just send the last the text last
name and for the age you put 0 because
this is our way to saying that this user
doesn't want to provide its age so this
is why you need to call the the primary
Constructor from the secondary
Constructor because again the secondary
the primary Constructor is the one which
ultimately declares the properties of
the classes the one which stores the the
the properties of the class the
secondary Constructor only
only takes parameters and then calls the
primary Constructor so in fact if you
put here the VAR keyword
you have an arrow which says
Varon secondary Constructor parameter is
not allowed that is because the
secondary Constructor cannot call it
cannot declare properties
only the primary Constructor
and because as I said you can declare
multiple second Constructors we can type
here
Constructor so we can declare another
secondary Constructor and here you can
put
name
here we put string
then we type last name also string so
this secondary Constructor is only going
to take
the
name and the last name as arguments the
age is not gonna this uh is gonna not
gonna take any value for the age now we
need to put colon
we type this parenthesis because now
we're calling the
primary Constructor and here we we pass
the name that is passed to this
secondary Constructor this that we
Define here
the last name
and for the age we're going to put 0
because this uh
this second secondary Constructor
doesn't
take any value any arguments for its uh
for its age
but because as I said ultimately the
primary Constructor is the one which
defines the properties we cannot we
cannot call the prime Constructor and
not pass any value so we pass this
default value here
and uh
so now if you go up here and let's say
that I delete the age
now our code works fine because now what
is happening here is this the the value
for the
for the name and the last name is passed
to this secondary Constructor this one
here
and the secondary Constructor then calls
this primary Constructor and it's
passing the two values to the Primal
structure name respectively this name
John and last name Smith and for the age
it passes the default volume zero so
this is how you can this is why we can
pass here uh
this this is why you can avoid here to
pass let's say uh you can avoid to pass
the last name and the age for the first
because it is using the first secondary
Constructor
and this object that we created here
it's using this secondary Constructor
because here we're passing only the
first name for the value for the first
name property and the value for the last
name property so it's passing them to
this secondary Constructor which then in
turn calls the primary Constructor it
passes them to the primary Constructor
so it passes the
the values for the two properties and
the last one is defaulted because
okay because you don't provide the value
for the age
with Pro with secondary Constructors you
can also put you can at the end of the
call of the primary consultor you can
put curly braces
to have some code executed when you
create an object with that specific uh
secondary Constructor so you can put
here curly braces and inside the color
blades you can have some code which is
going to be executed you want to create
an object with this let's say secondary
Constructor
an object with this secondary
so it's up to you what the code you put
there but to illustrate this let's put a
println statement here in the
in this secondary Constructor so let's
type here println and here I'm going to
type
second and I'm going to type second
because uh
this is the first Constructor this is
the primary Constructor and this is the
one which ultimately does all the work
is the one which stores the value for uh
the properties
and this is the third
Constructor so let's copy this
let's put here to Third
just for illustration
Also let's output in the console the
value of the the property values for
these objects so let's type here
printerland
and just type here name
equals let's put dollar sign
let's put curly braces
let's use our user
variable now let's call the properties
on this public so let's type name
now let's press Ctrl d
two times and let's put here now
last name
and the age
and let's also other space between
the information about the two objects to
make things more clear so let's put the
printer and heroes and put a backslash
in here
and let's copy the code that we have
here let's paste it below
let's change this
object to our friend object that we
created just like your friend
and I'm gonna speed this now a little
bit because
it will take some
now let's output this information in the
console
so now what we have is we have
we have
second and then third because this first
object is using the
the second Constructor
so this is why we have here a
second
and then the next line of code is called
and we have third because this one this
object that you have here the front
object it's using the third Constructor
this secondary Constructor so this I
have here third
then we have the values for the
properties for the I didn't have the
values for the properties of the user
object so you have
here the output
down here
and
then we scroll down and have name John
last name Smith age
zero because we have a
the property values for the second
object for this object
and this is okay this works completely
fine the thing to have in mind is that
now we're using the secondary
Constructors and the secondary
Constructor then calls the primary
Constructor and the primary Constructor
is the one which ultimately stores the
value source which ultimately declares
the properties and stored the values
but one thing to notice in the output is
that the first object has the name
Alex and the last name last name and age
zero that is because the first object is
only
taking a value for the first name
property or for the name property
and for the last name and the age
because it's using this secondary
Constructor is only passing in the first
name which is Alex that we have here
and then it's using the default values
last name and a zero it's passing those
default default values to the primary
Constructor so it's calling the primary
Constructor is passing the value Alex
and then the default value last name and
zero this is why I have last name and 0
here and for the next one we have
name John and last name Smith this is
because now this is using um the next
secondary Constructor and that takes as
arguments the name and the last name and
then it's calling the primary
Constructor it passes the
first name and the last name and the
aegi is defaulty so you have zero so
this way you have here John and Smith
and then zero so it's important to
to notice this and to think about how
this uh to think about this thing
so this is our discussion about multiple
Constructors respectively about
secondary Constructors in this video you
saw how you can
pass a different number of values to our
properties ultimately you pass all the
values to the properties by calling the
primary Constructor and providing
default values because in this way you
can satisfy all the possible cases so if
in our case one user only provides the
name and the last name is not provided
and the age is going to use the this
secondary Constructor and it's going to
pass the last name as default and the
zero and this is uh in a way
similar to overloading functions but is
not the same because what you're doing
here is overloading the constructors and
this in this way you can you can think
about
why why we're overloading the
constructors and that is because
if we didn't have secondary Constructors
we would have to create another class
with a different number of parameters
or the different number of
properties and we will need to to create
each object with that specific class
let's say that we create this object
which only takes a value for its
parameter name then we have to create a
class which we're going to Define only
the name property and it's gonna then
we're gonna create that obviously with
that class
and if an object if an object
let's say if an user creates uh if your
user doesn't
providing the the name and the last name
but now the age you have to create
another class with only the name and the
last name defined as its properties and
you can see that this this uh is uh this
will generate uh duplicated code and so
on and we can solve all of this by using
secondary Constructors and
calling the
primary Constructor so see you on the
next video and because quoting is about
conciseness in the next video we're
going to look at how we can do the same
thing that we have here with default
parameters because
um
kotlin supports for its properties for
its parameters in the constructed
default values so the same thing that we
have here can be achieved by providing
default values to the properties so see
in the next video
so now it's time to look at default
values for our properties and first
let's delete the secondary Constructors
and now I have a
error series because it expects the
value
expecting the values for the next
properties here
and um
let's also change this to
to first name because I refer to it to
the first name but it was called This is
it is called name so let's call it first
name so go right click on it
go to rename and then to refactor
to change it in all the places and let's
call it
first name and as you can see now let's
change it in all the place then press
enter
so now we have the first name and the
default properties are default values to
our properties are basically they are
similar to default values that we
provide to our parameters when we talked
about functions
then what we do is uh
let's say that I wanted to provide the
default value for the last name we just
put equals so inside the primary
Constructor we put equals and here we
put let's say
last name so now this has the last name
as a default value if a value is not
provided for the last name and here you
can put also equals
n equals zero and now the error as you
can see disappeared from both of our
objects because now
what is doing is when we don't provide
the value for the
last name and for the age then the
default values that we provide here is
going to be are going to be used as the
values for the properties so this is a
way of achieving the same thing that we
achieved previously with the secondary
Constructor but this is more concise
and the question is when to use one on
one or the other is
the um the answer may be if you want to
execute some code when an object is
created let's say
with one of the
let's say if you wanted to if you want
to exit some code when you create an
object then you can use secondary
Constructor because as I said secondary
Constructors can have a block of code
when uh which can be executed but the
this uh the default because primary
Constructor does not don't don't have a
don't have a block of code they you
cannot do that maybe you could use a
initializer blocks
but that is uh open to discussion
so this is how you can provide the four
values to
to the primary Constructor
in our code was fine it's
In This Very concise very beautiful and
the next thing that you can do is that
you can also use named arguments so you
can use the because here you use the
first name and the last name and if I um
because those are those are both strings
here you cannot see the distinction but
if I put here uh now I can use the name
argument so I can put your first name
equals so it's similar to the way we
have name arguments in our function and
here you can put the text
John
also here and this uh
with this thing you can you can change
the order in which you need to define
the values for the parameter so let's
put your last name
but we'll say this better let's create
another object
is
user 2
let's type user
and let's put here you wanna
but let's use the name arrowman so let's
put first the age so we're going to
provide the value for the age let's say
um
19.
and um
Let's uh let's type first name so here
let's put um
IWANNA because it's a string
quotation marks
and for the last name let's say
let's type also the name argument last
name and for the last name let's put
here um
Dobby
let's say
right so what we did here is that
in the primary Constructor the order for
for the properties very specific we have
the first name and the last name and
then we have the age but with the name
arguments we first provided the age
so we provided a value for the age
product which is the last one so and
then you provide the value for the first
name and with the name arguments similar
to the way used in our functions you can
pass the values to the properties in
which order you want irrespective of the
word in which they defined here so this
is very powerful if you
if you ask me it's very interesting
because you can pass the values to the
properties irrespective of the world in
which they are defined
so this is our discussion about default
parameters and the name argument in
with the primary Constructor and you
cannot use default parameters name
arguments with the secondary
Constructors they can only be used the
primary Constructor
so see you in the next video
but uh before I end the video Let's
actually run this code to see that it
works in the same way it was working in
previously when we use the secondary
Constructors
so let's run this code
so you have name Alex last name last
name because it's using this default
value that defined here then we have h0
because it's using this value of defined
here so this is
this object
and then we have name John last name
Smith a0 because now it's using this
default value so the same thing can be
achieved using um
default parameters and we didn't
output the values for the
for the second for the third object that
you created here in user 2 but you can
do that as a
as a challenge for if you want you can
output the values for this object so see
you in the next video
so now it's time to start a discussion
about Getters and Setters because so far
enough videos even though we didn't see
explicitly the Getters and Setters here
we've used the Getters and Setters every
time we got the value of a property and
every time we assign a new value to a
property
and um
the getter and Setter in kotlin are
implicit so they they are declared they
are Auto auto generated by default by
color by cutling for you so every time
you and let's say you get the value of
an object let's say let's get the value
of the user that's first name what
actually happens here is not that we're
getting the value of the first name
directly even though if you look at the
code this what it seems to be what has
happened is that every time we get the
value of of a property that value is
returned by the getter so you never
access the property directly and you
never never does change the the property
of uh the value of a property directly
you every you every time you you are
using the Getters and setters
and now this discussion is touching on
on a very important Concept in quadrant
programming and that is encapsulation so
encapsulation basically means to
to protect to hide the inner workings of
the class from being accessed outside
and if you look at this syntax that we
have here it seems that we actually
accessing the values the properties
directly but as I said that is not the
case because we're always using the
getter and the setter and because we
always use use the Getters and the
Setters the getter to get the value and
the set to to change the value of
property
that means that your data your
properties are never accessed directly
thus the laws of encapsulation are not
broken the the in other words you you
never allow somebody outside of the
class to access directly that property
so this is why uh
this is why we have Getters and Setters
and this is why the Getters and Setters
in Kathleen are implicit so they are not
even declared explicitly here we don't
see any
code which it will imply that we have a
get a Setter here because they are
automatically and by default generated
every time you define a property so
every time you define a property either
in the primary Constructor or
inside the class the
Getters and the get the getter and
Setters automatically generated for you
but uh let's say that you want to
override the getter and Setter to
provide some additional
additional code to the code that is by
the by default provided you can do that
by changing let's say
this property to a parameter
and to override the getter in Setter and
to see how the Getters and Setters
actually look under the covers
just type here VAR
we Define the property first name
we assign the first name parameter
property now the Getters and Setter need
to need to be overrated
immediately after the with after we
Define the property so we cannot have
some code here and then to override you
can to override the getter and Setter so
we need to
we need we need to Define them
immediately after we we Define the
property so we type here get
and as an attempting you see that I have
some suggestions then you go down here
you and you can choose you choose this
one
so you have parentheses curl braces and
inside the curly braces you press enter
here you type return
field I'm going to explain immediately
what is this
and now we need to override the setter
and to do that to just type set and I
have some suggestions
we also go down here we choose this one
press enter and hero type
field again this
under this identifier and input equals
to value
so this is the implicit code that is
generated that is auto-generated by
kotlin for you every time you you you
define a property in your class either
in the as I said in the primary sector
or inside the class
so because in fact if you look here we
have some underlines and if you hover
over here it says redundant getter
remove redundant getter because uh and
also for the set it under setup because
they are redundant because they are
implicitly again Auto generated by
cotton for you so this quad is redundant
here you don't need this code because
Scotland already provides this code
under the covers for you but if you're
not such satisfied with this quad with
this implicit code that is uh Auto
generated by cotton can you can um you
can override them like we did here and
provide some additional code so we can
put here let's say some text
so so that every time we get the value
of our
we get the value of our first name
property you're gonna have a pretty
pretty prefix and let's put here a first
name
let's put the colon dollar sign
and field we're gonna play I'm gonna
explain immediately what this field is
but let's say first however
how this works and here let's put a
printerland to print a value that is
passed to the setter and then assigned
to the first name property so let's put
here dollar sign
value was
assigned
to First
foreign
now I have name so we have our text that
we have here name and then have first
name Alex let's actually delete this
text to make things more clear
let's delete this text
let's delete this
now let's run this code again
so what we have now is that every time
we get the value of our property name we
have we have that prefix first name that
we have uh overwritten here in the in
the getter so the getter is called as I
said the value is returned by the getter
so together is called it Returns the
value of the first name property so this
field is is the first name property but
is uh it has this identifier field
because of uh of an important reason
which I'm gonna explain immediately so
it Returns the value of the first name
property
with the prefix first name and we have
first name the text that we have here
then I have the value of the first name
property we have Alex in our case
because our object has the name Alex as
the property name Alex
then for the
for the setter we don't have any code
here also we have the first name prefix
for John so our our every time we get uh
we get the first name property by
of our objects created by by using the
user class it gets that value it returns
that value through the getter and the
setter we don't have value was assigned
to first name property because the
setter is called only one we change the
value of uh of uh of our properties and
to do that we type user like we did in
our first video about objects or another
programming
DOT first name
equals let's say
oh
let's put here
Vlad
so now if I run this code
now the setter is going to be called
because the setter is called as I said
only when it we change the value of our
of our of of our property
so we get uh
get Vlad was assigned to first name
property so the code inside the setter
was called
because this code that we type here is
calling the setter so our code only only
always goes to the setter and the code
that we have here user that first name
Vlad what it's actually doing is
passing that value Vlad to
here so this for this uh this parameter
it that we have here is receiving the
value of Vlad and then that value is
assigned to first name property again we
have this field the identifier for a
reason and the reason is going to be
explained immediately
so uh
the Getters and Setters are working well
and they are as they said again the use
always when we get or
assign a new value to our properties
now what is this field identifier why I
didn't
type here uh
first name and here I didn't put uh
first name equals to Value so whatever
value is passed to the setter then that
value is assigned to the first name
property so why
why don't we don't do that
and um the reason uh for that is that
because
this syntax user.first name user first
name
user.first name equals Vlad is calling
the setter
if we put here first name equals value
so first name equals Alex it will be
equivalent to to call the setter again
so this line of code that we have here
it will call the setter again it will
pass the value to the center and then it
will assign the value again to the first
name so it will call the Center inside
the setter forever it will be it will
generate an error and to avoid the that
recursive call that infinite call we
need to use this field identifier so the
field in an identifier is the first name
property but it has this
special
use that it bypasses that error that it
will be generated if you use the first
name here
so in fact let's um
let's put here a first name to see
so if we put here first name
instead of field
and we have an error here
let's put here a
field
because
I want uh I want the error from the
setter to to get in the console not
there or from this thing here so now if
you run the squad
as I said that will generate a recursive
call it will call the getter over and
over
so get the error
so you see we have Vlad was assigned to
first name property Vlad was assigned to
first name property vad and so on that
is because
the setter
it's calling the setter forever
it's a recourse of call because this
line of code here it's calling the
setter it's it's a assigning the value
to the sending the value to the seta
then it's that values assigned again to
the first name property which in turn
close again the setter and so on so this
field the identifier is used because it
has this characteristic of
bypassing that error this is why we're
using the field instead of the first
name
property here and it's basically the
first name property but it has this
specific characteristics which
characteristics which bypasses the
recursive call which we got when we've
used the first name property
now if you run the code
now I have no error because the recourse
of call is not happening because you're
using the field which bypasses that
error
so this is why we're using uh and we're
having an encodone has this thing filled
and this the field can only be used
inside the getter or the setter not uh
not anywhere else also either getter or
the setter
and the same is true about the getter
this is why you need to use the field
identifier inside the getter also
because it will generate the recursive
call again
now to to illustrate better because you
maybe find the
confusing this discussion about Getters
and Setters what they really
are they are equivalent to having two
functions which
update the first name property and
return the first name property so they
they are equivalent to having
a function called Set uh
first name
and this function defines a parameter
called let's call it new value
is going to be of type string
let's put curly braces and here we type
this DOT first name
equals
new value
and the geta equivalent to having a
function
called
get
first name
and this is not going to take any
parameter is going is we're going to say
say explicit here that it's going to
return a string because it's gonna only
return a value
and this is going to return the first
name property
so we put here this
that first name so the getter and Setter
that we have here are similar this is uh
illustrative for you to have in mind to
having two functions which are setting
the first name property or updating the
first name property and are returning
let's change this to First
and are returning the first uh the value
of the first name property but because
constantly and it's about conciseness it
has this special syntax and they are
automatically generated for you because
uh as I said accordingly it's about
conciseness so you don't need to declare
those things every time you create a
class so let's delete this so have in
mind that under the covers is we have
something like this so let's delete this
now the arrow disappears
also you can have a shorter way of
writing the centering letter if you
don't provide some additional code so if
I delete this
and this
I can put here get equals field
and um
yes this is this okay because this is
like having a single line a single
function a single line expression
function because we're returning the
value to the function get so you can
write it like this because or I I show
you this photo because maybe you'll see
a written in this way and you may be
wondering why that's because this is
like having a a single body expression
function
so you can write it like this if you
want but again if you hover over this is
still already done let's so let's press
Ctrl G to have the previous code
so this is our discussion about Getters
and Setters and see you on the next
video
so now it's time to start a discussion
about the late init keyword and how we
can use the latent keyword with the our
properties but first let's delete the
code that we have from the previous
video because don't need this code let's
also delete this code
let's delete those two objects
that's
and lazil is property let's declare it
here so let's put the VAR keyword
and let's also delete the default values
here
and let's press Ctrl alt form on the
code
now we need to provide the values here
because we don't have default values for
the last name property and the age so
I'm going to type here
dobbyn let's say
age 23.
now
as you already know if you declare
inside the class
a property let's say that that property
is called favorite movie and it's going
to store the favorite movie of the user
you cannot let this variable
uninitialize so let's say that is going
to be of type string
so you cannot let this variable
uninitialize you need to provide a value
either by assigning directly
a literal value here or by receiving the
value through through a parameter
defined in the Constructor
but um that is not completely true
because
sometimes you'll want to to have a
property declared inside the class but
you don't have to assign a Twitter
valued uh right away so you want to
assign the value to the property later
and to be able to do that you need to
use the late init keyword and to use the
late neat keyword you just type here
late it and you have a suggestion later
need
and later need search for initialize
letter later so what we're saying here
is
initialize let later this property
favorite movies so you say in the to the
compiler hey I'm gonna
initialize this uh property favorite
movie but I'm gonna initialize it later
so believe me and uh
to do that you just
type user
that so you whatever object you create
with this class and you have a defined
latent property
favorite movie
and you put equals and then you put
let's say Interstellar here
so now we've initialized our favorite
movie property but we initialize the its
value later so we didn't provide the
value here directly inside the class
either by as I said by providing a
literal value or by
providing a value through the parameter
defined in the primary Constructor so
this is how you can use the
latent keyword if you want to
assign a value to a property later so
you don't want to assign the value
directly or or you don't want to cite
the the value more correctly said
right away so you want to assign the
value later you just put the latest
keyword in front of the property and
then you declare the property as
you the way you declare a simple
variable
right and if you don't initialize this
this property and you want a new output
the value in the console so let's say
that I put here a printerland
and I type user that
favorite movie
and I don't initialize it
and if I run this code now this
favorite movie property is not
initialized doesn't have a value
we're gonna have an error
and the error is uh
it's very specific
so you have exception thread main
kotlin unofficialized projects access
exception we have and then it says later
need property favorite movie has not
been initialized so it's very specific
in saying that hey you didn't you said
that you're going to initialize that
property but you didn't and uh down here
you try to to Output in the console the
value of the favorite movie but we don't
have provided a value and it's better to
have this uh this is called an exception
so it's better to have this energy Pro
and initialize property access exception
then having a null pointer pointer
exception because
this is why kotlin actually enforces
this behavior of uh
assigning values to the variable to the
variables so it Cotillion forces to
assign values to the variables and not
let them uninitialize because if you
don't initialize
uh you don't provide the value to a bear
to a variable or two property then when
you try to access that variable or that
property and let's say that you have an
app
that is gonna throw which is going to
throw what is called the null pointer
exception and that is very bad because
those kind of excursions are called only
at runtime and not at compile time so
your app can work let's say completely
well and when you press a button I don't
know to to see the the favorite movie of
a user then you get an error and adopt
crashes so this is why you need to avoid
those null pointer exceptions and kotlin
as I said enforces this behavior of
providing um
values always to the variables to the
end to the properties
and if you don't want to provide the
value to the
property then you can use this late on
it and it will show this uh different uh
exception called latent property
favorite movie has not finished so it's
it's a different exception than the null
pointer exception but with the latent
keyword we can still have as I said that
behavior of not initializing the
variable but you still need to
initialize it later because this one is
called late init
but this is not uh saying that the
latent
error that is shown here is not also uh
having the same behavior like the null
pointer exception that I talked about
because the late init error that is that
we have here
if you have an app it will uh also
Crusher up but the later neat keyword
allows us to not provide as I said the
value literally a little value here or a
value through the
constructed by the by assigning the
parameter here with the value pass of
the parameter
and the
is uh is our
responsibility to initialize that
variable later so that you don't get
into the same problems that we talked
about so we don't get this error so it's
up to you to
to declare a a property as late and
eaten then provide a value later because
if you don't it will also Crush you up
when you try to access uh by uh I don't
know in Europe somehow you want to
access the value of that property
so I always have a have a decent mind
that you need to initialize that
variable later
also I should say that the latent
keyword only works with
classes
and it does not work with primitive type
so even though the as I said the
integers and all the data types that we
looked at and also the
Boolean and Char are classes
we cannot use latent adhered with them
because if I put here in you can see
that I have an error
that it says latony modifiers not
allowed on properties of primitive types
because uh I'm not gonna get into much
of details but all we need to know to
know is that
when
the int class and all the Primitive
types which are classes uh at least
at the surface when they are compiled I
think they are compiled into primitive
types so they are not compiled into
classes so this I think is the reason
that you don't you can't use this latent
in the keyword but for other classes
because a string is is a data type but
it's a special data type as I said you
know in a previous previous video and
because of that you can use the latent
keyword and you can use the latent
latent keyword
with other classes so I can put here
user if you want
and it works because users is also class
is this class that we Define here
so it's good to to to remember this
now I'm going to end the video and see
you in the next video but first let's uh
press Ctrl G to have the code that you
had previously
so uh now I'm gonna end in the video and
see you in the next video
so now it's time to start a discussion
about companion object but to do that
I'm gonna delete the class that we have
here
and I'm going to paste it inside our
classes file because we're gonna need
this class later in our videos
and I'm gonna also delete this code
because you don't need this code
and let's say that
let's create the class called calculator
is not going to Define any properties
you know it's going to have a simple
function called sum which is going to
sum two numbers
so we're going to Define two parameters
here a
it's going to be an INT a b
also on it
n is going to return the sound so we put
colon at the end of our
parenthesis or function we put int
because this is what you're going to
return
and we put calibration type return a
plus b or you can put this in a single
body expression function so you can put
the code like this if you want
so we can put here uh you can also
delete a type you can put here equals
and this will work but I'm gonna
keep it like this
now if you want to use this sum function
that is defined in this uh
class calculator first you need to
create an object without class so we
type here Val I'm going to call it
calculator
and I'm gonna create here a new object
Constructor doesn't have any properties
any parameters and if you want to
to call that some function we need to
use our calculator
variable or I'll confrater object or
reference and we put dot like we did in
our research so use the dot notation so
now we're calling the sum function on
our calculator object that we created
online too let me put when we call our
function sum inside the buttons you pass
two numbers let's say 5 and 10.
and uh
let's capture this value that is
returned by the
by the function in a variable so let's
put here
Val result
because that is going to return the sum
of 5 and 10. of course that you can put
that in a printerland
statement if one but I put it in this
elaborate way to to make
more clear what you're doing and here
I'm going to type println
result
so now if I run the squad
you're gonna see 15 in output line in
the console
so let's increase this
so we have 15. and the way we did it is
we created an object like we did so many
times then we want that object use the
dot notation to curl that function on
that specific object on this object and
that function takes as arguments as easy
as
values to its parameters to integers we
pass 5 and 10 and then it returns as
well and we retain we
we capture that value in the result
variable and then we want to put that
value in the console and get 15. but um
if you think about the way we did this
thing is that the only way we can call
the sum function is by creating an
object and then calling the function on
that object but it doesn't make a lot of
sense if you have a calculator class
to call
to create every time through our code
every time you need to use the sound
function to create an object throughout
your code a better way it would be if
you could call that sum function
somehow without declaring uh without
creating an object and then using the
the object to call the function and to
you to do that we need to use what is
called a companion object and to use a
component object we go inside our class
we type companion object so we can press
enter to fill in a component object for
us or you can type that then we put
curly braces and inside the curl brace
you put our codes and in this case we're
going to put our sum function
now
you you're going to see something now we
have an error here
now this
function this sum function doesn't
belong to an object to an instance that
is created with the class calculator
instead it belongs to the class itself
and not to the not to any object that we
create
those the variables and the functions
that are the functions that are declared
inside the component object are also
called
class variables or
class functions because they don't
belong to they don't belong to a
specific object that you create with
that with that class instead they belong
to the class itself so you don't need an
instance to call that function and uh
that uh
implies that we can't use it with an
object because it belongs only to the
class and let's see how you can use it
using the class without creating an
object we just type calculator
dot sum and here you pass again
5 and 10. so
we just use our name or the name of our
class we put dot sum and now we can use
the function without uh then without us
needing to create an object and then
calling the function on that object so
this is a very powerful because uh
you will need this in your code
sometimes when you don't uh it it
actually doesn't make sense to create an
object every time you you call let's say
a sum function for a calculator
now we can also retain that value that
is written in a variable also result
put equals
now we can print this in the console
so we get also 15 but this time we
didn't create an object we didn't create
a new instance and we call that we call
the sum function on that object we just
type the calculator class and call that
function on directly on the class
all right so this is how you can use the
companion object
and this is also true for a variable so
if you put a variable here let's say Max
and you put an arbitrary number here
let's say 100
we can call this variable
also by typing calculator the name of
the class Dot and have our Max variable
uh like in contrast with how we did the
how you call the the properties in the
past by creating an object and using
that object to curl that property on
that object in this case you just use
the class and call the the variable and
this also can be can be useful if you
have some
constants to which you want to use in
our throughout your quad so let's delete
this so you can use also with variables
and if you think about uh
uh at our
one of our first lessons about the data
ties when you look at the minimum and
maximum value I I type something like
this Val Max
and I
to get the maximum volume I type int
that
max volume and this is using also a
companion object because as you can see
the integer class because the Primitive
types are also classes at least on the
surface
not when they are compiled on the jvm
they also use companion objects like we
have here to to get to to get the
properties and to get the functions
because you don't we didn't create an
instance of our integer of with our
integer class and then call that max
value on the object in fact if you hold
control on this integer class and if you
actually hover over it and after you
hold Ctrl it says
public companion object of int so if you
hold Ctrl and if you press and if you
press click now
it will open this primitives.kt file
and inside
primitive.gt if I have our end class and
we have a companion object inside the
companion you have this public constant
value we're going to look at the
constants in the negative but the point
here is that it's using the companion
object to to declare is declaring the
the this minimum value the maximum value
inside The Company audio so that you
don't need to create an instance an
object every time you need to use them
so
this is our discussion about compounding
object and see you on the next video I'm
going to close this file now
and if you if you want you can look you
can look in that Primitives file if you
want just take a look look what is there
so see in the next video
so now it's time to start a discussion
about Singleton but first i'm going to
copy this code I'm going to copy this
class with the companion object and I'm
going to paste it inside the classes
file
and if you don't have this code Discord
because you create a new project just
type the code that I'm going to type in
a second so let's delete the code inside
the main function
now what is a single then
a Singleton is a design pattern in
kotlin with which you want to have
only one instance of a particular web
object so you want to have only one
instance of a particular object and you
want to have that instance available
globally tutorial program so you don't
need to create an instance every time
you need to use that
that object in a different part of your
code
and there are
project practical reason for having only
one instance of a class let's say that
you have a database
you want to you want to have only one
instance of that database which creates
the database which gives the data and so
on because if you have multiple
instances if you able you are able to
create multiple objects with that class
then you'll have multiple databases in
your
phone or on our PC and that is not good
because you're using more memory than
you should and you have a duplicate
duplicated
duplicated and unnecessary code
so to solve that what we need to do is
to create only one instance of a
particular class and uh
having this example in mind this is what
we're gonna do next and first I'm going
to show you how we we did the
in the past how we created a Singleton
without having the object keyword so you
go down here
and first we're going to create a
Singleton in the world wave so we type
here class you're going to use our
example database not going to create a
real database we're gonna just use this
as an example
and to make to restrict the creation of
instances with this database class we
need to make the Constructor private so
we type private and uh when you use an
access modifier with the primary
Constructor you need to use the
Constructor keyword other otherwise will
have an error so if I delete the
Constructor keyword here
I have an error which says
after modifiers or Pro of primary
Constructors so we put Constructor
and inside the
inside the glass
now because we cannot create instances
of this class that means that we cannot
uh access any of the properties or the
functions of this class and to to to
have access to a function which is going
to return an instance of this class we
need to use a companion object because
with companion like this you can have
properties and functions being allowed
to being to be accessed outside of the
class without creating an instance
and here we type again
the private access modifier we call this
instance and it's going to be a database
a nullable database
should be valid there
instance
database and as I said nullable so we
can assign null to it
then we Define a function called get
instance
and this function is going to return an
instance so for instance of our database
class
only one instance one one single
instance not multiple instances
and to do that first to check to see if
the instance is null so if this is the
first time that we want to access
this uh
instance then it's gonna return true if
not it's going to return false so it
checks if it's equal to null if it's
equal to null so our instance hasn't
been initialized
you know type instance equals to
database
right so if the instance is equal to
nulled that means that the instance has
been initialized we initialize the
database so we can initialize the class
inside the class we cannot initialize it
outside
else
so if this condition fails the the code
below is going to be red else you're
gonna return the instance so if the
instance is not null and this uh this
code is not going to be a
this condition is going to be false and
the code will not be as a good inside
the if it's gonna we're gonna return the
instance but here you go you should
return the database
and it should be a knowledgeable
database
what is our Arrow disappeared let's
delete this
let's press Ctrl alt there
all right now how we're gonna use this
first
we type here
Val instance
input equals and type database Dot and
I'm going to use our function get
instance
and uh if we we print this instance in
the console so we type here instance
if you run the squad
so now we're calling the
fan gets instance inside the company of
object
we get this code that this code
represents the
location memory of the instance so we
have this code here and if we try to
instantiate this class so we put here
the Constructor if we do that then we
get an error because the Constructor is
private so we cannot create an instance
and
when you call the get instance function
so when we did this
first check to see if the instance was
equal to null and it was equal so now
then created the instance and then it
returned the instance
but if you call this
function again so let's call it
instance2
because database that
get instance now this will evaluate to
false because the instance is not equal
to null we have an instance and it's
going to come down here and it's going
to return the instance they're already
creating instance so if I
put a printerland here
and I'm gonna output the instance tool
you're gonna see that there is no
instance to you have the same instance
because it's you it's returning already
creating created the instance so we have
the same code here meaning
this translates to that you have the
same instance so no matter how many
times you use database I get instance if
it's the first time then it's going to
create the instance and it's going to
return in essence if you call that again
like we do for instance 2 then it's
gonna return the already created users
so in this way you have the same
instance no matter how many times you
you call the get instance function
because it will always return the same
instance because we
because of our logic that we created
here but there is a shorter way to
achieve the same thing by using the
object keyword and this is what we're
gonna do next
so let's close this
now let's see how we can create a
Singleton and which is going to have the
same behavior that we created here so
it's gonna be only one instance using
the object keyword so I'm going to type
down here object
I'm going to call it database
now let's delete this code because we
cannot have a
two objects which have the same name
and we cannot have a Constructor here
because it's a Singleton so you put only
curly braces
you can have properties and functions
inside the Singleton created with you
with the
object kios leslie.com inside Dimension
frame function too
so uh
Now by just typing object database now
we have the same thing that we had
previously just by typing object and
database so this will always return the
same
instance and we have only this code
object and the name of the object so the
in the instance of the object is going
to be created the first time you call it
and we can put an initializer block to
have some code to be executed here so
let's put a printerland
let's say yo
this is a database created
and to you to use this just type let's
put a printerland
and type database
and now if you run this
and the first time you call the
Singleton that time the Singleton is
going to be
it's going to be created so I have
database created then we have this code
which represents the
or Stringer is the string representation
of the object and if you press Ctrl D
here look what happens
we have
database created so because this is only
one instance this object is a single
turn it calls the initializer block only
once when it initializes itself so when
we call the database for the first time
it is initialized and it calls the code
inside the init block and after that it
only
it output this thing representation the
second time we call the database we
don't have database created because the
instance was already created and the
initializer block is not called again
because we have the same instance so if
you can press Ctrl D here multiple times
and we're gonna see that we have the
database created with only one
one uh once because
that is called only when the
only when the object is created for the
first time so on this line in the next
slide we have the same uh the same
objects we have here this
this is why I have the same code because
it's basically the same instance so as
you can see this is a lot simpler and um
more concise than the code that had
previously so this is how you can create
a Singleton in kotlin this is why this
is how we should do it
so see in the next video
so now it's time to start a discussion
about lazy initialization but first i'm
going to copy this Singleton and solid
hour classes file
and if you don't have this file because
you created a new project again just
type the code that I'm going to type in
a second so I'm going to delete this
now what is lazy initialization
lazy initialization is used when
creating an instance when creating an
object is expensive and the expensive in
the programming context means that it
will take some time
it will use some memory and in that case
it's recommended to use lazy
initialization and to illustrate the
lazy initialization I'm going to use our
user class so I'm going to compare user
class inside order
main file not because I can create here
an object by having the file here but
because
I want to
put the code here to make clear what I'm
doing so I'm gonna delete the code from
here
and if you don't have the file just
create a new class called user Define
the properties for its name last name
and age I'm gonna delete this because
you don't need this
and inside our user class I'm going to
put initialize an initializer block
which is going to be called every time
you create a new object and here we're
gonna put a printer printer print line
statement
which is gonna say
user
when I call the first name property so
the value that Sparks the first name
property
was created
so let's create a new object here
let's call it user1
equals user
now let's put some values to the
properties of the Constructor let's say
Alex
now if you run the squad
we get in the output user and the value
for the first name property Alex was
created
if I press Ctrl d
and I change this to user 2.
and let's change this to a generic name
user
for the last nameless
pass just the last name text
and let's skip that age so if I run this
code now
because now on the line 3 you create a
new object the initializer block is
going to be called again because we
create a new object which is user
user was created
now to initialize our user 2 with the
lazy initializer we just delete this
and to illustrate how the initializer
block works we delete this and we put
after user to buy so we put the keyword
by
and we type lazy and as I'm typing you
see that I have that black lace press
enter and put the curly braces and
inside the calibration we create our
object so user
and here to pass the values to the
properties so let's put
user one
let's pass last name
and for the age let's put
zero
now
previously when the
user was initialized
in the world way
I found out the user user was created so
the initializer block was called when he
created the second level but now
if I run this code
look what happens
we get only our first object we get the
initializer black only called for our
first object and for our second object
initialize using the lazy initialization
we don't have the initialize of law
because the object is not initialized is
the object is only going to be
initialized
when you use that um
object in your code so if you use that
object somewhere in a code the object
then is going to be initialized and it's
going to be used so if I type here a
println
which says
user DOT first name user tool
now if I run this
now because I know I'm I am using the
user 2 object now the user to object
instance is going to be created and then
I'm gonna see user 2. first name so now
we see user let's see user 1 was created
so the initializer block was called
because when we called the
the print line user to that first name
then in that at that moment it created
the instance and then it outputted the
user one so this is why now we see here
user one one was created and previously
we didn't because
now we're using the user to object in
our code so unless you are not using the
the instance the object that have
created using the lazy initializer it is
not going to be initialized so this is
initializer this is initialization by
lazy
so see in the next video
so now it's time to start a discussion
about enum classes but first i'm going
to copy our user class inside our
classes file
now I'm going to delete this class and
also I'm going to delete the code inside
the main function
now what are the num classes
in on classes are used when we want to
represent a fixed set of values so when
you want to represent we want to create
some constants you should use genomes
because
enums are like constants but they are
more powerful because you can they can
have properties and they can also have
functions
and you know I'm sorry
usually used in um if conditioners or if
statements or in in the when statement
or if I want to call it the if statement
expression or when statement expression
now let's see how I can create any
number class
and to create any num class just type
here enum the keyword enum
and as I'm typing I have some
suggestions
then we put class and let's call this uh
you know class directions
Direction actually
then you put curly braces
and inside the enumclass direction we
Define our enum values so here we Define
North
put comma enter
South
you can put them in one line just to
have comma between them
East
and west
right so we have our
enums values defined inside our
Direction enum class and those enums
values that we have here here they are
instances of our enum
class Direction so they are an instance
there an object created inside the
enumclass direction just that they have
this different name and as you can see
the name of the you know values should
be all the names should be in uppercase
letters now let's see how we can access
those you know values
to access the you know values we can
let's put the printer line here
we type Direction
then we press Dot
and we have some some suggestions here
we have west east north and south so we
have our enum values suggested so let's
choose West let's output this in the
console
so we get West so this is the
enum value
West and um
let's press Ctrl d
let's change this to East
so let's change this to East
let's change this to North
and South
now if you run this code
we get our enum values West is north and
south
so this is how you can get the you know
the how you can get the genome values
that you define inside your genome class
now we can also
you can also pass
you can define a Constructor here for
our enumclass and Define some properties
like VAR let's call it Direction
of type string
and VAR
distance
and this is going to be an integer
now if you hover over here you have some
underlines and the underlines if you
have always says that you Nam has not
the full Constructor so now because as I
said those elements values are instances
they are objects created inside the
original class now we need to pass some
values to
the properties that we Define here so
let's pass some values here so let's
press let's type here first
North again I'm gonna speed up this now
a little bit
all right so now what we did here we
passed some values to the
you know values Constructors because in
in up here in our enumclass direction we
Define some properties and those
properties because the enum values are
objects they are instances for a number
directions even though they have those
different names you need to pass to the
constructors then some value so we pass
here north south east west and password
for for the densest distance 10 20 50
and 40.
now
let's see how we can Loop through our
enum's values and to do that we just
delete this code
and what if and here we add the four
groups so we type four
let's call it the
Direction
in and here we type
Direction our enorm class
dot values and this is going to return
an array with all the enum values that
are defined in our class
now let's put calibrases
and let's draw the printerland
and let's put in the direction
so now if you run this
you'll see the same output
but in the order that they are defined
inside the class
so we see the same not the same output
because they are outputted in the order
in which they are defined in the class
so we have north south east and west and
this is how we can Loop through an enum
to through the enum values of a num
class so this is how you do it so now
let's delete this code
now if you want to access the arguments
that are passed to our enum values
Constructors
we just first put a printerland to
Output the values on the console
and type Direction so our rename class
Dot
and we choose our in our value let's
choose North and from here and here now
we type also that and now we have some
suggestions we have Direction distance
and we also have a name
and name is uh
is a variable which is not defined by us
so we've only defined those properties
direction and distance but name is
variable which is built in in the
enumclass similar to the the the
direction that values which return the
array is the the direction that values
values was also uh property which
actually it was an array property which
was built into the enumclass so we
didn't create that it's provided by the
enumclass so this is why we have that
name there so let's put Direction
let's press Ctrl d
uplicate this code and let's change this
to the instance
let's press Ctrl D again and let's also
print that name
which is the built-in variable which is
the built-in variable provided by the NM
class so let's put here name
now if we run this code
get North so this is the value that you
pass here we get 10 and then we get
North with capital letter so
so we get the value that we passed here
for direction and distance which are
defined in Direction class so we get the
value spots for this specific
you know more volume and then we get the
North and this is the built-in um
variable which is uh provided by you by
Dynam class
but as I said you can also have
functions so let's have a function which
Returns the direction and distance so
let's type here fun
we call it print data because it's gonna
print the data of a specific in our
value
it's not going to take any input put
curly braces
but now we have an error here that is
because uh when you declare a function
inside the nenum class you need to
provide a semicolon for the last in um
defined in our class so I need to put
here a semicolon and there will
disappear and let's print the data here
let's add the println
let's put quotation marks
as for Direction
equals
dollar sign
Direction
and
distance
equals dollar sign
now if you call this wanna
our
wanna enam valueless type direction that
let's say West
Dot and now we have our function print
data
so this print data function is going to
put in the data of the West enum that is
defined here so it's going to Output
West and 40 in the console so you know
if you run this code
we get direction West and distance 40.
so this is how you can use functions
inside the noun classes
next let's see how we can use our enum
Direction and generally how we can use
enums with the when statement expression
so I'm going to close the console
I'm going to delete this code and the
print data function works for all of our
Renown values
so let's delete this
and here I'm going to Define a variable
it's going to be a Val it's going to be
called Direction
we're going to put equals and hero type
Direction our enumclass let's choose
East
so now the enum
actually is the west east so now our
Direction enum is is going to be stored
in our Direction variable let's use the
when statement expression
and we type here when
Direction
then you put curly braces and here we
type
Direction
Dot
East I'm gonna put
Auto
execute this course so print the Len
the direction is
yes and we'll do the same thing for the
next one so let's press Ctrl d
let's change this to
West
North
and South
so this is how you can use the enorms
with the one statement now if I run this
actually I should change the text there
but I'm going to change it
so let's close this to change the text
here
now if you run this you're gonna see
the direction it sees because this
condition is true
our Direction argument here is going to
match with this Branch so it's going to
evaluate true and then it's going to
execute this code you can pull
calibrations if you want but as I said
in our discussion about the when
statement expression
you should do scary braces if you have
multiple lines of code in our case we
have one single line of code but you can
put curly braces if you want and of
course that this Branch will always
evaluate to true because here we type
direction that is
into our Direction variable literally
directly and this value doesn't change
but in real up this value could come
from a database or from the user input
and in that case you need to use the
function which is also built into the
enorma class and that function
is called value of so we type Direction
dot value of and this value function
check his checks to see if our value
that we pass here exists inside our
enumclass so it checks to see if is
defined here and it all it also returns
that value so if I type here
yeast
now if I run this code
we get an error which has no num
constant direction that is because
all of our enum values have they are
defined in uppercase letters
but if I put here that
uppercase
and if I run this code
now we get the direction assist and uh
this value that we have here is this
value as I said could come from a
database or from the user input and the
direction that value of is going to
check to see if this
you know value exists in our rename
class and it's going to return that
value
in our variable so it's going to assign
that value to our variable
so see you in the next video
so now it's time to start a discussion
about inner classes so what are inner
classes in our classes are classes which
are declared inside another class and
they are generally used when you know
that there is a very close relationship
between two classes so when it doesn't
make sense to put two classes separated
then you should use inner classes and
let's look at an example and we're going
to imagine here that we have a list View
and this list video list view is gonna
display some items in a list in on the
screen and here we're going to use inner
classes because for displaying the each
individual item we're gonna create a
list view item so first you create a
class called list View
foreign
we Define a property called
items and it's going to be an array of
strings
now we put curly braces and inside the
class we type the keyword inner
then class and now we create a class
which is going to represent the
individual items in the list view so we
put type here list view item
put the
the primary Constructor but we put not
we don't Define any properties and then
we put curly braces
and this inner class let's use gonna
have a function called display
item and it's going to display the value
the values of an item of other specific
position so we put here position let's
say
Define a parameter to our function
it's going to be an end
and we're just gonna type here print
line
and the inner classes are have access to
the properties of the outer class so
inside our inner classes that we have
here we can have we can access the
properties that are defined inside the
outer class list view in this case we
have a single property called items and
here we can type
items and notice that I can use the
items property which is defined in our
outer class list view we type position
and this is going to return
an item at this position which is passed
as an argument here to to do our
parameter position
and we go up here and we type Val
list View
because we're going to create an
instance for this View
type list View
now we need to pass an array to our
primary Constructor to the property item
so we type here array off and we Define
some generic names here let's say uh
name
one
and name four now how can we access the
display item function which is inside
our inner class
list item list view items this this
should be list view item not items so
let's change this go right click on it
and go to refactor and rename
let's call it the items
press enter
now to access the display item function
which is inside the original class list
view item
we type list View
so our instance our object list view Dot
list view item and then again that and
now we have our function display item
and we can pass here let's say yo
let's say uh two
now if you run this code
so get in the output name tree and this
is correct because it entries the other
index too
and this is how you can access the
display how this how you can access
generally a function inside then uh in
inside an inner class you just create an
instance of the outer class then you
call a
you call the name of the class of the
name of the inner class and then you
call the function Auto so see you in the
next video
so now it's time to do a challenge using
the knowledge that we have about object
oriented programming
and the challenge is to create a class
which is going to represent a bank
account of a person and this class is
going to have three properties the first
one is going to be called the account
name the second one is going to be
called the balance and the third one is
going to be called transactions and it
should be a multiple list
also you should create functions for
deposit and withdraw and also function
for calculating the balance and you also
you also should add the
the checks for checking to see if the
amount is uh when you deposit the amount
is greater than zero and all of that
stuff so do this Challenge and then
watch my solution
so
my solution is this I'm going to create
the class
and for this challenge you should also
have in mind the discussion that you had
about access modifiers so I'm gonna call
it account
and I'm going to Define here a property
called the
we're gonna be called the Val is going
to be called the count uh
name
and it's going to be of type string
of type string
and we put curly braces and inside the
class I'm gonna declare the next two
properties and those one uh first I'm
going to declare it without the access
modifiers because IntelliJ probably is
gonna figure out that we need to put
access modifiers on them so I'm gonna
type VAR balance
and I'm gonna assign 0 so this is the
default value and
VAR transactions
and this is going to be equals to a
multiple
or Multiple List
of int because this this is going to
store the transactions
so these are the three properties of our
class now I'm gonna create the first
function which is going to be called
deposit and this function is going to be
used to deposit
money inside our bank account and it's
going to have a parameter called the
mount
it's going to be of type
end
and first we need to check if this
amount is greater than zero because you
don't want to deposit uh negative value
so if amount is greater than zero
and we choose greater than zero because
we also don't want to deposit zero so
this is why I put greater than zero then
if it is greater than zero then I'm
gonna add that to our transaction
list that add
amount
and then I'm gonna say balance
I'm gonna update our balance I'm gonna
put plus equals
amount then we're gonna add the print
line which is gonna say
I'm going to put the quotation marks
dollar sign
I'm gonna type amount
I'm gonna put dollar sign this dot
balance
so I'm gonna output in the console what
is the balance but if the amount that is
passed to this function is
a negative sum I'm gonna go in the else
part and we're gonna say
another print line here
which is going to say cannot deposit
negative sums so we're gonna put here
okay cannot
deposit
negative sums
so this is our deposit function next I'm
going to create another function and
this is going to be called withdraw and
this is going to be used for withdraw
withdrawing mine so we type fun with
draw
and we put parenthesis and this is gonna
take a parameter called with draw wool
so uh
it should be like this
and it's going to be an integer we put
curly braces
now
it should be with
with here with
with
draw
now we need to convert this into
negative sum because now we're uh
withdrawing money from autocon so first
we need to check if
and we're going to put minus because I'm
gonna convert this into a negative sum
withdrawal is less than zero
so if this is a negative
sum which is going to be withdrawal
you're gonna
I'm gonna add to our transactions is
transactions that add and you also put
the minus sign so you put minus with
drawal because now we're adding now
we're uh we're taking money off the of
our account then I'm gonna put this that
balance
my uh Plus
equals minus
withdrawal because now we're taking
money
and then we're going to add again a
print line it's going to be this one so
I'm going to copy this
but now this is going to be the
withdrawal
else if
this is not
a negative sum so
I'm gonna put else
I'm gonna type put in the line
cannot
wait
draw
negative sums so if he tries to withdraw
a negative sum then we're going to say
cannot withdraw a negative sum here we
put the minus because we we're taking
money out of our account so we need to
check for uh that's why we're checking
here if this is less than zero
shouldn't be negative here
and we're going to create another
function and this is going to be called
calculate balance so we type here fun
Let's uh
bring this
fun calculate
calculate
balance
this is not going to take any parameters
and it's going to return an INT
put curly braces
and I'm gonna put this that balance to
zero because
I want to calculate the balance I'm
going to add the transactions to this
property balance so here we're gonna say
and here we're gonna loop we're gonna
type four
turn suction
in our list of transactions
so
for transaction in our list of
transaction I'm gonna type this Dot
balance
plus and equals transaction
so our transaction and then we're going
to return the balance at the end of our
Loop when we end we ended looping so
return this Dot
balance so this is our solution to the
challenge and let's um let's create an
account and let's pass some values here
so I'm going to type here
Val
Alex account
I'm gonna put equals
account
I'm gonna put now I'm gonna call the
primary Constructor so I'm going to type
here Alex
and we still use I'm still using my name
here but
so I'm going to type here Alex account
Dot
deposit so I'm going to deposit let's
say one thousand
and uh
I'm gonna type OLX account that withdraw
I'm gonna withdraw
500 then I'm gonna put Alex account
and I'm gonna put uh
deposit the negative sign let's say
minus 20.
and Alex account Dot
that we draw also negative sign let's
say minus
100.
now if you're on this code
foreign
deposit balance is now 1000 so we have
our call card called from our deposit
function
then we have
so I should I didn't change the text
here so that's why it's saying uh
this should say with uh withdrawn so uh
sorry let's change this to
with
drone
so let's run our code again
so get 1000 deposit balance is now one
thousand now we get our uh correct
output to get the
then 500 withdrawn so get our call the
call from our withdrawn function we
withdrawn balance is now uh 500 then
then you get cannot deposit negative
sums cannot withdraw negative sounds
because we passed the negative numbers
to our deposits and withdrawal function
and here we're checking to see if those
are negative or positive so this is our
solution to our
to our Challenge and I hope that you
enjoyed this and that you solved this
and this is not again the best solution
this is just
my solution probably you'll find you
figure out a better solution
maybe your concern better and more
concise solution than this actually I
forgot before we end our video Let's
actually called also our calculate
balance function so I'm gonna type here
uh
Alex account
dot calculate balance and this is going
to return an integer so I'm gonna type
here Val because that function returns
something so I need to capture that in a
variable so I'm going to type here valve
balance
equals Alex account
so no other print line here
and there's gonna say
balance
is dollar sign
format the code
now if we run this code
[Music]
now get our previous output to 1000
deposit balance now one thousand five
hundred withdrawn balance is now 500
then cannot deposit negative sums and
cannot withdraw negative sounds and then
get balances now 500 so our code works
well
so this is our code
one more thing that I forgot is that I
said at the beginning of the video that
you should have in mind the discussion
that we had about access modifiers when
doing this challenge
and I forgot to to add the access
modifiers for balance and transactions
because now what can I do for balance I
can
use our Alexa account
s and I can type here balance and now
because that is uh actually that is not
really probably because when I talked
about uh get us unsetters we said that
that when you access a property you
always access access that property
through get a run Center so we never
access directly the getter and the
property but uh
still you should not make that that
public because by default if you don't
provide an access modifier they are they
are by default public so if I type here
now account balance as you can see I can
call that and I can type here 1000 and I
can deposit now I can change the balance
of the account directly from here and if
you hover over here
uh IntelliJ figure out that you should
make this private so make this private
the balance and also the transactions
because
you don't use them inside the primary
Constructor and they are used only
through the to the functions that we
defined here the because of that you
should you should declare them as
private because you use them only
through the function that you declared
inside the class so declare them as
private and now you if you hover over
here it says you cannot access balance
because it's private in account and now
we cannot change the balance from
outside the class we can only
deposit or withdraw uh
sums of money from our bank account
by interacting only with the functions
and not by calling the property directly
and assigning a new balance to to the
property so make them private and this
way you cannot uh you don't uh you don't
access the property outside of the class
and you change data directly the the
value of the property again it's not
really direct because the code that you
had previously so this code actually is
calling the setter here but still you
can change the value of
the balance but now because we made that
private and the the compiler is smart
enough to figure out that because they
are not declared inside the primary
Concepts and they are only used you only
interact with them with the deposit and
withdraw
and uh calculate balance functions so we
don't use them outside you don't have
them also declaring the primary
Constructor it knows that you should
make them private because you interact
them only with the functions and now we
have this underline because it's private
so we cannot change this balance now
from outside the class we can only
interact them again using the functions
so I'm gonna delete this and
now see you in the next video
so let's delete this
so actually I'm gonna let it there
because
it's uh good to see so now it's time to
start a discussion about inheritance so
what is inheritance inheritance is the
concept in the quarterly programming
context with which you can create a
class using another class so in other
words you can get all the functions and
properties that have that the class
already has in your new class and in
addition to the getting all the
functions in properties in uh in your
new class you can add some new functions
some new properties which are specific
to this new class but they aren't for
the also this the class from which you
are inheriting is called The Base Class
the parent class or the super class
and you might be wondering why is this
useful why you want to do this
let's say that you have a very big class
which performs very hard task and has a
lot of functions in coding but you want
to create a new class which is slightly
different from this class what you can
do is you can get all that code copied
in the new class and then you can add
your new functions or new your new
Behavior to this class but dust is not
recommended because you have duplicate
code what you can do instead is you can
inherit all the functions and properties
which this big class already has and in
your new class you can add the new
functionality the new Behavior which is
specific to this new class but it's not
for the base class so in this way you
can uh you you avoid the duplicated code
and you increase the code reusability
and for that I'm going to show you in an
example and I'm going to create two
classes one is going to be called car
and one is going to be plain so we
create here a class we go down here
we type class
I'm going to call it car
is going to have some properties the
first one is going to be called name
this is going to be the brand name of
the car
the second one is going to be color also
string
engines the number of engines that this
car has
gonna be an integer
and Val
this is going to be
doors so we're gonna store the number of
doors
all right
we put curly braces because I'm gonna
add some functions to this class
to function actually fun
move
and uh
fun
stop
and here you're gonna say
print line
quotation marks dollar sign
the name of the car
is moving
similarly
down here in the stop we're going to say
the car has stopped
car
has
and we're gonna create a another class
called plane
which is going to have also Val
name
we're gonna be a string a vowel color
also string
Val engines an integer and the valve
doors
unint
put curly braces and we Define those two
function we're going to copy those
I'm gonna paste it here
so now what we did here is that we
created two classes
they both both have
uh properties for the primary
Constructors and but as you probably
already noticed we have the same
properties we have the name here we have
the name there we have the color there
we have the color here the color there
the engines also we have here and there
and we also have those functions which
are almost actually are the same so we
have what I said at the beginning
duplicated code so it doesn't make sense
to put this code here another
another way to do this is to create a
base class a generic class called
vehicle which is uh and usually
you create the generic class when you
know that
several classes we are gonna share those
properties and those behaviors so a car
in the plane both are Vehicles so we can
put here instead of declaring the the
name and the caller inside the our
inside our classes car and plane you can
put this in a vague vehicle uh
class in a base class and we can inherit
those properties in our classes instead
of declaring them your inside our car
and playing class so we can put here Val
name
it's going to be a string
and the Val
color also string
now I can copy those two
let's put curly braces here and I can
paste it paste it here so
now I can delete those those two
functions from our classes
and what we can do now is we can inherit
those properties so we can delete those
properties that we have here
we cannot we will as you'll see you'll
need to declare them as parameters but
uh
they are not they're not going to be as
properties in any they're not going to
be as properties here
now
what we can do is that we can inherit
this shared those share the functions
and those shared properties because both
the car and the plane
have a function to move have a function
to stop the baby they both share a name
they both share a color so they both
share those properties and uh functions
but uh
as we did previously is to put them
inside the the the classes would not
it's not good because we have a
duplicated code and in this way we put
this code here
and now we can inherit this code so we
can have this code directly you can you
can have this code the being uh
being accessed inside the car and plane
without declaring them in our classes so
to inherit from our class first you need
to Mark the class from which you want to
inherit as open because by default they
are they you cannot inherit from a class
so if I enter in head from a class we go
at the enclosing impurities of our
primary Constructor
we put colon and we type the name of the
class from which we want to inherit and
in this case it's going to be vehicle
now
if you hover over here
it says that this type has a Constructor
and thus mods B initialized here and and
next you say this type is final so it
cannot be inherited from and that means
that we cannot inherit from this class
unless we mark this class with the open
keyword in front of it so we need to put
here open
and now if we hover over here
now we don't have that error you only
have this here which is this type has a
Constructor and dust must be initialized
here and that basically means that it
says hey I'm trying to use this vehicle
class I'm trying to but in order to use
it I mean I need to initialize this
vehicle class so we need to pass some
values to the
construct of the primary Constructor
that is defined here you need to pass
some values to the name and to color
and to do that we Define here name we
type name
actually dot let's press Ctrl Z
let's put a space and we type name
we put
comma then we type
color
and notice that we don't have the VAR or
the Vault keyword in front of them that
is because the those
parameters that would have here because
they are parameters because they don't
have the value of our keyword they they
uh they they they have to be declared
only as parameters because the
properties are going to be declared and
they are declared by the primary
Constructor of the base class from which
we are inheriting from
and because of that we don't we we don't
we don't need to declare the property
again here as you can see if I put the
VAR keyword we have an error says name
hyzer anyway what that means that we
cannot have the property declared here
because the properties uh already
declared inside the Base Class inside
the vehicle class from which we are
inheriting from what
we can do here is Define the parameters
and the value that is passed to those
parameters so the primary Constructor of
the class cards are going to be passed
to the to the vehicle primary
Constructor so hero put the primary
Constructor so you put two parentheses
and we type name
and this name is this one from here
so we type name then we put comma
because we need to pass a value for the
second one for the color and the type
color
and this color is this color here
so we type color
now
if you go up here let's say for let's
look first as the actually let's also
inherit from inherit inherit also one in
on the plane class so we put colon also
here
we type vehicle
and now we need to also to Define here
the parameters the name and the color
so we type name
and at the time you can see that
IntelliJ has given us some hints so if I
type here color it says that color
string so it's very helpful
put colon we pass those values to
primary Constructor of the base class so
we type name
color
and now if I go up here on I create some
instances of our car and playing class
so we type here Val car let's put equals
this type card
let's choose for the name BMV
and the
for the color let's say red
for the engines one for the doors four
now I'm going to create also an object
with our plane so let's press Ctrl alt
form on the code
valve plane
equals plane so our class
we type here
for the name
for the color let's say
or white
and
blue
for the engines for
and for the doors let's see
also for
now if I go down here and I
type here car dot
if you look here you see that you see
that we have the function stop and the
function move but we didn't declare them
here you deleted them previously but
because we are inheriting from the
vehicle class because when you are in
editing the properties and the functions
from the class from which you are
inheriting from are part of the new
classes so the the the
move function in the stop function they
are now part of our color class
similarly it's the same in the same the
same here the the the the move and stop
are uh are part of the class plane so if
I type here car
dot move
and car dot stop and then plane dot move
and plane so look like then now I can
call them like they are declared inside
the our current plane but they are not
there but because we are inheriting they
are part of the class so you can think
of
you can think of this thing that we have
here as a single entity so it acts like
a single entity
so now if you run the squad
we get in the output band there is
moving then they have stopped bearing is
moving doing has stopped
and uh
this uh we get this output because as I
said those functions are part of our
classes and they are using the name
so in this case the name that is passed
to the car this name that we have here
been there
is passed to the to the primary
Constructor of the base class and then
it's used here so it's calling the
movement save and there is moving so in
the same way for the for the plane we
get the same output it gets the value
that is passed here viewing and then it
outputs the viewing is moving and then
it has stopped
but we can do even more we can
override those functions inside our
class so we can create a version which
is inside the base class from your
inheriting we can create a version of
this function which is specific to the
car or which is specific to the plane
and I'm gonna look at that
so now I'm going to override the move
function from our Base Class vehicle
inside our playing class because I want
to make the move function specific to
the playing class so I want to provide I
want to provide an implementation of the
move class which is specific to a plane
so how is our plane is moving a plane is
moving by flying so I'm not satisfied
with only this generic function which
says the name of the vehicle is moving
and to override the function you first
need to Mark Mark the function similarly
to
to the class we need to mark it with the
open keyword so we type open because
kotlin wants to make things explicit so
we put open and now we can
we can
we can override that function inside our
plane class
so we go to to override the function go
to code
generate and here we have vehicles in
harsh code tostring and go to override
methods and you you have those equals
hash code into string and those are here
because every class that you create in
Kathleen is implicitly inheriting from
the any class but we're gonna look at
that on but more more on that later
because you look at that in a different
video and we have our function move and
stop so
the the idea is telling us that those
are the functions which can be
overridden inside our plane class from
our vehicle Base Class so we choose move
we press ok
and you have this super dot move we're
gonna see middle what is this and you
can also override it
by just typing the keyword override and
you can override the function so you can
type here override
and while I type in you see that we have
this override fan move stop or and have
also those so we choose move
and I have the same thing
now super dot move means that call the
function so super means call something
from our base class in this case call
the move function from our Base Class so
we're gonna let that here but in
addition to that we're going to add a
new function so we're going to type here
fun
flying because the plane is flying
and we're just gonna have a simple print
line
which is going to say
put quotation marks let's bring this
down a little bit
a plane is
flying so now I'm gonna call this
function flying inside our move function
which was overridden
so we type flying
flying
now if we run this code look what
happens
if you look in the output to get when
they is moving when they have stopped
and then we get the apply the plane is
flying and then we get bearing is moving
and bearing has stopped so what what has
happened here now because we where when
this function move is called here on our
object plane created
now it's using our own implementation of
the move function and after that so it's
using our own implementation it's
calling the flying function that we
created here because a plane is moving
in a specific way is flying and then
it's calling super dot move and super
dot move is calling the function from
the base class so it's calling the
function from here so
by doing this we made our function
specific you make we make the we made
the function move specific make the
function move unique to the plane class
because a plane is moving in a specific
way and we can do the same thing for the
the car class so
uh now you may be wondering why why I
didn't declare the inside our Base Class
the engines because they are also
present in in both classes because when
you create a generic class you should
only include the commonly used functions
commonly used and shared functions and
the properties so uh
all all vehicles have a name and the
color but not all vehicles have engines
so this is why I put the engines here so
in addition to the name and the color
which all vehicles have we added some
new properties which are specific to a
car
similar here in addition to the name and
the color which all vehicles have and
we've inherited that from our class we
add that also engines and doors which
those things are in addition they are
specific to a plane and more we also
override the move function because we're
not satisfied with the with the simple
move function from our Base Class to
include to provide our own
implementation of how a plane is moving
so you can see that by using an
inheritance and
adding new properties are the new
function you can create more specific
classes you can inherit you can also
inherit from the car class to create a
more specific class you can create a
Tesla
class and so on so this is what
inheritance is and
see you in the next video
so I thought that's a good idea to show
you another example with inheritance and
I'm gonna go down here
and I'm going to define a class so I'm
going to type the keyword class and I'm
going to call it View
and this view is going to represent a
view in uh which is used in Android and
if you want Android is just a
rectangular area on the screen and it's
responsible for drawing and event
handling
but you're gonna mimic as I said what
the view is and uh you know Android or
not going to create a view like the one
that is in use like the one that's used
in Android
and we Define the primary Constructor
but we're gonna not Define we're not
going to Define any properties the
primary Constructor
and this view is going to have a simple
function called Draw and it's going to
be responsible for drawing this view on
the screen so we type draw
and create a function and we're gonna
add the simple a simple print line here
which is going to say drawing The View
so we put here
quotation marks
drawing
The View
and uh we're gonna
mark this class as open because I want
to inherit it from it
and we're also going to Mark the
function open because I'm going to
override that function in the
in the next class and because this is a
generic View and it's going to have this
draw function only this function what
you can do let's say that I want to I
don't want to create a simple uh a
simple view which is just a rectangular
area on the screen but I want to create
something more specific let's say that I
want to create a button
in that case instead of creating the
button the button from zero because this
View
in Android
has a lot of functions and properties
which are responsible for creating the
view for handling the events and so on
so
um because here we have on your simple
function but the real view has hundreds
of functions and instead of creating our
button from zero we can just inherit
from The View and we can inherit all the
functionality that the view already
provides to create a generic View and we
can add some
unique characteristics characteristics
which are specific to a button and in in
this case in this way we increase the
quad reusability and it's more easy for
us to to create the button than rather
than creating the button from zero
because the view already provides all
the tools that you need to create a
generic view only we you're gonna
inherit all that behavior all that
properties but I'm gonna but we're gonna
change it a little bit so this is what
we're gonna do with the inheritance so
we create a new class called button
so we Define the primary Constructor
and here you can Define some properties
which are specific to a button not not
just to a generic view which is a
rectangular area on the screen so we put
Val text and this is going to be a
string so our our button will have a
text which can be plugged in or signed
up
and also it's going to have orientation
because it's going to be one on a place
on the screen
on a specific place on the screen and
this is going to be a string
of course you just only Mimi only mimic
the
View and button which are are used in
Android this is why we have so many we
see we have so little properties and
only a simple function function in our
view draw and we put uh here colon to
inherit from our view because I want to
inherit all that functionality all that
properties that a view provides but I
wonder is just to change it a little bit
to make it more specific I want to make
a button and of course as I said this is
just uh
an example we don't have but in a real
in a real app this will have a hundreds
or thousands of line of code and we can
inherit all of that behavior or that
functionality in our new
New View which is a button but you can
override some functions and you can
provide some you can create a more
specific view than a general review so
you don't need to define the primary
Constructor
and you put the curly braces
now I want to override the draw
functions so that when the draw when the
draw function is called I want to not
drawing just a generic view but to draw
a button of course as I said this is
just an imaginary example so we type
overwrite fundra
and instead of calling the super
function which is inside our
our Base Class View or parent Class View
I'm gonna type here print line
and we're gonna put the text drawing
the
button
of course and now what we did here we
created the generic view as I said and
again this can have hundreds of maybe
thousands of line of code and functions
and different functions different
properties
but we we inherited from The View class
and we added some new functionality so
instead of just drawing a generic view
now of course we just add a simple print
line here but here you can have the code
which is going to be responsible for
drawing a speed a button so it's going
to be more specific than a simple
generic view so you can put here a here
is the code
for
creating
the button so I'm going to put the
Commander and let's say that
now I want to create a run around button
so instead of creating again all that
functionality which which is present in
the view and then create and then use
and then creating all the functionality
which is uh inside the button the button
class we can make this button uh open
and we can inherit all the functionality
that the button provides and we're gonna
add something new something unique to
this class that we're going to create
and this class is going to be a round
button so we type here round
button
and here you need to define the text
because we're going to inherit from the
for the from the class button
orientation and notice that I don't use
the VAR or the VAR keyword here because
they they're going to be only parameters
because the properties the actual
property is going to be are going to be
um
ultimately declared
in the button class
and
one thing which is going to be specific
to a round button that you're going to
create is going to be Corners so we type
Val corners
it was gonna be an integer because the
the corners basically here are going to
pass a value which is gonna in our
marginal example this is going to
receive a value which can be
um in degrees so how many degrees do you
want to how many degrees you want to
make the buttons by how many degrees you
want to make the button around so it can
pass here 20 or 30 anyway so we put
colon here and we inherit now from our
button
class
right and here you need to pass the
text
the orientation
and that's all
and you put calibrases now let's
override the draw function in our round
button because when that function is
called now I want to add some specific
code some new functionality which is
specific to a round button so it's not
gonna draw just a button but it's gonna
draw a round button so we of course
we're just going to add the simple print
line there but um
in a real app you can put here the
actual cottage which is gonna draw the
round butter so we put here print line
and we put
rowing
the round
button
now let's create some instances let's
create some objects with those classes
and we type here
Val view so we're going to create our
generic View
we Define the battery Constructor we
don't have to pass any values there
because we didn't Define any properties
inside our view
then we create a button so we put here
Val
button
equals button
and you don't need to pass some value so
I'm going to pass here the text let's
say login
the orientation let's say yo
it's going to be a text here so we put
here let's say Center
next we create a new
a new object but this is going to be now
a run around the button so we put around
button
equals round button
and you pass the text here round
button
actually let's pause it takes uh sign up
and uh
for the orientation let's put
Center also
lo you need to pass also value from for
the colors let's put let's say 30
degrees it will be
in our imaginary example now let's call
the function the function draw on all of
our objects that we create so we type
view dot draw
then we put button
dot draw
and round button
dot draw now if you
just press Ctrl Z
if you run this code
so we get in the output drawing The View
then we get drawn in the button drawing
The View again drawing the round button
and let's uh think about why you have
this output so first we see that we have
drawing The View which is the function
inside our view that you created here so
it's from the generic view so it's
drawing The View then we have drawing
the button so
here
when this line of code is uh red it says
drawing the button so you have
we have our we have our code which is
you know which is with just a print line
but uh so this is drawing the the button
then it's calling the super function so
it's calling the function inside the
view which it says drawing The View
next
when this line of code is red so round
that round button that draw now it's
calling the draw
function which is inside the round
button so instead of just now calling
the because now we are inheriting from
the button class
now uh we override this function here
and it's it's uh using our
implementation for creating a round
button it's uh executing this line of
code and then it's calling the super
implementation which is drawing the
button you can actually remove this if
you want because you let's say that
calling the code inside from the button
is not gonna affect our logic so if I
delete this now if you run this code
now we have drawing the view drawing the
button and we have drawing the view
drawing the wrong button so now it's not
calling here the super so it's not it's
not calling the code which is inside the
for the bottom because we are inheriting
first from the button but but the button
is also inheriting from The View so it's
calling first this then it's calling
draw which is inside here and we have
the round but now we only have drawing
the wrong button because here now it's
using our own implementation of the draw
so we have drawing the round button
so buy this just by
by making our view because as I said in
real app this view is can have hundreds
of maybe thousands of line of code of
different functions and properties so
you don't want to create all of that
from zero when I want only to let's say
I want to create a button I can't
inherit I can inherit from The View
which already provides all the functions
and properties and logic to create a
generic view but I can override some
functions which are responsible let's
say for like this draw and I can ex I
can Define some logic and when all of
that functionality is called It's Gonna
not draw only a generic view but it's
gonna draw a button so by inheriting
from The View we increase we increase
code the code reusability
and this is very very powerful because
let's say that uh like in our example
you want to you don't you're not
satisfied with the simple button which
is used in Android and you want to
create a draw a round button so instead
of creating all of that logic from zero
you can just inherit from a simple
button you can have override some
functions and when when you execute that
quad now it's gonna execute the code
with the implementation with the
additional implementation the with the
additional code which is which is gonna
generate a round button and it's just
not just a simple button so this is our
this is our discussion about inheritance
I hope that this clarifies some things
and see you in the next video
so now it's time to start a discussion
about seal classes so often you want to
represent only a fixed set of
possibilities so however case can either
success or it can fail a user can be a
standard user or a pro user and in those
cases you may be thinking now that you
can use enum classes but enumclasses
have some limitations and let's see why
you should use instead seal class so
let's type Main
I'm going to create a in on class here
call it the result
and let's put curly braces unless I hear
success
and the error
now the problem with this is that we
cannot encode more information here so
let's say that I want to to to Define
here a non-resolvable resolver error and
resolver error and I cannot do that here
so if I type here x dot exception I can
I cannot do that because
um the the the the types that are
defined here cannot have properties so
you cannot Define this here and for that
we need to use seal classes and to use
the seal class you just type seal class
I'm going to call it result
it's going to have a parameter called
Val message it's going to be of type
string
and you can Define your uh
classes which are gone inherit from the
seal class either outside the seal class
so you can Target class let's say
success
and let's type here
meh
message of type string and we can
inherit from the seal class so you can
type here result
message
or you can copy this and you can Define
it inside the enumclass so you can have
it as an SSC class so I'm going to type
another class here called
error
foreign
the parameter here
actually not
that is the parameter
message
foreign
the parameter here
message I'm gonna hit it from the result
you know from the results class
I'm gonna pass that parameter here
to the parent class
now
I'm gonna Define a function down here
called get data fun get data and it's
gonna have
a parameter called the result
it's going to be of type result
and here you're going to define a when
statement so we type when
the type result and now is the
interesting part
now if you hover over this underline
over when it says when expression must
be exhaustive unnecessary is error
comma is Success branches or else Branch
instead so in other words what is saying
here by uh
to have the one statement exhaustive
it's it's what it's saying another word
is that it needs to cover all the
possibilities so both possibilities that
we have here and you can type yourself
this or you can click on here click on
this right bulb and you can click here
add the remaining branches and as you
can see it's added the remaining browser
you add is result. error and easy result
does success and those are exhausted
those are the only two possibilities
which are
which are possible so here I'm gonna
type result
let's define a function inside the CL
class so I'm going to type here fun
show
message
it's gonna have a print line which is
going to say result
dollar sign
message
so and now I'm going to put dot
show message and also here result
dot show message and now this is
uh this is uh exhausted because now we
call we covered all the possibilities
which which are uh inside the which are
as a consequence of the fact that we our
classes are uh inheriting from the seal
class so if I add here an uh else Branch
so if I put here else as you can as you
you'll see this is going to be redundant
because we covered all the possibilities
and the compilers know this and this can
be very useful in some scenarios
so if I put calibrations as you can see
this is gray out because it's redundant
because it knows that we covered all the
possibilities and the possibilities are
only those two result that error and
result are success so if I type here now
success let's type success
equals
result
bo2s there
equals result dot success
let's type success here
let's press Ctrl D let's call this error
result let's change this to error so
this is how you create instances of the
nested classes let's call this failed
now let's type here get data down here
get data and let's let's pass success
and let's run our code now as you'll see
the message
result success
so we get results success in the output
so
if I change now this to error you will
see that this is the result error
because it is executing this branch
so if I run this
to get result failed
now the interesting part here is if I
add here another
possibilities so
if I type here class
progress
and I type message
string inheriting from result
let's type let's pass the message
parameter to the super class to the
parent class
now what what we have because our class
is a sealed class what we have here is
that the when is underlined and is
trying to say something to us is saying
that when expression must be exhaustive
unnecessary is progress so it knows that
there is another possibility for uh for
our result uh we it can be therefore you
need to add that possibility otherwise
I'm going to show you this order and if
you try to compile this code I'm gonna
throw an error so what what you can do
here is can we can type here is a result
to make it exhaustive so to cover all
the possibility result of that progress
let's put Arrow
result dot show message
and now if I create here another Val
let's call this uh
progress
because the result dot progress and
let's define for the parameter
progress here
now if I change this to progress
now you'll see the output result
progress
so we get result progress because
now this branch is true but if I let's
if I delete all of those look what
happens if I click here or is where you
have those on this underline it says add
else Branch so when expression must be
exhausted so it means that it needs to
cover all the possibility
possibilities are necessary is error is
progress and is Success so if we click
here on more actions
and if you click here on ADD remaining
branches it it knows that those are all
the possibilities on which our result
can be and it automatically generated
the
the check for us and we we only just
need to type here result
not show message and that's all and with
tnumps you you don't have this
auto-generated code for you because uh
I'm gonna explain immediately
so with with an enum if you add another
so if you have a Nemo class I can delete
the code now here because
but I'm going to keep the code as it is
and because all the subclasses of excel
class are known by the compiler the
compiler can fill all the possible cases
automatically for us if I declare this
Arrow class as a seal class and I
declare two classes inside here called
let's say class
resolvable error so or recoverable error
and it's going to have a parameter
called exception it's going to be of
type exception
this one
and we're going to extend from our error
seal class
not this one
this one
and we're going to pass the message
parameter
and I'm going to declare another class
non-recoverable
and it's going to have an exception
so this is more powerful than
in arms because you can have all those
properties and you can you can have
subtypes and and all of this and within
arms we cannot do this so let's extend
from error
let's pass the message
and now I need to delete this because we
cannot instantiate The Shield
class so let's delete this
now if I delete this now from here look
what happens I have an underline and it
says
add
it says one expression must be
exhaustive so it must cover all possible
cases that that exists for this cell
class unnecessary is not recoverable or
is recovered or branches so if I click
on this and I click on this bulb I click
here add remaining branches as you can
see it adds all the possible cases so
all the possible cases that we Define
inside our seal class for us
automatically
and we just type your result
dot show message
again here result
message and you cannot have this
Behavior with the non-class so this is
why still classes are more powerful
because they can have subclasses you can
have
more information on the classes so you
can have exceptions passed to them and
so on so
this is our discussion about seal
classes and see you in the next video
so now it's time to start a discussion
about abstract classes and to show you
what abstract classes are I'm going to
use the code that you had in our
discussion about inheritance but I'm
going to change it a little bit so I'm
going to delete for this class plane
because you don't need this class and
I'm gonna
I'm gonna delete this instances that we
have here
and I'm going to declare this as a VAR
and this also has a VAR so they're gonna
be now properties
I'm gonna delete the properties that we
have here
and uh
now we have this here so I'm gonna
delete these two
let's delete this
now
what are abstract classes
um abstract classes are very similar to
interfaces the only difference is that
in abstract classes you can declare
properties which can have a value and
you know in interfaces you can't
actually you can but you you need to
provide an access modifier
and to declare an abstract class we go
in front of the class that you I want to
make it abstract and we type the
abstract keyword
let's put the class keyword
and now our class is abstract and with
an abstract class you cannot create
instances abstract classes are created
only to be inherited from uh by other
classes and now if I try to create an
instance with this abstract class and I
just type Val vehicle
and we type vehicle here and we put the
parenthesis to call the go to the
Constructor
you have an error here and says cannot
create an instance of an abstract class
so you cannot create an object with an
abstract class an abstract class can
only be inherited by another class and
abstract classes usually are used like
interfaces when you want to provide
what you need what needs to be done but
you don't provide how it's going to be
done so you can you need abstract
classes are used when you define
uh functions without the body and the
code the body and the code is uh it's uh
implemented it's provided by the class
by the class which inherits from the
abstract class so they are as I say
similar very similar to interfaces the
only difference that in abstract classes
you can have properties so you can have
here a Val
text
and you can assign here some text in uh
in an interface you cannot do this let's
type some text
so this is the difference and uh
also
um you I should say that um
you can Implement many as many
interfaces as you want
but in a class but you can only inherit
from a single class right this I forgot
to say when I talked about the
interfaces now
if I want to make uh if I want to if I
to make now our functions abstract you
just type the keyword abstract in front
of them and now they are abstract and
we're gonna do the same for our stop
function but now we have this underline
because as I said abstract functions
like interfaces or the functions which
are defined in the interfaces cannot
have a body so we need to delete this uh
you need to delete the body you need to
delete the curly braces Because the
actual body the actual logic and the
code is going to be provided by the
class which uh in head is from the
abstract class now
to inherit from an abstract class we go
here
we put colon and we type the name of the
abstract class from which you want to
inherit vehicle
now
if you go out here now we have this red
bar which says
so need to call the Constructor here
all right actually I think I can delete
this but you still you still need to
call this Constructor here even though
we don't have any any parameters any
even though we didn't even Define The
Constructor here now we need because
like the interface the abstract class if
you inherit from an abstract cluster and
if that abstract abstract class has some
abstract abstract functions defined in
it you need to implement those functions
inside your class and you go here when
you have this underline if you click on
this right red bulb and it says
Implement members order make car
abstract and we click on Implement
members we select our two functions we
click ok
and now we have our functions
implemented inside our class
so this is what
Astra classes are and they are as I said
very similar to interfaces but the only
difference is that you can Define in
properties inside the an abstract class
and you can provide the value to that
property and here because we we have
inherited from our abstract class here
you can provide the actual
implementation of the functions so as
you can see we have this to do which
says not yet implemented so they are
they are very similar to interfaces
so I'm gonna end this video now and see
you in the next video but before I end
the video I saw that it's a good idea to
to say to you where abstract classes and
interfaces are used uh interfaces that
are using many many places but um
abstract classes are particularly used
when uh and also interfaces are used
when you have some apis and those apis
want to just to define the functions and
the API is going to generate the actual
code for uh for those function so you
can have a let's say a database
and you can provide the the name of the
functions which are responsible for
creating the database for getting
getting data from the database but you
don't provide the actual code which is
gonna select that data from the database
and return the data you just you just
declare your functions as as the
abstract
and the API is going to generate all
that code which is responsible for uh
returning the data and from the in other
words the API is going to do all the
hard work you just you you just Define
the the functions if you have if you
let's say if you have a property Define
an abstract class in the abstract
functions or interfaces and the API is
going to do the hard work of uh based on
what your function is doing by
editing the name of the function is
going to generate all that code which
you you've you've had to generate if you
do if you don't have if you're not
before the API to generate that for you
so this is where uh interfaces and after
classes are sometimes used and the
interfaces also are used in event
handling and that is one in one um uh
the you need to write code to respond to
respond to respond to graphical using
using your interface uh movements
so I'm gonna end the video now see you
next
so now it's time to start a discussion
about data classes but in order to
understand what data classes are we
first need to understand what is the
difference between structure equality
versus referential equality
and to restart the difference I'm going
to create two variables the first one is
going to be a Val it's going to be
called name one
and we're gonna assign the
follow Alex three so it's going to be of
type string
now I'm going to press Ctrl D to
duplicate that line of code
and to declare the second variable which
is going to be called name two and it's
also going to have the value RX
now I'm going to add the printerland
here to output something to the console
and here we're gonna type name one
equals equals
name to
so the equals to operator is doing what
is called is checking for structural
equality because it's checking to see if
the content of the variable name 1 is
the same with the content of the
variable name too so another loss is
checking to see if they have the same
value and it's they have because both
have Alex assigned to them so now if I
run this code
because this is a Boolean expression
this is going to return true or false
and we're going to see in the console
too
but if I change this to Alexandro now
the variable name 2 has a different
value so this is going to return false
because they are not structurally equal
their content is different they have
different values
now get false and this is called the
structure equality
the next type of equality is called
referential equality and the reference
equality is used when you want to check
if two variables or two objects are the
same so what the referential equality
operator is doing is checking to see if
a tool as I said variables or
objects are the same so if I type here
name one
and to use the the reference we call it
operator we put three equal sign here
and if I type here name one equals name
one so is name one equals to itself that
is going to be true
so you're gonna see through on the
console
outputted so we have two but if I change
name one equals equals equals to name
two that is going to return false
because they are distinct objects in
memory they are different uh variables
they are not the same there is the name
one
name one variable is not the same
variable as name two so we're gonna have
false here
so we have false so this is the
difference between a structural versus
referential equality so now I'm going to
close this
I'm going to close the console
and having this in mind we're going to
start a discussion about data classes
so let's go down here and let's create
our user class because I want to compare
to user objects to see if they are
structure equals so you type user let's
define the primary Constructor and let's
define three properties for the primary
Constructor the
first name
the last name
and the age
which is going to be an integer
now if I want to check if to
user objects are a star vehicle let's
first create those objects so let's
delete this code
let's say Val user1
equals now let's create our object and
let's pass some values to the
properties of the Constructor let's pass
here Alex
for the last name let's put open
and for the age 23.
now let's press Ctrl D to duplicate that
line of code and to create the second
user object let's give a different name
to this user too
now go down here let's press Ctrl alt
alt for mother code
we typed our println because I want to
check to see if our users objects are
equal
if they are structurally equal so we
type here user1
equals equals so the equals to operator
user 2.
now if you run this code what do you
think you're going to see in the output
what you're seeing the output is
actually that you'll get
we get false and you may be wondering
why because if you think about the air
structurally because they have the same
values for the properties but they are a
distinct objects but we said previously
that the equals
equals uh two equals operator is
checking for uh structure equality so
why get false here
this is because previously the equals to
operator is
it was checking to see if the two
strings are structurally equal and the
equals to operator is actually
a function which is defined inside the
any class and the string class what
actually was doing when we called the
equals to operator
it was using its own implementation of
the equals method so
uh every class that we create in kotlin
it's using its implicitly inheriting
from the any class and because every
class that we created it's implicitly
inheriting from the any class
every class is also going to use the
functions which are inside the any class
so if you don't override those functions
inside your class to provide your own
implementation like the string class did
for our strengths then it's going to use
the implicit uh the font is going to use
the function which inside which are
inside the any class and
if you type here user1 that and we have
equals to string and hashcode those
three but those three functions we are
particularly interested and the
particular one is interested inside the
equals they perform when you don't
Implement inside your own class those
functions
again particularly on Bay course class
the equals class spin forums only a
referential equality so it only checks
if those two users
are the same users and if they're not
that's gonna it's gonna return false so
this is why you get false here because
it's calling the function the function
which is inside any class so what you
have implicitly is something like this
so for any class that you you use or for
any class that you declare
you have implicity inherited from the
any class and because of that you have
those
three functions which
are defined and if you don't override
them to provide your own implementation
then it's going to use the code that's
inside there so actually if you press
Ctrl here
and if you
click it takes us inside the any class
so it's clear that this function
the equals function is inside any class
so because we don't have any functions
here so we need to override that
function inside our class and we need to
provide our own implementation to Define
our own code to determine if two user
are one of when two users are slash
legal this is what you're going to
Define inside our class so let's delete
this
let's pull the curly braces and actually
I'm gonna bring an image to show you how
the quarter and hierarchy actually looks
so this is the image and at the top as
you can see we have the any class and
then we have our Boolean class our
string class and then we have our user
class and all of those classes I have
here the Boolean the string the number
they are inheriting from the any class
they are
using the the functions which are
defined inside the any class and they
override the they are overriding those
methods inside them and they are
providing their own implementation for
those functions and this is what we need
to do also here as you can see they will
inherit from the any class implicitly so
we need to override them to provide our
own implementation for the equals and
for the next two because we're going to
look at also at the
as you saw there you are going to look
also at hash code because uh equals and
hash code are very linked together and
also the two string function
so we need to override those uh inside
our class
so this is what we're gonna do
so we go inside our user class and here
we need to override the equals function
when we type overwrite and while I'm
dumping you can see that we have three
suggestions here and we select the user
function because this is the one that we
are interested in and as you can see
here
this function is part of the any class
so we press enter we delete the super
return
and the first thing that we need to
check is to see if the current instance
the current object that on which this
equals function is called it's comparing
with its cell so we need to check if the
the if the object is the same as the
object that we are comparing with and to
do that we type here if this
so if this current object is current
instance equals equals so three equals
we check for referential equality to see
if they are the same equals
other so
we type other and if that is the case if
we call we are comparing the same object
so you have user one equals user one
then gonna return true because that
means that uh we are comparing uh with
the same object if that is not true then
the next thing that we need to check we
we're gonna go down here so if not we're
not comparing with uh it's not comparing
with itself then we need to check if the
other so the object which is passed as
an argument to this function which is
called on another object
and to check if other so the argument
is user because we we can uh we need to
check the expressly to see if this
object which is passed as an argument to
our equals function is an user object
because we don't want to check for a
different object we need we need to to
see if this is a new zero object so only
if the object which is passed as an
argument to the equals function is an
user object then we're gonna
return true so here you need to type now
we need to determine we need to Define
our Logic for what it means for two
users to be equal and it's up to you how
we Define this implementation I'm going
to type here only return so I'm gonna my
logic is if they have the same first
name the same last name and the same age
we're gonna say that they are equal we
have the same user of course that in a
real app you can have a more complex
implementation so we type here return
this so This current instance that first
name so
and then put two equals other so
if so the other is because we check here
explicit to see if this is another also
because this condition is going to only
pass if the other
argument is unusual so we type other
because we have access to the first name
and the last name and the age if other
DOT first name so this is our first
condition and
this Dot
this dot last name
so I'm going to check for the all uh for
our three properties
equals equals other so other is another
object because we determine that here
that last name
and
this dot age equals equals H so this
entire expression that is that we have
here is gonna return through only or if
all the our three conditionals so if
this DOT first name is equal to other
that first name so with the object that
is passed as an argument or equals and
if this data last name is equal to other
that last name and if this dot h is
equal to
the other that age let's put here
then and only then we're gonna have a
true here so it's going to return
through otherwise if one of those
condition fails it's gonna return false
and down here you need to if other let's
say doesn't pass so if other reason is
not an user we're gonna return false so
in that case going to turn false now if
I run this code look what happens
so previously we had the false and now
we have true here and this is because
now it's using the equals function which
is inside our user class so it's using
our own implementation so it's checked
here to see if uh our
first name is equal to other DOT first
name so it's checking uh so it's using
our logic inside the the equals function
so this is why you get true and you can
also you can now if you press if you
hold Ctrl here as you can see now it's
taking us inside the equals method that
we defined here it's not taking it
inside the ionic class this is because
now it's using our own implementation so
first to check to see if we are dealing
with the same object then we're going to
return true you're not going to go any
any we're not going to go down and if
this is false you're gonna come up here
you're gonna check to see if other the
object which is passed or equals
function is an user instance it's an
user object then I'm gonna check to see
if our current object that we are
calling on the sqls
function is equal which exclusive for
the first name there is the same we
check to see if the last name is the
same and we check to see if the age is
also the same then in that case it's
going to return true and we're gonna say
that they are structurally equal so
we're gonna see through in the output
else if other is not an user so if you
pass
to the function argument the different
parameter a different argument here
let's say you pass an integer then it's
going to return false here we're going
to come down here so now if you look
here you may be wondering how this
syntax works so we have those signs but
it's calling the equal smart function so
you can also put that equals if it makes
more sense and if we put that equals
user so
so uh
now you can see that but if you hover
over he says replace with the two equals
so it's the same thing as having that
equals and
passing that argument here which is user
two so again we are invoking uh the
equals method on the user one object
let's press Ctrl J
and we are passing our user to objects
and we are using our logic that we
Define here to determine if they are
equal
and you can replace this back to to
equals or if it makes more
visual sense to put the to use the
equals you can use equals it's the same
thing
we put user to here
so as you can see we are calling the
function so this means this object so
this object so defined here this if uh
when we're saying this that first name
it we we mean this object so if this is
that first name it's equal with the
other other that first name it's then we
are calling this object that is passed
here as an argument so
um next we will look we're going to look
at the next two functions because as I
said the equals and hash codes are very
linked together and we're going to also
look at the the two string function and
now if I change the first name for the
user 2 to join and if I run this code
you will get false in the output because
when it will come inside this if it will
check to see if this does first name
equals to other at first name and
because we're using the end operator and
all the conditions have to be true this
is going to return false so I get false
in the output
and um
but if I change it back to Alex
we'll have
true so the objects are structurally
equal based on the logic that we defined
here
inside our equals function
and as I said you also
you can also look at equals and hashcode
because they are very linked together
and uh
the rule is whenever you override equals
you also need to override the the
hashcode and if two objects are
comparing equal so if they are equal
based on the equals method that you
implemented they also have to have the
same hash code
and I'm not going to go into that but
this is because they are
the hash code is used for performers
reasons in collections but we're not to
go now into that we can just type here
override
and uh
here we just type return zero and this
uh this is not gonna affect our equality
at all as I said this hash code it will
make it makes more sense to implement
the hash code in a different way in
collections because they are used um for
performance reasons particularly with
hash set and hashmobs
but uh for now for our simple class
because we don't use this class inside
any collections we don't need because uh
we don't uh don't have to think about
that per the performance reasons to of
the hashcode and uh just if you want to
just uh just return zero here like I
return and yeah because it would work
fine it's not it's not going to affect
at all our equality but remember that
rulebook that if you override the equals
you also have to write a hash code and
uh if two objects are comparing equal
the more must have the same hashcode
this is true as I said particularly in
collections not now because we're not
using this code inside collection
and we can also override the tostring
method and this two string method is
used to return the string representation
of the class so we also type here
override and we have our two string
function I I said method a few times but
there are functions not methods methods
are different thing in Java
and uh
let's delete this function let's type it
again so if you can see
so this is going to return the string
representation of the class so I need to
to return here the values that that are
passed to our to our first name and last
name and age and if we don't do that if
you add the print line here
and you type user1
let's press Ctrl D and user 2. you're
gonna see just some
you're gonna see the user and you're
gonna see some numbers but we're not
gonna see the string representation of
the those two users you're not going to
see Alex so the name and the age so you
see this
dosto but uh
to avoid that because this also use
useful because previously when we want
to
um output in the console the values of
the properties you have to call those
properties and to add multiple Sprint
lines but with the two string
function we can just type here return
and type here
user
we put parenthesis and here we type
first name
we put equals we put dollar sign
let's put a single quotation mark dollar
sign
first name
let's put the quotation marks here a
single quotation marks
last name
equals dollar sign last name let's put
inside the single quotation marks this
comma and age we put also equals dollar
sign h
now if you run this code again now it's
going to use it's gonna one
when we are typing user one and user two
is going to use the tostring function
that we defined inside your class and
it's gonna return the string
representation of that specific object
so if you run this code
we get user and get first name Alex last
name Adobe in h23 and get for the second
you use their first name Alex last name
domain and H22 so now get the string
representation of this class and this is
uh more beautiful because you don't have
to work to always type that user one
user1.a user1. last name the first name
and so on and for the second object two
because now it's using the
two string function with our own
implementation inside here so this is
how you can use the tostring function
and this also how you can use the
password but as I said hashcode is it's
a different discussion which you're
gonna have when we're going to talk
about collections for now just type
return 0 here and then we could all fine
and if you think about there is a lot of
code just to compare to two objects we
have almost
38 line of hold just to to determine if
two objects two user objects are equal
and we also have to override this not
necessary but it will also variety this
hash code and the two strings so there
is a lot of code just to do this uh
simple thing to compare it is to user
objects are equal and because kotlin is
a byte it's about conciseness we don't
actually need to do all of this stuff
but I I thought I thought that it is a
okay to explain to you what you'll need
to do in the past in order to understand
what now questioning is doing better
especially with data classes so you
don't need to
type yourself all of this code that you
have here you can just so if I delete
all of this code let's copy it first and
then delete it
so if I delete all of this code also the
and now if I run this
now we get false and we get those we get
user and this tag text because now we
don't have an implementation of the
equals of the two string of the hashcode
and
if you think as I said it's a lot of
code to implement all of that and in
kotlin you can just type the data
keyword in front of the class and all of
that code not specifically the same
logic but all of that code that we typed
there is going to be generated
automatically for you so the equals
method is going to be generated the hash
code and the tostring and uh
the properties which are going to be
included inside the implementation of
the equals of the inside the of the hash
code and inside of the tostring are
gonna beat all the properties defined
inside the property Constructor so all
the properties defined inside the
property inside the primary Constructor
they're going to be used inside the
implementation of the equals of the
hashcode and the tostring so we just by
putting here the data keyword all of
that code all of that logic is going to
be implemented for us so if you run this
code now
so look at this how concise is compared
to what happens just one line of code
and if if you run our code with the data
keyword
now as you can see we have true and we
have user first name Alex last name so
you have the same output as previously
and just by putting data keyword
all of that was all of these calls so
let's press Ctrl J all of this squad
not specifically
exactly this code but all of this code
all the implementation of the equals of
the harsh code entry was generated
automatically for us just by uh just by
putting the data keyword in front of our
class
and if you don't want to have a property
included in the implementation of the
of the equals or of the harsh code or of
the the two string you can just omit it
from here and you just you declare it
inside the
inside the class so if I put let's say
here so if I delete this because data
classes cannot have parameters
and I declared it inside the class
inside the data class
VAR age and it will sign a value because
we cannot let
the property uninitialized
let's delete this now
and if you run this now that property is
going to be excluded from the
implementation of the equals the hash
code and of the two string so we have
here true but we have a first name Alex
last name Domi so now the limitation for
the equals only includes those
properties the first name and the last
name and also for the to string function
we have only the first name and the last
name the age is excluded but
let's put this back
so this is what data classes are they
are generating
Auto automatically for you the
implementation of the equals the harsh
code the two string also for the copy
function and for the component function
but we're going to look at the copy of
copy function in a separate video and
they generate all of that code that we
saw previously that we talked about
automatically for you by just putting
the data keyword you put the properties
inside the primary Constructor and all
of that implementation is going to be
generated for you for all the properties
you find inside the primary construction
and just that just by one line of code
all of that logic is generated
automatically so this is what data
classes are see you in the next video so
now it's time to start a discussion
about interfaces so what are interfaces
interfaces
um are you used when you want to have a
commonly used Behavior shared among
different classes but you don't
want to provide the actual code that
goes inside the class which is going to
implement that interface but you just
want to define the the name of the
function and the parameter of the
function
the actual code that goes inside the the
functions that you define in inside the
interface
they are particular to each object that
implements that specific interface
so
let's say that you have
let's say that we have some classes
let's say that you have a class car a
class which is uh which represents a
truck and you have a class which
represents
represents a plane you know that all of
those three objects have in common the
same behavior of starting the engine
let's say and you don't know how each
particular class is going to start the
engine but you know that each class is
gonna have in common this function which
is
I'm gonna start the engine again you
don't care about the particular how each
particular object is gonna uh what code
goes inside the or what uh logic goes
inside The Stand start engine function
for each of those particular objects but
to care only about the fact that they
they share the same behavior they they
all start the engine but how they start
the engine is uh particular to
each class and this is what we do with
interfaces we only Define the what so
what what we Define in the interface
only the
the the what and the what represents the
what those classes are gonna have in
common so you know that they uh gonna
have a function called start engine but
you don't
don't know how each object how each
class is gonna Implement that logic and
to that to to for that I'm gonna use an
interface so we Define what needs to be
done but we don't Define how it's going
to be done so to declare an interface we
go down here at the enclosing calibrates
of the main function and we type
interface and while I'm typing you see
that we have this suggestion we type we
press enter we can type the entire word
if you want so interface and I'm going
to call this internal phase engine and
the name of the interface should be with
a capital letter to start a capital
letter it should be in Pascal case if it
has multiple words
and the interfaces cannot have
Constructors because they cannot be
instantiated you cannot create you
cannot create an object with an
interface interfaces are used only they
are created only to be implemented by
classes they cannot be instantiated so
we need to put curly braces and inside
the
the body inside the curly braces we
Define what needs to be done so we
Define only
the function we Define we type the name
of the function I'm going to call it
start engine
but we don't Define the actual code for
the function so we put parenthesis here
you can Define parameters if you want
but we don't put curly braces and we
Define our logic here because we only
care what about what needs to be done so
we only care that each class needs to
start the engine how it's going to start
the engine it's up to each particular
class
so we go down here we type class and I'm
going to create a class called car and
it's going to have a
a vowel name which is going to be a
string
and a vaal color which is also going to
be a string
and now to implement the interface we
put colon and we type engine
and as you can see we have this engine
we have this eye for interface here so
you press enter then we put curly braces
to define the body of the class and now
we have this underline here and this
underline is here to tell us that we
need to in now we need to implement the
we need to implement this function
because the the interface and the class
have a contract is like a contract and
the contract says that if you implement
an interface you need to you must
Implement you must override the the the
function so you need to implement the
function you still will this is why we
have here here an underline so if I
click on this underline what if I hover
over there and I click
on the light on the red bulb you see
that it says Implement members so click
on Implement and have our
start engine function we click OK and
now our functions was overrided here and
we have this to do which is not yet
implemented and this is there to to tell
us that this method this function is not
Yeti implemented so we need to define
the actual logic here
and let's create two other classes let's
um
call this class track
and it's also going to have a name a Val
going to be a string
and the color also string
and we're gonna also
implement the interface so I'm going to
put colon engine then we put curabase
now we need to implement because I said
there is a contact between the interface
and the class and the contract says that
you need to implement the function
so we Implement a function here and we
create another class
call plane
and it's also going to have a Val name
it's going to be a string
and the eval color also string
and here we put colon and we're gonna
also implement the interface interface
inside the plane class
and we put call on engine our interface
then curly braces and now we have the
underline because again we there is the
contract now between the interface and
the class and that says that we need to
implement this function inside our plane
class
and we have those to do and those to do
are here to tell us that we need to
we need to imple we need to provide some
logic to the to the actual function so
let's delete those and let's put some
code here
so let's delete this
and let's add the print line here which
is gonna output some text to the console
and we're gonna have the text the car
you
starting
the engine
and I'm gonna copy this because now I'm
gonna put here some text
I'm gonna say the
track is starting the engine
and here is going to say the plane
starting the engine
now what what we have done here and what
we did here is that
we know that each class respectively our
car our tracking and our plane they all
gonna start the engine so they all gonna
share this start engine Behavior the one
all all gonna have this functionality
what we don't know is how each class how
each how each object is gonna start the
engine because they uh they start the
engine in a different way the engine of
of a car is different from an engine of
a truck or form of Lane so we know that
each each is gonna
not that each class or each object is
gonna start the engine but we don't know
how they're gonna start the engine so
here we go inside the actual uh feelings
inside the the function which we type
the text the car is starting the engine
the truck is starting the engine and the
plane is starting the engine so they
differed in how they start the engine
but you know that they all gonna they
all gonna start the engine so this is
what interfaces allows us to do
you can define an interface if you know
that uh multiple uh related or unrelated
classes or objects are gonna have a
function shared between them but you
don't know how each particular class or
object is gonna em is gonna uh how is
gonna how it's gonna have the actual
quad uh how it's gonna write the actual
code for that uh that behavior so you
don't you don't care about the how you
want to care about the what so we know
that in this case they will start the
engine but they they start the engine in
a different way and you can have here
another class let's say
that a person which creates another
another class and the class is gonna be
called Tesla and in that case again you
can implement the interface because you
know that uh the Tesla is also going to
start the engine you don't know how it's
going to start the engine but you know
that uh is going to start the engine and
how it's going to start the engine is
specific to a Tesla car so this is what
interfaces allow us to do we can Define
uh some shared Behavior between
unrelated or related classes and that
the actual code you don't Define any
code inside the interface you can put
you actually can Define here a property
but uh uh usually you just Define uh the
the function the function name some
parameters and the actual code goes
inside the class which implements that
interface let's let's actually create
here a class Tesla so we put here
let's put this a little bit up
so we put here class Tesla is gonna have
also a Val name
it's going to be a string
Naval color
and this is also going to be a string so
now we can Implement our engine
interface so we don't know how Tesla is
going to start the engine but we know
that it's going to start the engine so
we we Implement our interface put call
on the name of the interface and now we
need to implement the start engine so we
click on that
and we have not yet implemented let's
put our print line here I'm going to
press Ctrl V
and here's gonna say that's like
starting the engine
so this is what interfaces are and
see you in the next video
because I'm going to end the video now
so here you should say a Tesla is
starting the engine not the Tesla
so I collected that
so I thought it's a good idea to show
you a practical example using Android
studio where interfaces are used because
the when I first learned about
interfaces and after classes I found
them very confusing because they are
very very abstract and you don't see
when when you somebody teaches you those
Concepts you don't see how where and
where you're gonna use those uh those
Concepts interfaces and Abstract classes
and for that I'm going to open Android
Studio
to show you a practical example using
interfaces and also organize Android
Studio to show you a practical example
where we're going to use
abstract classes so I opened Android
Studio you don't need to it looks
similar to our IntelliJ because this
IntelliJ IDEA just that is it's Android
Studio so we will click on my
application
and here we have this thing called main
activity we don't need to worry about
this because as I said I just want to
show you where interfaces are used in
Android Studio to get to get an idea
about where they are used because I said
they are very abstract
foreign
this thing called activity.main This is
where we put our
UI this is where we put our buttons this
is where we put our list views uh this
is where we put generally our UI so as
you can see we have two buttons here and
they have an ID
again I'm not gonna go into this but if
you click here on design you see that we
have a login button and a sign up button
so this is the UI part of our app now
I'm gonna click on this main activity
and this is the part where you're gonna
put our code and now I'm gonna link
those UI buttons so let's go to quad so
this is the code for creating those
buttons
and I'm gonna link those buttons because
they have this ID here login button so
you have here Android ID
and if you come from Android Studio you
already know all of this I'm gonna link
those UI buttons with some objects
buttons by typing some code so I'm gonna
Define up here
foreign
called the login button
and it's going to be of type button so
this is a class button
then I'm gonna Define another later need
because I'm not gonna initialize it
right there so Laten it again
sign up button
and it's gonna be also of type button so
types like we have types for uh for our
numbers or for our just that this is a
class and this rep this class is a
button objectives and now we need to
link those those objects that we created
here
with those buttons that we have here
those UI buttons so to link those login
button and sign up button
and to do that to go down here
and I'm gonna I'm gonna go I'm gonna do
this in the longer way and here we type
login button again you don't need to
understand all of this this is just to
illustrate how interfaces work I'm gonna
put equals
and now I'm going to type find view by D
and this function find view by ID is
gonna link our button object that we
created here with our UI button
that we have
that we have created here and it's going
to be linked by its ID by this ID that
we have here login button so if you go
here hero Type R so R is this thing
which uh
again don't need to understand all of
these arrays is used to to get that ID
to link our button object with our
button UI so if you put r dot ID that
and we have our uh our two IDs so we
choose login button
so now we have linked our UI button with
our button object so we linked the UI in
other words with the code now let's link
also the setting up button so we type
here saying a button
equals find view by ID you you also type
r dot ID Dot
sign up button again you don't need to
type this code because probably you
don't even have Android Studio this is
just to illustrate something
now
to illustrate how interfaces work let's
say that I want to
let's say that I want to
to do something when this login button
is clicked and I want to do also
something when design up button is
clicked and it and here interface is
coming to action
what you can do is you can say login
button
Dot and there is a function called set
on click listener and this function what
is doing is
basically setting a listener on our UI
button so that when you click on that
button the function called on click is
going to be executed and the code that
is going to be in that function is
particular to each to each button so
you you you're gonna set the interface
so you types don't click listener and
hero type also this illustrates uh the
object also this by by this example we
also illustrate how the Anonymous
classes work so you type object
and now I'm gonna inherit actually gonna
Implement our interface on click
listener and this only listener
interface has a function called on click
and here to put curly braces and press
enter and now here we have this
underline
and if you click on it you have this red
bulb because it wants us to implement
to implement that on click function so
we're going to implement that
and it says to do not get implemented
I'm not going to do the same thing for
the
for the sign up button so I'm gonna copy
this
I'm gonna paste it down here
and I'm going to change this to sign up
button so now each individual each
individual button has us on has its own
on click listener interface and the code
which is going to be executed inside the
one click method because this function
is going to be triggered when you click
on the button is particular to each
button so this button is going to log in
the user this button you're gonna put
here the code to sign up the user but
you're not going to do that we're just
gonna
we're gonna uh show some text on our
emulator so we type here to show the
text toast
dot make text here you need to pass the
context so don't worry about all of this
main.activity here you need to pass uh
how how long this is gonna show on the
screen so we choose a short
and we put that show to show this on the
actually here we need to pass the text
so what text is going to be shown on the
screen so here we're gonna say
login button
clicked
and now here we need to pass how long
it's going to slow so you type those Dot
short so if it's going to be shown for a
short time and then we need to call the
show functions to show this on the
screen and I'm going to press Ctrl uh C
to copy this and I'm gonna paste inside
our on click function in our interface
that we have here for the sign up button
and this is gonna say
that
sign up button was click so sign up
button
clicked
now in Android Studio we have what is
called an emulator and this is basically
a virtual phone and we can run you can
run our code and we can test our code
and we're gonna see when
on that emulator those buttons and when
you're going to click on those buttons
this code that we Define here for for
those buttons because we linked them so
we linked
those two buttons that have the login
button the sign up button so this is
their UI code this is their XML code
you we've linked them through code here
and when we click on them the Code in
each particular object is going to be
executed so now if you run our code go
up here and I'm gonna create now the
virtual font to see our buttons and I'm
going to click on them to see how it
works
I'm going to close those
now it's connecting to the emulator
and this is our virtual virtual phone so
this is the virtual phones and here we
have our UI that we created here
so this is what the users see so this
the what the user say and this is what
we see it's the this is what happens
under the covers and now if I click on
this login button look what happens
it says login button click so it
executes this on click function inside
the login button if I click on the
sign up button it says sign up button
click because it's executing the one
click function and the code inside the
one click function for the sign up
button
and they are as I said linked by the by
the ID so this is what happens under the
covers this is what the user see
now
this is where interfaces can be used
because if you think about you can have
multiple uis different uis text views
lists or
items into the items in a list which can
be clicked and for all of those you know
that always go all of them are gonna
have on click function all all all have
this shared functionality to respond to
a click you don't know how that is gonna
how that that one click function is
gonna
execute or what code that on click
function is going to have for each
particular UI uh UI but you know that
each each one is gonna have one click
function what is going to go inside the
one click function for you for each
particular
UI it's up to that specific UI so it's
up to a button it's up to a text views
and so on so this is a over interfaces
are used because we know that they're
going to have a shared functionality of
one click but you don't know how that
functionality is going to be implemented
by each particular uis in our case we do
we know that login button and sign up
button
both both are going to have a one click
both we're gonna are gonna respond to
click events but you don't know what
they're gonna do so this is why you
define the interface and the developers
who write code gonna Implement that
interface and you're gonna write the
actual implementation for that function
which is specific to that object so this
is our discussion and if you find this
confusing
particularly if I'm confusing the uh if
because I touch a little bit on Android
Studio in our discussion don't be
because I just wanted to show you a
practical example where interfaces are
used using Android studio so let's click
again on login button
we get our toast login button clicked
slang a button click I can create
another button which can be used for a
I don't know if you forgot the password
and you you're gonna implement the on
click listener you're gonna override the
you're gonna override the one click
function I'm gonna write some code to
to send uh to send to help help the user
to recover its uh puzzle and so on so we
can see how interfaces can be used
practically in this with this example
so this is our discussion see you in the
next video so now it's time to start a
discussion about object expression but
first let's go down here and let's
create a class to see why you'll need to
use object expression in the first place
so you type here class
and now and our class is going to be
called button
we put the parenthesis to create the
primary Constructor we Define some
properties here the first one is going
to be text is going to be of type string
the second one is going to be also
available it's going to be called ID
it's gonna be an integer
and the last one is going to be called
One Click listener
it's going to be of type on click
listener so this is an interface that
we're gonna create
so let's go down here to create the
interface we type interface on and while
I'm jumping you see that you have this
suggestion one click listener
to create the interface press enter
put curly braces and let's define a
function fun
on click
let's put parenthesis
now let's create some objects with our
class button to see why you'll need to
use a
object expression in the first place so
let's go here
and here we type Val let's call it login
button
put equal and now let's create our
object type button
with parenthesis now let's pass some
values to the properties of the primary
Constructor
and this is gonna have the text to login
for the ID we type some arbitrary
numbers here one two one three
two
and um
now here you need to pass the one click
listener interface but do not we cannot
type here one click listener because
we cannot instantiate the interface so
what can we do to solve this problem
one solution to this would be to create
a separate class here
let's put it actually above the
interface
let's call it click listener this class
class
click listener and this class is going
to implement the interface
so we put here colon and we call our on
click listener interface put curly
braces
and now we need to implement that one
click method that one click function
that we defined actually
inside our own click listen interface so
press ok to override to add on click
function
and we have that
to do we have this to do which says to
do not yet implemented so this is there
to tell us that it's not implemented yet
so let's delete this
all right so what we could do is you can
create here an instance of the
click listener so we type here Val
click listener
equals create the instance we'll create
an object
and now you can pass here the click
listener
so now the arrow disappeared but if I
create a second object let's call it the
sign up button
equals button
let's pause the text so
sign up
for the ID was an arbitrary number
now
in our imaginary or
example that we have here
actually if you think for real scenario
with this button and the one click
listen what we want to achieve here is
that if you have a graphical user
interface
you want that you want to detect that
click so you want to declare detect one
that specific button let's see that this
button object that we have here is
linked to an uh graphical button which
on which you click
because they are linked when you click
on that you want to
call that one click function that is
defined inside our interface inside here
but you want to
make that one click interface we want
you want to make that one click function
particular to particular to that button
which was clicked so we we want to to
implement that uh one click function to
that particular button which was clicked
and the code that goes inside that
particular button so let's say that you
click on the login button it's
particular to that button so that in the
next
when the next button is clicked so when
if the user clicks for when the sign up
button then you know you need to also
have the one click
method called but that one click that
one click function actually I I keep
saying method but the one click function
should should have its own
implementation a particular to the sign
up button so what can we do in that case
we cannot pass the same instance here to
click listener because even if it
creates here another instance of the
click listener it will still have the
same code which is here so if you put
here some code this is code blue it will
be shared among all the objects that are
created so what you can do in this case
is to use an object expression
or also called anonymous
anonymous anonymous classes so what you
can do here we can type object
we put colon and now we
are inheriting from our we are actually
implementing our own click listener
interface so we type object colon on
click listener and we put curly braces
because here we declare and we also
instantiate the the anonymous class so
we need to implement that right there
so by doing this now we where we made
the one click function particular to
each object Which object button so we
can do the same thing here we type
object
and we Implement our on click listener
interface we put curly braces now we
need to implement
for this particular object for the sign
up
or button objects we need to implement
that function so if we type we click we
click on this object
we go to the red light bulb and we type
we press here where it says Implement
members so implement the one click
function and now what we did here is we
made the one click
function particular to each object so
each object now we can put here some
code
or we can type here this sign
in
actually let's type login
that was it so now we can have code here
which actually log logs in if you have a
real graphical user interface which logs
logs in the user and here you can also
code to sign up the user when that
specific button is clicked
so by doing by using the object
expression also called Anonymous class
because you don't have
reference you don't have a name for the
class here you just it's just Anonymous
for this
is anonymous so we cannot it does not
have a name so we cannot call it later
or do something because it's created and
also instantiating right there this is
why I need to implement the one click
function and now we made the one click
function particular to each button and
you have more
objects more objects of created with the
class
button they'll have their own
implementation of the one click
function which comes from the interface
on click listener
so this is why you need to use the
anonymous
class or also called object expression
and it's an expression because the value
that the because the object is always
it's created and instantiate it is
actually declared and instantiated at
the same time it's also assigned to the
property that we Define here so this is
why it's called an expression
so see you in the next video
all right so now it's time to start a
discussion about delegation but first
I'm going to add the main function here
now what is delegation delegation means
giving power given Authority from one
instance from one class to another class
and delegation is usually used in in
scenarios where inheritance starts to
break so when inheritance starts to
break when you want let's say it for
whatever reason to inherit from two
classes in that case you can't use
inheritance because with inheritance you
can you inherit just from only one class
but with delegation you can plug in
multiple
implementation of classes in your own
class and let's see how we can do that
so I'm going to create first an
interface called a and it's going to
have a function called print
then I'm going to create another
interface called B and it's going to
have a function print though
then I'm going to create a class so I'm
going to type here class and it's going
to be called first delegate and it's
going to implement the fun the interface
a here
and I'm gonna press Ctrl o to override
the function print here
and I'm going to create another class
called second delegate
and this is going to implement the
interface B
so I'm going to place Ctrl to override
the
function print tool
now I'm going to create up here a class
called up
so class up
now let's say that I want here to
inherit from the first delegate and from
the second regulator so I'm going to
inform the single delegate and if I type
here first delegate
I put parenthesis opening parentheses
closing parentheses
if I put curly braces now I have another
line because I should Mark this as open
so mark this as open and also this as
open because I want to show you that so
now if I want to inherit from the second
class called from the second delegate
because let's say that I want to use the
the print to function in my class for
whatever reason
I can't because I can't only inherit
from one class so if I hover over here
over this underline it says only only
one class may appear in a super type
list so in other words saying that you
can only inherit from one class and that
is all we cannot inherit from multiple
classes now with delegation we can plug
in multiple implementations in our own
class so what I can do here I can say
hey
implement the interface a so I'm going
to inherit it from the interface a but
you're gonna say use for the interface a
the implementation of the first delegate
class so this is what we're saying here
a and the keyword by first delegate
we're saying hey use for the interface a
the implementation which is provided by
the first delegate class and that will
work
then I'm going to put a comma here and
I'm going to say use also for the class
B so I'm going to type for the interface
B so we're gonna type B and we're gonna
use the by key you're also going to type
here by
second delegate so you're saying use for
the interface B the second delegate
implementation and it's gonna use that
and it's gonna be him
happy with that so you're gonna see that
we get no error and now I can override
here both the print function and also
the print to function so if I press Ctrl
o now I can override also the print too
and this is inherently very powerful
because we can plug in here multiple as
many implementations as you want in your
class so this is in the if you think
about in contrast with the inheritance
this is very powerful because here you
can plug in as many implementations as
you want and this is very powerful so
this is how you can use the delegation
in kotlin and next we're going to see
how you can use delegation with
properties
so to use delegation on properties first
I'm going to paste some code here so I'm
going to paste this code here and what
we are having here is a class format
delegate which is inheriting from the
read and write property
and it's overriding the get value and
the set value so we are overriding the
setter and the getter inside our class
and we provide our own implementation so
whenever you
you use the setter to set a value or to
get as a get a value we we are
overriding those functions and we
provide our own implementation next I'm
going to create here up here a class but
first I'm going to delete the code and
the interface that we have here because
we don't need this code
so I'm gonna delete this code and I'm
going to create another class
and this class is going to be called
user I'm going to put curly braces and
I'm going to define the properties
inside the class so I'm going to type
here VAR
first name so what we are doing now is
we're creating a property first it's
called first name and I'm going to use
the by queue we're just going to say buy
format delegate so what we are saying
now is use the
use the the we use the code which is
inside the format delegate Whenever you
set the value or get the value of the
first name I'm going to put the
parenthesis here next I'm going to type
another VAR last name and I'm going to
type here again bye and I'm going to
type format delegate so format delegate
and we put parentheses
so not now what is going to happen is
that whenever you set the first name
properly or we get the name the first
name property is going to use our
implementation that we provided here
this is what you're gonna do and the
same it will be true for the last name
because we are using the
delegation here on properties so I'm
going to create here a user so I'm going
to type here Val
user want to type equals to user
and I'm gonna type here with
I'm gonna type user this is the
scope function I'm going to put curly
curly braces and I'm going to type here
first name
equals Alex
and the last name
equals uh
dominga
now if I output those values in the
console look what happens so if I tap it
here print line
user that first name
and print line let's actually use again
with the scope function type here with
just pass here user curly braces
print line
first name
and print line
last name
now if you run this code you're gonna
see
that it's using the overriding functions
that we provide in our format delegate
so we have in uppercase letters like we
defined here we're gonna wanna whenever
we set about is going to be set it with
the it's going to change the value to
lowercase letter so get Alex and obinka
in lowercase letters so this is how you
can use the delegation on properties and
see you in the next video
so now it's time to start a discussion
about collections but first i'm going to
create a new project I'm going to call
it collections
for the language select link for the
build system IntelliJ make sure to have
the jdk selected and also check this box
to have the main function Auto generated
for us so I'm going to click on create
to create the project
now I'm going to delete this code
because you don't need this code
and also I'm going to hide the project
pane
now what are collections collections are
a group of objects stored together in a
single variable they are similar to
array but there are there are different
in some sense and
they are mainly three collections that
we're gonna look at and this those are
the list the set and the map and the and
those among those
collections they are separated in two
groups so there are multiple multiple
lists and set air maps and immutable
lists set and map and in the motable
means that you can write to that
collection so you can add or or remove
elements to it so the that collection
can grow or Shrink as you add or remove
elements to it and immutable means that
you can only add elements when it when
you instantiate that or we're going to
create that collection you cannot add
later elements to it the size is fixed
so we cannot add or remove element so
this is the difference between immutable
and multiple and we're gonna look at all
of those in this video so we're gonna
look at the list collection first and
we're gonna look at an immutable list so
we type Val I'm going to create a
variable names and here we're gonna type
to create an immutable list type list of
and here we need to specify the type
what kind of data I'm going to put here
and do type name one
name two
and name three now we cannot add or
remove elements from this list because
it's an immutable list but we can get on
Elemental output in the console and to
do that to type it in the line
we type names we put square brackets and
we get the element by its index and the
index also starts at zero so let's get
the first element
so if you're on this code you'll see
name one I'll put it in a new console
so you get name one so this is an
immutable list we cannot add or remove
elements from it after we
instantiate it here what now now let's
look at an mutably so a list which can
within which you can add and remove
elements to it so to do that we just
change this from a list of to a mutable
list of
so we type here multiple
we can also remove the explicit type
here the explicit type declaration
because it's gray out
so remove that because it can be
inferred and to this mutable list now we
can add or remove the elements so I can
type here names
and we have this add function so you can
type add
and here we can
you can pass a new element so we pass
here let's say name
4. now if I uh let's type here names
that for each
print line
not in this footage
name start
for each this for each
opening the line
now if you run this
now you see you have name one name two
name three and name four so name four
was added to our Multiple List because
our list is multiple we can add or
remove new elements so down here I can
I can type names dot remove
and we can remove an element and we can
remove the element I think by
you can remove you can use this function
remove art so we can remove the element
by its index so we can type here the
index
and that is going to remove the first
element so if you run this code
name one is not going to be showed
so as you can see name one was removed
because you can you will remove it by
its index and we can also remove an
element
using this function by typing uh
the elements so we type here let's say
name
two
name two elements and now it's going to
be removed so now if you run this
name two was removed so those are two
functions with which you can remove
elements from the Multiple List so this
is a multiple list you can add and
remove elements to it and the list is
gonna grow and Shrink as you add or
remove elements to it so this is the
Multiple List
now
we're gonna look at a set and I set this
a collection which can store only unique
unique elements so you cannot have
duplicates so if I delete this
so in our
in our Multiple List you can put an
element which is the same
so we can have two elements which are
the same so if you run this
we have two elements which are the same
going to see name one at the end I have
name one name two name three and name
one again so you can have uh duplicates
in our collection on our multiple list
but in a set you can't so but first
we're gonna look at uh first we're gonna
look at the immutable set and then add
automotive ball set so we type here uh
let's delete this
we type here set off
and here you need to buy string
now if you run this
you will see that name one is not shown
two times here it's going to be shown
only one time so you have name one name
two and name three this is because the
set Seto the set is not allowing
duplicates in its uh in its list so
and this is a new multiple set set off
so if I type here names dot add we
cannot add or remove new elements but
you can also use
a multiple set of so we type here
Moto motable
set off
and now we can add and remove new
elements so you can type names that add
so here you can add a new element let's
say
name
so now if you run this
I'm going to name one name two name
three name four
and our duplicate is not strong because
I said a set can only
can only store unique elements not
duplicates but if I add objects that we
create look what happens so let's create
some user objects but first let's create
the class user
and it's gonna have a
Val name is going to be of type string
no let's create some user objects here
and we're gonna add to our multiple set
so we type here
wall user one
I'm gonna type here
user
I'm going to pass some generic names
like
name one and let's control the a few
times
let's change this to name two
five
and let's add here a Val
user
six
equals user
and let's type here Alex
let's press Ctrl d
and let's change this to
user 7.
now let's add those to our
multiple cells so let's change now the
type
so it's gonna store user objects
so we're gonna pass here
user one I'm going to speed up now this
a little bit
I'm gonna press Ctrl tilde format the
code
now we can add this we cannot add here a
name for because now the type is user
now if you're on this let's actually
change this print to it dot name
and let's let's run our code now
and we have name one name two name three
name four Nerf name five and have Alex
two times so why you have duplicates
even though I said that sets can only
store unique elements this is because
previously the set actually what is
doing to determine to if to if it has
duplicates is using the equals to
function that we talked about in our
video about data classes so when we
typed only strings then it was using the
equals to function which was overridden
inside the string class to determine if
there are uh if there are equal strings
but now because our class doesn't have
the equals to function over it then it's
in its class it's not it's using the
equals to function which is inside the
ending class so you cannot determine if
two users are are equal and to change
that just let's hide the console
and just put the data keyword here
because now this will generate the
equals to function the the the two
string and
the harsh code so now if you run this
now we have Alex only one time because
now it's using the equals to function
which was uh Auto generated by by uh by
the class user because you put here the
data key or so this is a good thing to
have in mind that
this model set is using the equals to
function to determine if the object that
you add to to yourself are equal so
having this in mind now let's look at
Maps so I'm going to close this
I'm gonna delete this
let's delete this
let's delete this also
now let's look at the next collection
that you can use in kotlin and that is
the map collection and use collection
when you want to store key value pairs
so I'm going to create a variable it's
going to be called users
and I'm going to put equals and I'm
going to create first animated bottom up
so we type map off
map
of and here you need to specify what
kind of type is going to be the key so
the key is going to be an integer but
you can put any class you want here
and the value is going to be a string so
I'm going to store the ID and the name
of an user
and to Define our element in pairs here
we type first the key and then we use
the to keyword to map our kit to its
element so 2 is value actually so type 1
2 and now the value let's first type
Maria so
now we have one element stored in paired
and the key is one the value is Maria
next I'm gonna do the same for the next
one so I'm gonna type here
two
the keyword tool
Alex
and then
I'm gonna type three
the keyword tool
so inside you need to type the value now
now type John
now to get one element from this map
with I print line
we type here users
square brackets
and we type we get the element by its
key as you can see by this hint key so
we get let's say the element one
so now if you run this code
we get Maria because Maria has because
this key code is for the for the key one
the value mapped the value which is
corresponding to this key is Maria and
if you change this to two
gonna get Alex if you run this
so this is an immutable map in this map
you cannot add or remove elements but if
I declare this as
a multiple map so let's change this to a
multiple map
so we type here mutable
map off
let's delete this from here
and let's pass here and
and string
now here now
so you need to put this in parenthesis
here we can add new elements so we can
type users
actually first let's Loop through our
mob to see
our elements and I'm going to use the
for each function to Loop so we type
here users dot for each
and we choose this one
and inside our Rook without we are the
print line
and
I'm going to put quotation marks and
here we're going to put dollar sign I'm
going to type T and T is the key and
dollar sign U and U is the value so now
if you're on this
you get one and Maria to and Alex Three
Angels so we have the key and we have
the corresponding values and you cannot
have duplicated keys and this is very
important to know you can also add or
remove elements
from this map so to add an element you
just type users
and we need to specify the key
so we put square brackets so we type
user square brackets and then put a key
let's say five
and we put here equals to and here we
need to pass a value so the value is
going to be let's say
Vlog now if you run this
we get one and Maria two and Alex three
and John N5 and the corresponding value
Vlad so Vlad has the Kiwi the key value
five
so you can also remove an element from
our map so we type users dot remove
you know you you here for this remove
function you pass the key of the of the
element that you want to be removed and
let's say that I remove two so I remove
Alex from our map so if I run this quad
now Alex you know it's not going to be
shown here
because it was removed on the line for
so Alex was removed so this is how you
can use the immutable and multiple Maps
this is how you can add and remove
elements and this is how you can Loop
through our map and this is our
discussion about Collections and see you
in the next video now it's time to start
a discussion about collections
operations and we're going to look at
the first operation and that is
Transformations and we're going to start
with the first one called mapping so I'm
going to create a new project
I'm going to call it
collections
operations
IntelliJ then click on create
we go on the left hand side
click on kotlin right click new I'm
going to create a new file I'm going to
call it Main
I'm going to create the main function
now
what are transformations as the name
implies Transformations are some
functions which which you can change a
specific collection
and we're going to look at the first one
which is called mapping so I'm going to
create first
a collection so I'm going to type Val
numbers and it's going to be a set so
I'm going to type numbers you're gonna
equals to set off
and here we're gonna Define some values
like one two
three four five
let's press Ctrl alt format the code
now I'm gonna add the print line here
now to use the mapping collection
transformation we just type numbers
and one important thing to know here is
that those
transformation functions are Lambda
functions so if you don't know what
Lambda functions are I suggest you to
watch the section which is called Lambda
function to First understand what our
Lambda functions because it will be it
will be very hard for you to understand
how this how those Transformations work
without understanding how Lambda
functions work
now
here we're gonna call our our
transformation function which is the
first one which as I said is mapping and
the function is called map I'm going to
explain immediately what it's doing and
as you can see it's a Lambda function so
we're going to press enter
and we we are inside the curly braces
and here we're gonna Define our
transformation so what we are saying
basically here is
do whatever I I type here in this those
uh
curly braces apply to every element of
the of this cell of this collection so
if I if uh now to refer to to refer to
the parameter uh uh to the specific
parameter from the numbers uh uh set we
type it
and I'm gonna type it times
10. so what we are saying here is
do this transformation so change this uh
change this uh this set by uh more
multiplying every element inside the
this uh this collection inside this set
by 10. so if you run this now every
number is going to be multiplied by 10.
so if I run this
now we get instead of one two three four
and five we get 10 20 30 45 so what this
map function and what this uh it times
10 did is is it transformed it changed
our set into into what it it was changed
by the expression that we defined here
so we said that I want every element we
said here to be multiplied by 10 and
then we display them here
we can go even further we can put here
an if statement so we can type here if
let's say it so it refers to the to a
specific element in that list in that
set so if it equals equals so if equals
three I'm gonna say
we're gonna say here
it
times
100.
so what we're saying here if one of
those elements inside these numbers set
is equal to 3 then multiply it change it
so change it by by the by this
expression so multiply it by 100 and you
can also put the else part so we put
else you want to put it times
so if the else part is true if the else
part is executed we're saying if the
number is not equal to 3 from this list
then multiply the number multiply the
number by uh by 10. so now if I run this
look what we have here
so we have 10 20 and we have 300 here
this is because this transformation now
is using the if and else statements that
you define here so this is what the map
Transformations allows you to do you can
change you can transform a specific
collection by an expression that we
defined inside the curly braces of the
map function
all right
now let's look at how we can can use the
map transformation to with another
collection unless you'll see how can you
can use the map transformation with a
map so with uh with the with the map
which has a key and a value so to do
that we just type here
Val
numbers map so I'm going to type file
numbers
equals I'm going to type map off
and here I'm gonna type
key
one
two
then
key
tool
two two then
key three
two
three
and
finally key
for
two
four
now if you wanna use the map map
transfer transformation function on the
map map collection you you you can use
it either on the keys so you can use it
on the keys or on the values so we can
type here print line
number map
number map so we choose here
Dot and we choose map Keys now so choose
this one map key Lambda expression so
map keys that one and here to type eat
dot key so get the key Dot uppercase so
that is going to upper case all the keys
inside our map then I'm gonna add an
another print line here
I'm gonna type number map
Dot
map
now choose
map values
and we type here it dot value
so the Value Plus
it dot key dot length
now if you run this though this
expression is going to be applied to all
of our keys inside our numbers map that
we Define above and the second
transformation is going to be applied to
all the values that we defined inside
our numbers map so if you run this code
now I'm going to see the
the keys being first uppercase and then
we're going to see the keys plus plus
the length so you see
first I get 10 20 300 for 40 and 50 for
our first transformation that we have
here
then we have our second then we have our
transformation on the map on the map
keys so we have we have the key and then
we have the value we have he and the the
key is uppercase because we said uh to
to do that by using this expression it
so it uppercase all the keys as you can
see here and then you see the
corresponding value for the key
after that you see
you have numbers map map that value so
you have it that Value Plus e dot key
dot length so we have key
and I have one and we have six we have
key two and half seven so the key the
value of the key is uh is uh to the
value of the key it's added the length
of the
so to the value that we have here we we
have added the the value length of the
string key that we defined here so this
way I have uh we have uh two then we
have seven then we have eight and then
we have nine
so this is our and you can also
you can also do for the uh map for the
map transformation and we type here
numbers
Dot map
and we choose this one index not node
and here we choose we have two
parameters first is the index and second
is the value so I'm gonna choose the
name for the first one index and for the
second one let's call it uh
value then you have the auto and here we
have we're going to Define our
transformation of our expression which
is going to be applied on our numbers so
here I can use the index so again I'm
going to type here an effects if a
statement so if
index
equals equals zero then I'm gonna
assign so I'm going to transform to the
to that we're going to put the value
null
to the index 0 else
I'm gonna type index
times value
so else you're gonna uh multiply the
index time times the value so if you run
this
we get 2 6 12 and 20. so for for the
first one we get nothing because we for
the first index we signed null
and then uh it's using the else part to
to transform our numbers list and it's
multiplying the index by the value so we
we first uh
we first have this indexed uh
zero multiply the here we have null for
this because we checked here so we have
not so at the index two we have one
times two and uh we have two then here
we have add indexed two we have two
times three so the index is two the
value is three and uh we we get uh we
get six here and so on so this is how we
can use also the index if you want in
your transformation now we're going to
look at the next transformation that you
can do in our collection and that is
zipping
now it's time to look at the
transformation function called zipping
so I'm going to add a comment here
called the
zipping
and I'm going to declared to list I'm
gonna call the first one colors
no particles
I'm gonna type please stop
I'm gonna type red
Brown
and
Gray
and I'm going to create another list
called the animals
stuff
I'm gonna type here Fox
beer
quotation marks
and uh
wolf
now
what does the zipping or the zip
functions allow us to do is to create
pairs of elements with the same position
in both collections so we can create
pairs with red we can create a pair of
fox and red a pair of bear and brown and
a pair of wolf and gray
and you can do that just by typing here
print line
and we have you can do this in two ways
to type colors
and you can type Dot
dot zip and you type here animals
and
if you run this
you'll see them in pairs so you're gonna
see Fox thread
bear brown and so on so you see here red
fox brown bear gray also the zip and the
zipping is used to create Pairs and the
pairs are at the same position in both
on both collections
or if you don't want to use this Z
function with parenthesis you can type
here colors zip and animals
and type here any models
now if you run this code you're going to
see the same output
now if you want to use a transformation
with the Z function you can type here
print line
you can type colors dot zip
and I'm going to use the parenthesis
animals
and animals and now I'm going to put
curly braces so the Lambda function here
I'm going to type
animal
for a let's put for scholar
and animal I'm gonna put the arrow sign
and here I'm gonna type day I'm gonna
but I'm gonna put first
quotation marks and quite the
and I'm gonna put dollar sign
and we're going to refer our animal uh
parameter that we defined here so we
type here there
animal
Dot and we call the replace first chart
function so type replace first chart and
as you can see this also has uh I think
along the
function and inside of this we type it
dot uppercase
uppercase and this is gonna uppercase
the first letter of the animal
uh
with the animal that is defined here and
I'm going to type yes
dollar sign
color
right now if you run this
you're gonna see the force and the f is
uppercase because it's uppercase by this
expression that we have here
it replaces and this it refers to the
animal uh an animal uh variable animal
variable that is defined here and it
refers to the first letter so it says
eat that uppercase so uppercase the
first letter
then uh then uh return that to the to
the animal uh any more variable and we
have the fox is red so I have the color
and then we have the bear is brown the
wolf is gray and all the animals start
the capital letter like we Define here
in this
in this expression
so this is the zip function so this is
how you can use the Z function to create
Pairs and also you can use the unzip
function to unzip a list of pairs so
first let's create a list of pairs so
I'm going to type Val
number pairs
equals
I'm gonna type list of
and here we're going to put
one
two
three
four
two
four now if you want to unzip those
pairs that we created you can just type
here print line
number pairs let's first display them as
pairs
and the necklace print line and so let's
type number pairs
dot unzip
now if you run this you're gonna see
them first in pairs and then you're
gonna see them unpaired because we use
here the anzi function so as you can see
here you have first one and you have one
two two three three four four so you
have in pairs first
and then we have them separated so we
have first one two three four
and then we have the numbers one two
three four so did you we unzip them we
separated them they're not pairs now
anymore with this unzip function this so
this is how you can use the NZ function
now it's time to look at the next
transformation that we can use and that
is Association now what is association
association Transformations allows you
to build maps from The Collection
elements and certain values associated
with them
and different Association types the
elements can be either keys or values in
the association map I'm going to see
what this means and the basic
Association function is the association
associated with which creates a mob on
which the elements of the original
collection are keys and the values are
produced from them by the given
transformation function so let's see an
example with uh with this so I'm going
to delete this code because
it will make a doubt but hard to
understand we could have so many things
here
and I'm going to type Val
numbers you know put equals
I'm gonna type really stuff
nanotype here
one
two
three
and four
now I'm going to type here print line
numbers and we are going to use the
association associate with the function
so we type associated with
and this is going to produce as I said
previously it's going to produce a map
in which the elements of the original
collection are keys so the keys of this
map are going to be those elements and
the
values are going to maybe are going to
be produced by what expression we Define
here inside the parenthesis so I'm going
to Define here
it so I'm going to type it
dot length
so now if you run this you're gonna see
the keys being one and then I'm gonna
see the value being the length of that
specific element so if you run this
we get the key one the value three the
key two the value three then you get
three the value is five then you get
four and the value is four so what has
happened now is that the associate with
function created the map in which the
elements the key the key are the
elements of the collections so those are
the keys inside our map and the values
of uh those uh with the association with
the associated with those keys are
produced by the expression that we
Define here by its dot length so
basically gonna use the length of that
specific element and it's going to be
the value so this is why I have one
three two three three five and so on now
for
building maps with collection elements
as values there is a function called
associate by it takes a function that
returns a key based on an element's
value and if two elements keys are equal
only that last one remains in the map so
let's look at this one so I'm going to
type here
print line
I'm going to put here numbers
so we type numbers
dot associate by
and now here going to define the
expression which is going to build the
key because now the the associate by
function is going to build a correlation
which the elements now are not Keys like
we had previously but they are values so
here in the expression need now to
Define how the key for those respective
values that we have here is going to be
created so we type here it
DOT first
dot uppercase
so this is what what is this is gonna do
it's gonna create a key
it's gonna use one let's say that we
have element one
and it's gonna take your element one
it's gonna take the first letter of the
element one and it's gonna uppercase it
and you're gonna have o and as the key
we're gonna have o and as the value
we're gonna have one and uh for the next
ones uh it will be the same so now if I
run this quad
foreign
elements are the values here so they are
the values previously The Collection
elements what the key is and the the
keys were builded by the expression that
we defined here by this so we have o and
we have t and we have four and we we
have uh t uh only one time and we don't
have two entry because uh you cannot
have duplicated keys in a map so this is
why you only have one only one t here
so uh
this is associated so this is
Association now associate by can also be
called with a value transformation
function and to do to do that you just
type here print line
numbers
that associate by
now we need to
apply a transformation now on the key
and on the value and how gonna how gonna
do that
we can type here actually let's delete
this because we don't need curly braces
we put parentheses and we type here key
and we have a suggestion key selector so
we're gonna apply the First
Transformation on the key so we type key
selector that named argument and we put
curly braces
and here we type it so the key DOT first
dot uppercase
so now what we're saying here apply this
transformation
for every key
in in in the map that is going to be
built so apply this transformation for
every key that is in the map that is
going to be built so we're saying to
uppercase uh to take the first letter
and uppercase it then we also need to
apply transformation for the value we
put
comma here at the end of our curly brace
and we type here
value
you also have a name argument you put
again curly braces
and here we're gonna type it dot length
so this is the transformation that is
going to be applied
to all the values in the map that is
going to be built so this is the
transformation so this is how all the
keys and the the in the map that is
going to be built are gonna be uh change
so the first letter is going to take
this thing is going to take the first
letter of the keys and it's going to
uppercase it
this will uh
we'll take the length of the the all the
values in the in the the in the in the
map that is going to be built and it's
gonna display the the length of that
element so if you run this
we get 0 3 T 5 F4 so we have the first
letter uppercase and then we have the
length three then we have t we have the
letter upper case and we have the value
five the length of that uh uh element
then we have F so we have a four and we
have the the the transformation apply on
that element on this element on on four
and we have the length and we have four
so this is how we can use transformation
Transformations with the associate by
function and the next we're going to
look at the next transformation fact
function and that is flattened now it's
time to look at the next transformation
function that you can use and that is
the flattened function but first let's
see why you'll need to use this
flattened function in the first place
so I'm gonna add the comment here called
flatten
and I'm going to create a variable here
so I'm going to die Val it's going to be
called numbers
sets and this is going to be a list with
list so I'm gonna type here
list of
and inside the list I'm gonna Pro I'm
gonna type set off so we have a list
inside the inside of our list
and I'm going to provide some values to
our set of like one two three
then another set of
four five and six
seven
eight and nine so
what we are having now is we have a list
within a list where the index of this
list is it's its own list so we have a
list of sets of ins
now if you want to Loop through this
list if you want to display the elements
in this list uh it is not that easy
because you will first need to Loop
because let's say that because what we
have here
is what is called a multi-dimensional
array so more specifically what we have
here is a two-dimensional array and at
the index 0 we have a list at the index
one we have another list and at the
index two we have another list
and to navigate to this list we need to
first get inside that list that is at
that other specific index to Loop to
that list and then we need to move to
the next index and to to look to that
list to that next list which is that
index
but now let's see first how we can
access one individual element from our
two-dimensional array so from our array
of arrays and to do that to type here
print line
gonna put numbers set
and if we we put square brackets and we
Define the index from uh which from
which list we want to access the element
and now I want to access the element
nine and the element 9 is stored at the
index two so we put two
and let's say that I want and I want to
access as I said the the element 9 now
to access the element line I need to go
within this list and use the index to
get the element I and element 9 is
stored at the index two so I'm going to
put square brackets two
but this for whatever reason doesn't
work with a list of sets and we need to
change this to array of
array of also those
also change it to array of
array of also array of an hour
everything will work fine
so array of
so if you run this so now we are
accessing the
index tool where the array is stored
where our number is stored and we get
the element two we get element nine so
now if I run this we're gonna see nine
autopilot in the console
so we get nine so this is how you can
access one individual element from our
multi-dimensional array so I'm going to
delete this I'm going to change it back
to
to a list of and to set off
so let's type a list of
set off
and set off
and now let's see how we can Loop
through this type to the dimensional
array and to do that to type here four
and type numbers I type specific numbers
because this is gonna as as you can see
um gonna hold on hold the numbers the
set of numbers four numbers in number
sets
so now you we are you we are getting the
as you can see here this is of type is
the the type set of ins so this uh
basically gets the element of the number
set index let's say zero and it gets the
first set and now we need to Loop
through that set so another four
number
in numbers so now we are looping
through the list through the set which
is inside the list of the index zero I
didn't zero
and you can add the print line to add to
do output that number I'm going to type
here number and also I'm gonna add the
space here so I'm gonna add the print
line here and I'm gonna type here four
or slash
n
now if you run this
as you can see you have on the output
one two three then we have a space four
five seven six then seven eight and nine
but uh we achieved this by using a loop
and then we use another loop so we have
a loop inside the loop we have a nested
Loop in order to get to the
to this uh two dimensional array because
as I said the in the index of this array
is its own list so it contains the list
now with the flattened uh with the
flattened function what you can do is
that we can convert this two-dimensional
array in one dimensional array so you
don't need to use this nested for Loops
in order to Loop through to them it will
return the nested the nested
uh is it to private it will provide
access to the nasty collection elements
without you needing to Loop through this
two-dimensional Ray it will it will
basically
take that two-dimensional array and it
will convert it in one dimensionally and
you will not need to create to have this
nested Loop inside you have to have this
Loop inside the loop in order to to
display the number so to do that to type
here uh Val
numbers let's say flatten
equals to
number sales so our our list to it list
that
flatten
now if you look at the type here now
this is a list of fins you no longer
have a list of sets of ins so this is a
very very uh informative because it
tells us that this now is just simply a
list of ins is not a list with the set
which is which is uh which itself is
also or a list of events so
this converts that two-dimensional array
in one dimensional array and because of
that now it's much easier to get one
element from our list because now our
list is not a two-dimensional array and
it's just one dimensional array so if I
type here print line
and the
let's say that I want to get the element
nine I'm going to type here uh
numbers flatten
square brackets and I'm going to type
here eight because it's stored at the
index 8. so now if I run this
so we get 9 here and as you can see this
is much easier than uh with the the two
that dimensional array so this is what
the flattening function is doing is
converting the
the two dimensional array or if a
multi-dimensional array in into one
dimensional array so now let's look how
we can Loop through our uh one dimension
array
so let's delete this
and if you want to to Loop through this
you just type 4
number
in
numbers flatten
and we either here a print line
number
and
let's comment this code
and if you run this code
now get the number displayed one after
another so get one two three four five
six seven nine and we got this because
our function our flattened function our
transformation function is transforming
it's converting our two-dimensional
array in one dimensional array so it's
easier for us to get the elements into
loop loop through them so this is what
the flatten function is doing and next
we're going to look at the
string representation and the functions
that you can use uh what we for the for
the string representation
I'm going to close the console
now it's time to start a discussion
about string representation so if you
need to retrieve the collection content
in a readable format you can use
functions that transform the collections
to Strings and there are two functions
to do that the join to string and the
join two The Joint to string build a
single string from the Collision
elements based on the provided arguments
the join 2 does the same but appends the
result of the given appendable object
and what that means is that it's gonna
add the text to the object on which that
function The Joint function is called
you're going to see an example with this
immediately
and now I'm going to create a variable
called numbers while numbers
I'm going to put equals I'm going to
call it actually numbers strings
equal
and I'm gonna type here list off
and I'm gonna put here
the text one
two
three
and four
now if you want to retrieve the
this if you want to get the string
representation of this list
if you just type here print line
and type you put your numbers strings
and if you run this
we get one two three and four but this I
I think is calling the two string
function it's not because we're not
using the joint to string function and I
don't like those
square brackets I want them to be
separated by comma with spaces to get
the to get data just type here
print line
so let's
put here print line
and to type numbers to string
Dot
joint to string
and uh we don't we delete this and put
parenthesis
now you throw on this
you'll see now the single presentation
of our list they are going to be
separated by comma when we do is going
to have a it's going to have
spaces now let's look at the Joint 2
function and for that
I'm gonna Define another list down here
so I'm going to type here let's press
Ctrl alt for model code
so I'm going to type here uh
Val
is going to be called list string
and now I'm going to use something
called
a string buffer and this is like the
string type is a little bit different
but it's gonna allow us to do
is going to allow us to present how the
joint function over so string buffer and
we put parenthesis and here we Define
our text and we're gonna type the list
of numbers I'm going to put colon so the
type here the list
of numbers
colon
now to use the join 2 function just type
here another print line
we we type number string
number strings dot join tool
and as you can see this receives a
buffer and this is the buffer that we
have created here so I'm gonna
press enter and we're going to type I'm
gonna give us the argument the listing
that we created
and what is this this is gonna do is
gonna append this text that we have here
in front of all of our elements that we
have in our list number strings so now
if you run the squad
as you can see it added the text the
list of numbers that we have here to our
number strings in front so we have the
list of numbers one two three and four
now
if you want to build the
custom string representation you can
specify its parameters in a function
arguments which are the separator prefix
and postfix and the result will start
with the prefix and end with the with
the postfix and the separator will come
will come after each element except the
last so let's see how we can do that
so
um I'm gonna use
I'm going to use the number numbers to
string so I'm going to type here print
line
numbers to string
and we type join
join to string and we select this one
with the you select this one with the
which with the separator parameter
and the type is separator so now we
Define the what is going to be the S the
separator here and we're gonna put
quotation marks
and we're going to put
this so this is going to be our
separator between our elements next
we're going to define the prefix so we
put we put here
comma type prefix and now I'm going to
put the prefix and the prefix is going
to be the text start and colon so I put
quotation marks start
and colon
and we also need to provide the post fix
and to do that we put another comma here
so those are named the arguments which
are
defined in this files and join the
string so we type here
postfix
and we put
colon
and
now if you run this you're going to see
them separated by this separator that we
Define here is going to have the prefix
start and it's going to have at the end
this post fix which is comma and N so
now if you run this quad
as you can see we have start and we have
one then it's separated by the sign that
we defined here then we have 2 3 4 and
we have the end so we have our post fix
that had defined here now
for bigger Coalition you may want to
specify
limit so a number of elements that will
be included into the result and if the
collection exists that size with that
limit all the other elements will be
replaced with a single value called the
truncated argument so let's see what all
of this means so let's say that I have a
list called the
numbers let's type here Val numbers and
I'm going to create a range from one
to 100 so what we have here is 100
numbers
and let's say that I type here print
line
but first let's convert this to a list
so I'm going to put this in parentheses
so you put this in parenthesis
and you put at the end that to list
and this is going to convert now our
range into a list and as you can see the
the type is a list of ins and now if I
type here numbers
and if I run this code
when I get all of our numbers displayed
now with as I said with the join join
tostring function we can specify a limit
and also a truncated this is going to be
the thing which is going to be sold out
after our number limits so what I can
type here is I can type join to string
and uh which is also
one with parenthesis so hero type limit
the named argument limit and let's say
that I don't want to get all the numbers
as you can see here from to 100 and I
want to get only the first 15 elements
to do this you just type here limit 15.
then we type truncated and that is going
to be that this trunky thing is going to
be showed after our limit number so I'm
gonna put here uh quotation marks
less than um sine dot dot and uh
greater than PSI so now if you run this
look at what we have in the output
now we get we only have the first 15
elements and then for the next elements
we only have this uh
string that we typed here this is this
expression that we have here and we can
change this if you can change this let's
say to 25 so if you run this now you'll
see only the first 25 elements displays
foreign
to string with the limit name argument
and the truncated now let's say that you
want to customize the representation of
elements of the elements themselves you
need to in that case you need to provide
the transform function so what we can do
is that we can type here print line
let's say
and I'm going to type number strings
put dot join to string and choose this
one with curly braces
and here I'm gonna Define how this uh
this uh
list is going to be transform so how's
going to be changed so I'm going to type
here
quotation marks element
and I'm gonna put
colon
we're going to put the dollar sign
and put it
dot uppercase so we're gonna uppercase
all the elements
so if I run the code now
get element and get one
so you can get one uppercase an element
to get two uppercase element three
uppercase element four uppercase so this
is how you can use the transformation uh
we can this I can transform your list we
using the joint to string function
so this is our discussion about the
string representation and now I'm going
to move to the next sections so I'm
gonna end the video now now it's time to
start a discussion about filtering so
what is filtering filtering is one of
the most popular tasks in collection
processing in kotlin filtering
conditions are defined by predicates and
that is Lambda function that take a
collection element and return a Boolean
value true means that the given element
matches the predicate false means the
opposite
the standard Library contains a group of
extension functions that lets you filter
collection in a single call those
functions leave the original collection
unchanged so they are available for both
multiple and read-only collections to
operate the filtering result you should
assign it to a variable or change the
function after filtering
now the basic filtering function is
filter when called with a predicate
filter Returns the collection elements
that match it for both list and set the
resulting Collision is a list for map
it's a map as well
now let's Define a variable here call
number so let's type in val numbers I'm
going to put equals to list of
and I'm gonna type here
one
two
three
and four
now if you want to filter this list what
you need to do is let's create another
variable here called
longer
then
three
I'm going to put equals I'm going to
type numbers
Dot and we type filter
so filter
and we choose this one
and here we defined how our list so we
will Define the expression which is
gonna determine how our list is going to
be is gonna be filtered so I'm gonna
type here it so the element dot length
let's say greater than
3.
now if we I add the print line down here
print line
now this list is going to contain all
the elements from our numbers list which
are longer than three so if I put here
longer than three and if I run this
we get 3 and 4 because those are the
only string numbers which have a length
longer than three so I'm going to close
the console next let's see how we can
filter them up and for that I'm going to
create another variable called numbers
map
foreign
here the key is going to be a string key
one
the value is going to be one
comma then
key to
to
then
key three
two three
and now I'm gonna put key 101
two
101 the value
now if you want to filter now this map
I'm going to create another variable
called filtered
mop and it's going to be equal to our
numbers map but it's going to be filter
so I'm going to type DOT number snap
that filter
and now I'm going to filter filter the
map both by the key and by the value so
we type here it dot key
dot ends with so we we want to filter it
first by the key and the one that key to
ends with a specific character and that
character is going to be one
and so we put the operator and we want
the the value to be greater than 100 so
we put here it
dot value
greater than 100 and the only key which
satisfy this condition that we find here
it's only is this key so now if I add
the print line here
and if I type filter map so the map
which was filtered using the expression
that we defined here
now if you run this you're gonna see
gonna see
this in the output because this is the
only one which satisfy the condition so
you get key 101 and we get the value 101
so this is how you can filter them up
using the both the key and the value now
the predicates in filter can only check
the values of the elements if you want
to use element position in the filter
use filter indexed it takes a predicate
with two arguments the index and the
value of an element
to filter correction by a negative
condition use filter not it's written as
a list of the elements for which the
predicate yields false so let's see how
we can do this so I'm gonna declare two
variables down here
file
filtered
index
is going to be equal to numbers
or a variable that is defined above
that
filter index
and this is gonna take
two parameters index and the value so
I'm going to type here
actually you need to put curly braces
index
let's change this to value
actually let's keep it as s
Ctrl Z
and
here we're gonna Define
our expression by a by which our list is
going to be filtered so I'm going to
type here that first I want the
index
to not be equal to zero
and
I I also want
that
the value of the element so actually
let's change this to valid to make more
sense so let's type here to value
because we're talking about those ones
so I want the value of that string so
the value dot length I want I want it to
be less than a 5.
all right so this is the transformation
if you want this is not a transformation
this is how we want to filter our
numbers list that we defined above I
want to
filter both by the index so this is why
we use the filter index and also by the
value
and I want the index to not be equal to
zero this is the first condition for the
filtering and I also want so use the end
operator that the valued of the element
the length to be less than five now if I
print this if I added here a print line
but first let's Also let's also use the
uh filter not so I'm going to type here
Val
foreign
filtered nut
and I'm going to type equals numbers
dot filter not
curly braces
and we type here it dot
length
so the value of the element
is to be less than equal to 3.
now if we output those two in the
console so if I add here print line and
I'm going to Output filter
Index this should be filtered in the
solicit Factor this
so let's type here in the index
I type it already
so let's type here
edex actually
it will make more sense
but I have Elixir so why anyway so I'm
gonna output that first then I'm gonna
hear a print line
and I'm gonna type filtered not
and filter not as I said is gonna return
a list of the elements for which the
predicate yields false
now if you run those two look what
you're gonna have on the output
so this is the output for our first for
this print line and for this print line
so let's think about what we have here
first we have two and four
and we Define the filter here first the
index which should not be equal to zero
so the one is first excluded and we also
want to that to the value that length to
be less than five so the only ones which
uh for which the value is less than five
is the 2 and 4 because the length of the
three is bigger than 5 because it has a
length of 0 1 2 3
4 and
the length is 5 but I want the length to
be less than five not less than equal
than five so this is why this is not
included and you only have two and four
next
uh now use the filter nut and it's gonna
as I said it's gonna return a list of
elements for which the predicate for
each this expression is gonna yield
false so it's gonna go through all of
our elements and it's gonna return the
elements for which this is false so we
get three
N4 because those are the only ones which
are not less than equal to three they
are greater than equal to three so this
is why we have here three and four
because this returns if Returns the
elements if the uh the the length of the
element is less than equal to 3 so this
is why you get here 3 and 4.
and
there are also functions that narrow the
element type by filtering elements of a
given type so there is a function called
filter is instance which returns a
collection of filaments of a given type
being called so let's see how you can
use that but first let's create a
Val mixed
let's call it mixed
list
I'm gonna put equals another card type
list off
and I'm gonna Define some mixed elements
here so I'm going to type here let's say
one
two three then some charts like
a
B
C
now so on strings let's type here
hello
World another string
Alex and let's also type
a Boolean so let's type here let's say
false
now there is a function as I said which
which Narrows the element type by
filtering the elements of a given type
so we can use this function called
filter is instance so what you can do
here is we can we can type
mixed list
Dot
filter
is instance
so we choose I think this one not this
one
filter is instance
of Y so mixture is that
filter
is instance
and here with inside the angle brackets
we Define the generic type for which
this list is going to be filtered so
let's first choose the chart Char then
I'm going to put that for each so I'm
going to use the for each Loop
and I'm gonna add print line
and I'm going to type it here so I'm
going to type the parameter
which is the each chart so now if I run
this we will get only the charts being
displayed here because it is filtering
by using the instance of charge so you
get the charge if I change this to
to in now I'll get the integers from our
mixed list so if I run this
now get the integers one two three that
we have defined here
and if I change this to let's say a
string I will get the strings inside our
mixed list because filter is instance
it's gonna take the specific title that
you type here and then it's gonna Loop
through all of those types which are of
this type in this list so if I run this
I'm gonna see Hello World Analytics
so we get hello world and Alex also I
can filter for Boolean values if I type
here Boolean is gonna
it's gonna output in the closet or the
one Boolean value that we have here
which is false so if I run this
I get false so this is how you can use
the filter is instant function on types
to filter the mixed list and you can
also put that because this Returns the
list this entire thing a filter at least
you can put that for each to call the
the this the for this for each Lambda
function and then we output them in the
console
uh the next thing that you can look and
that we're gonna look at is called
Partition so I'm going to add a comment
here but I'm going to hide the console
first so I'm going to put here a comment
I'm going to type here partition part
T1 so partition
and this is an alter another filtering
function called Partition and it filters
a collection by a predicate and it keeps
the elements that don't match in a
separate list
so you have a pair of lists as a return
value the first list is containing the
element that match the predicate the
predicate and the second one is
containing everything else from the
original collection so I'm gonna take
again our numbers that have defined the
path so I'm going to type here
uh
file and to to get this partition we put
we put parentheses and here to type
match so this is going to be the values
which are going to be
matched by the predicate and
I'm gonna type here rest and you're
gonna be stored the rest of the value
which which don't match the expression
the predicate that's going to be defined
and I put here equals
numbers
dot partition
and we type here it
Dot
length
greater
than 3.
now if I
other print line here
I can print first the match
let's press Ctrl D and now I can print
the rest of the elements which don't
match this this condition this
expression that is defined here so if I
run this code
you will see first all the elements
which are greater than 3 and then we're
gonna see the rest of the elements which
are not greater than 3. but let's add
the space here to make things more
clearly so we're going to add a hero
print line
quotation marks for recession so let's
run this again
so we get three and four so those are
the elements which are coming from our
match list which is defined here uh
which is uh which satisfy this condition
which is greater than 3 so we have three
and four so the length is greater than
three
and then we have one and two so those
are the rest of the elements which are
not satisfying this condition that is
defined here so we have one and two so
this is how you can use the partition
function to
to get the
basically to get a pair in which the
return of value the first is the first
is the list containing the elements that
match the predicate and the same code is
the one containing everything else from
the original collection
so this is how you can use the the
partition function so
now I'm gonna end the video and see you
in the next video now it's time to look
at testing predicates and those are
functions that simply test the predicate
against the collection elements and we
have three functions any
which returns true if at least one of
the element matches the given predicate
then we have none which returns true if
none of the elements match the given
predicate and then we have all which
returns true if all of the elements
match the given predicate so let's test
all of them so I'm gonna type here print
line
numbers
that let's start with any so we put any
so here we type it dot ends
with
and let's put let's say
e
then out of another print line
numbers
dot none
it should be
curly braces
eat
Dot and sweet
let's say w
and print line
numbers
dot all
let's say it dot length
so if if the length of all the elements
is greater than one
so now if you run this
all of those gonna return either true or
false
so get true true and true this is
because first testing any and then this
returns true with at least one of the
elements much in the given predicate so
it is true we have
two elements which ends with the E we
have three and one so that's why you
return true there
then we check to see if uh none of the
elements ends with W so we're checking
to see if none of the elements uh in our
numbers ends with w n is true not only
for elements will end through double so
we have two in the output
then we check numbers.org so we check
into if all the elements the line the
length of all the elements the element
strings that we have here one two and
three are greater than one and this row
all of them are greater than one so this
one have true true intro
so this is how you can use the test
predicates uh on your collections
first time to look at the plus and minus
operators so in Catherine plus and minus
operators are defined for collections
they take a collection as the first
operand and the second operand can be
either an element or another collection
the return value is a new read-only
collection and let's look at an example
on this I'm going to type here Val
numbers
you want to put equals two so now I'm
going to type your Multiple List off
Multiple List at least with we to which
you can add and remove elements and I'm
gonna type here
one
two
three
and four now if you want to add an
element to this list you need to type
here numbers dot add
and here you need to specify let's say
five and now this new element is going
to be added to the list but with the
plus and minus operator you can do we
can do this in an another way so you can
type here
uh
but I'm gonna put this in another list
so you can type here Val
plus list
so we put equals to and type numbers
Plus
and to type five and now this element is
going to be added to our list that we
have here it's going to be added to the
the string five and it's going to be
stored in this plus list now let's look
at the minus operator here Val I'm going
to call this minus list
and put equals 2 and I'm going to type
numbers so now I'm going to use the
minus operator so I put minus
and we type minus
multiple list of
and we put here
let's say three and four so we type here
three
and four
I have an underline let's see what it
says
now anyway let's run our code to see
what to get in the output
but we need to add some print lines
together so
I'm gonna add here a print line
plus list
and another print line
minus list now if I run this again
we get one two three four and our
Five Element added to our numbers list
from our class list which is outputted
here
and then we get 1 and 2 because 3 and 4
were removed using the minus operator so
this is how you can use the minus and
plus operators with the collections
so this is our discussion about the plus
and minus operators and I'm going to
look at we're gonna
uh
move to the next section so I'm going to
close the console and I'm going to end
the video
now it's time to start a discussion
about grouping so the kotlin standard
Library provides extension functions for
grouping collection elements the basic
function Group by takes a Lambda
function and returns them up in this map
each key is the Lambda result so the
result of that expression inside the
Lambda function
and the corresponding values is the list
of filaments on which this result is
returned this function can be used for
example to group a list of strings by
the first letter
you can also call Group by with a second
Lambda argument a value transformation
function in the result map of group y
with two lambdas the key is produced by
key produced by key selector function
are mapped to the result of the value
transformation function instead of the
original elements
so let's see what all of this means by
looking at an example so if I type here
Val
numbers
and I'm going to put
list of
again one
two
three
four
and five
now we I can add here a print line
I can type numbers
and I can type here dot Group by
and I'm gonna group it by
it dot first so the first letter in in
one of our elements that
uppercase
and now we're going to look at the next
the next Group by with the key selector
and with the transformation function so
I'm going to type here print line
numbers Dot
group y
so we have this one key selector so you
type here key selector
equals
and here we put
curly braces and we type eat that first
so the first letter in our element so
first it should be here
we put a comma
and we type value so the how the value
of the the value of this list is going
to are going to be transformed and here
we also put curly braces and we put it
that uppercase so put it curly braces it
should be
it dot uppercase
let's press Ctrl alt L to format code
and now let's run our code to see what
we get in the output
so we get
for the first one number the numbers are
grouped by for uh and we have this
Lambda it that first.apper case it takes
the first letter in Upper cases so it
gets whoa whoa so then you get one
we get T we get to we get F we get four
we get uh then we use this one which on
which we we uh you we we group uh
elements with a second Lambda argument
with the value transformation function
and the result uh map of group y with
two lambdas are the keys produced by the
key selector and the function are the
function are mapped to the result of the
value transformation function so the
results are mapped to this
transformation that is defined here so
this this is what creates the keys this
is what creates the key this uh Lambda
function and this is what creates the
the the the the values so we get all
because you get in that first so the
first letter and get one because this is
the value so the value is uppercased we
get one so we get one here then we get
again eat that first for the for all men
so you get T then you get two and I get
uppercased and get F lowercase f and get
four and uh and five
so this is our discussion about grouping
and uh my suggestion for you is to play
with the code try different values for
the key selector for the value transform
for uh try to group The Elements by
different expressions and just play with
the code until you get uh get uh until
you get comfortable with the code now
it's time to start a discussion about
the driven collection parts and the
quoting standard Library contest
accession functions for retrieving parts
of a collection
these functions provide a variety of
ways to select elements for the result
collection listing their position
explicitly specifying the result size
and others I'm going to start with the
first function called slice
which Returns the list of collection
elements with given integers the indices
may be based either as a range or as a
collection of integer values so I'm
gonna create first domain function
I'm going to type Val numbers I'm going
to create a list of
and I'm going to type here one
to
three
four
five
and six
now to use the slice function we simply
add here a print line
and we'll type your numbers
dot slice
and we create here arrange so we type 1
dot dot
and next we're going to add another
print line and I'm going to type numbers
dot slice
and I'm going to put here now zero dot
dot
four
and
I'm gonna type step
two
foreign
list so slice here
slice
and I'm gonna add another print line
here
numbers
dot slice
and I'm gonna add now a set here so I'm
going to type set off
and I'm gonna type
three
five
and zero so let's press Ctrl R till the
format the code
now if you run this code look at the
output
so you first get the first three
elements we get to
two three and four because uh we're
starting from the index one so we get
two three and four
then we get from 0 to 4 so you get one
but you don't get the two because you
have this step two which steps the
second element and then we have three
and five because it's stepping for the
four so this is what step two is doing
here
and next we have numbers slice and get
four
six and uh one but we get them as the
string representation we don't get them
as
as a integers so
all right
now
let's look at the next functions and
those are the take and drop
and to get the specified numbers of
elements starting from the first you can
use the take function for getting the
last elements use the take last when
call when when called with a number
larger than the collection size both
functions return the whole collection to
take all the elements except a given
number of first or last elements called
the drop or the and the drop loss
function respectively
so I'm gonna
add some print lines here I'm gonna add
print line
and I'm going to type numbers
dot take
three
Another Printer line
numbers
dot take last
hmm
also three then another print line
numbers
Dot
drop
one
and another print line
numbers
dot drop last
five now if you run this code
look what you get in the output
but let's add a space here so on another
print line
quotation marks photosyn now let's run
this code again
so we get uh
for you get numbers take three and this
function basically takes only three
um
three elements from our list
then numbers take last three is gonna
take the last three elements from hourly
so I have four five and six
then we have a print print line numbers
drop one so you have two three four five
and six and the first element is dropped
so this this is what this function is
doing
next we have numbers dot drop plus five
and this function is basically dropping
all the uh file the last five elements
and you have only the one so this is
what those functions are doing
you can also use predicates to define
the number of elements for taking or
dropping and there are four functions
similar to the ones described above
and those are take while take last while
drop while and drop drop last while and
let's look at all of them but I'm gonna
put a space between uh
our code that we have here so I'm gonna
have the print line here
quotation marks photo session
print line
so I'm going to type here numbers
dot take
while
and here we Define the predicate I'm
going to type
not
eat dot starts
with
f
in quotation marks
now another print line
numbers
dot take
last
while
and we Define here the predicate it
not equal to 3. not equal
two three
another print line
we type numbers
dot drop while
and we Define the expression the
predicate which is going to be applied
for our drop last while
so it should be
drop while here
and type it
dot length
equals equals to 3.
and what another print line
numbers
Dot
drop last while
and we type here it contains
it dot
contains
quotation marks I
no
if you run this code
we first get one
two and three so because here we check
in we're uh because using the logical
not operated we want all the elements
which don't start with f so we don't
have four and a five we have only one
two and three
next we have
numbers that take last while and we
Define the expression for which is going
to be
returned the elements by it not equal to
three so you only have four
five and six and uh the the the three
the three is is missing and we don't
have one because take last value only
takes the uh last elements so this is
why we have only
and six when you don't have three so it
doesn't care about the first element or
uh about uh the second element
next we have numbers drop while eat that
length equals to 3 and here we have
we have
so it at the lines equals to three and
three four five and six so
this condition is satisfied so it
basically it drops all the elements
which are equal to three so we have
three four five and six and all of those
are bigger than three and the ones which
are equal to three respectively one
uh uh two and uh let's see and six
actually six is appearing here
so
one
two
I don't know why six supreme but this
basically saying that it should drop
while if that length equals uh to three
so it basically drops all the elements
which are equal to with the length three
so we have this is what we have here um
three four
five and six six should not be but I
don't know why it's here now
the next that we have here is numbers
dropped last while so again this is uh
Focus specifically about the last
element so it contains I so get uh
uh one two three and four so because
this drop last while is basically
basically dropping all the elements all
the last Elements which contain uh which
contains I so we have
six five
so we have a
drop last while so we have it that
contains I
so it drops all the elements which
contains I so sorry for what I said
previously so this way I have here one
two three and four and uh the five and
the six are missing because it basically
drops the old Elements which contains
the letter i so this is how you can use
the take and drop the next function that
you can use is called chunked
and
if you want to break a collection
through parts of a given size then you
can use the chunked function chunks take
a single argument the size of the chunk
and Returns the list of
[Music]
list of the given size the first chunk
starts from the first element and
contains the size of the elements and
the second chunk holds the next size
elements and so on the last chunk maybe
may have a similar size so if I have
here let's change this to numbers
strings and let's type here
Val
numbers
while I was changing that I should use
refactor so
let's use a refactor
rename
numbers strings so it will be changed in
all the places we're using that
and here have numbers and I'm gonna put
equals and I'll put parentheses
zero dot dot 13. and I'm gonna put that
to list to convert this to a list
and we add a print line to see how this
chunk function is working so we got the
print right let's close the console
and we type here numbers Dot
Dot chunked
and would put three so it's gonna chunk
our elements into three into
um
basically elements of three so we have
zero one two three four five six seven
eight and they're both on on chunks of
three elements so this is what this
chunks is doing
so this is why I have here this result
and
the next function that you're going to
look at is called windowed and
and we we can also use a transformation
on our chunked element so I cannot hear
a print line
we type numbers
Dot chunked
chunked which we also choose the size
three
then you put curly braces and here I'm
gonna Define how our chunked elements
are going to be transformed so we put it
dot
sum so it's going to sum the chunked
elements so if I press Ctrl I'll tell
the format the code and now if I run
this look what we're going to see in the
output
so we get uh you get first the chunked
elements here
in entry in three elements and then we
have our chunked elements but they are
summed up so we have first three because
zero plus one plus two is three then we
have three four five because that is
twelve don't have seven eight uh seven
uh
six seven eight and they have twenty one
then we have
uh 10 11 and 9 and we have 30 and so on
so this is uh how uh you can use the
chunked function to chunk the elements
together by a given size and you can
also use the transformation function to
do a transformation on them like adding
them so as you can see we have adding
them here
next we're going to look at the next
function function that you can use and
that is called the windowed function and
we can retrieve all possible ranges of
the collection elements of a given size
with the window function the function of
getting them is called windowed it
returns a list of element ranges that
you would see if you are looking at the
collation through a slightly wind off of
the given size unlike chunked window
returns element ranges Windows starting
from each collection element all the all
the windows are returned as an element
of a single list so if I have here
the
let's create another
variable here let's call it
Val numbers
string
two
and we're gonna type here let's say
or I can assign
I can assign the number of strings here
so I'm going to type here number strings
now what I can do here I I can add a
print line
and like I can type numbers string store
Dot
windowed and we choose let's say three
and let's see what we have on the output
so now if you run this code
I should have added here a space so
let's add the print line here
backslash
photo selection
foreign
so we have one two three then we have
two three four you have three four five
and four five six so this is similar to
junk but window provides more
flexibility because uh you can
specify a step which defines a distance
between the first element and and to a
DH and windows by default the value is
one so the result contains Windows
starting from all elements if you
increase the step to two you'll receive
only Windows 30 from the other element
first third and so on and finally you
can apply transformation to the return
ranges right away to do this you provide
the transformation as a Lambda function
when calling windows so it is similar to
chunked
and um
so with this I think we end our
discussion about the thieving collection
parts and see you in the next video and
if you find this confusing don't worry
because it's so confusing for uh for me
for me and for probably other people
because it takes time to to get used to
this and my suggestion for you just play
with the code change the the parameters
play with the functions try different uh
values and so on so see you in the next
video
now we're going to look at some
functions with which you can retrieve
single elements from our Collections and
the first one is one which retrieves an
element by its position so I'm gonna
create the Val numbers again
numbers equals to
list of
and
we type here
one
two
three
and four and also five
and let's say that I want to get the
element at position three to do that
just add here a print line and we type
numbers
dot element
and here you specify the position three
so zero one two three so we're going to
get four outputted in the console
so we get in the output as expected for
now there are there are also two
functions for retrieving the first and
last element and to do that just add
another print line here
and type numbers that first
so this is gonna retrieve the first
element and Ctrl d
numbers Dot
last so
this is gonna receive the first element
one and last is gonna retrieve the last
element five so if you run this
we get first four from our
disappearance line then we get first one
and again the last five
and we can also edit three
elements by condition so I can type here
uh I can type down here or
or I will type it here
actually I'm going to type it down here
it's going to add here a print line
numbers let's say
DOT first now I'm going to retrieve by a
condition so once I first I'm going to
choose this one with curly braces and
the condition is that I want to leave
the first element for which the length
is greater than 3 so I'm going to type
here it dot length
greater than 3. and I'm gonna add I'm
gonna press Ctrl D because I'm gonna do
the same thing for the
by condition so I'm going to type here
numbers that last but I'm gonna change
the condition I'm gonna change it to
eat that starts with the it that starts
with
the letter f
so now we're retrieving the first
element which is greater than three and
next retrieving the last element which
starts with the letter f
so now if you run this
we get 3 and 5 because 3 is the first
element which is has a length greater
than three and can get five because this
is the one the last element which starts
with the letter F and if you can other
space here if you want to make things
more clear so we're gonna add the print
line quotation marks
backslashing
actually
forward selection
so if you run this
we get three and five output today in
the console
and we can also retrieve a random
element from our numbers so I can type
here print line
numbers
dot random and this is going to return a
random number from our list of numbers
so if I run this
we get one and if I run this again
get four so every time you run this
you'll get a random number
and you can also check if the list is
empty so you can type here print line
numbers
that is empty then that is going to
return true if the list is empty and if
the list is not empty it's going to
return false so if you run this
we get false so this is our discussion
about how to retrieve single elements
see in the next video now it's time to
start a discussion about aggregate
operations so kotlin collections
contains functions for commonly used
aggregate operations
and those are operations that return a
single value based on the collection
content most of them are well known and
work in the same way as they do in other
programming languages
and we have minor null and Max ornal
which return the smallest and the
largest element respectively and on
empty collections the return null then
we have average which Returns the
average value of elements in the
collection then we have sum which
Returns the sum of elements in the
collection of numbers
and have count which Returns the number
of elements in our collections so please
declare a list numbers
list of
let's put so let's put some numbers here
like let's say six
then
let's say
now let's press Ctrl format the code and
let's add the print line here let's put
quotation marks and let's type the sum
is
dollar sign
and the type here numbers
dot sum
numbers
that's sum
all right and uh
I'll add another print line and now this
is gonna say
the
count is
again dollar sign
numbers
dot count
another print line
the average
is
again dollar sign
numbers that average
another print line
and now I'm going to say the
max value is
again dollar sign numbers
dot marks
numbers Dot
marks
or null
and I'll print line
the mean value is
dollar sign numbers that mean
or null
now if you run this code you're gonna
see in the output the corresponding
values for those expressions that we
have here so again the sum is 134 the
count is 5 because we have five elements
here the average is 26.28 the maximum
value is 100 and the minimum value is 4.
so this is how you can use those
aggregate operations and agree and those
aggregate um
functions and beside the regular sum
there is an advantage so much summation
function called sum of that takes a
selected function and Returns the sum
sum of its application to all collection
elements and let me show you how this
works so you just type here
so we type here print line
the sum is
dollar sign
numbers
dot sum of
we select this one
and here we type it
times two
now if you run this what it's going to
do is it's gonna sum all the numbers
like the first function that we have
here so it's going to sum 134 and it's
multi is going to multiply that that
number by two so if you run this
we get 260 which is 132 times
134 times 2. so this is how you can use
the sum off with this uh
transformation which is gonna basically
multiply the list with a number with the
with the sum of the list with the number
so this is our discussion about
aggregate operations and see you in the
next video now it's time to start a
discussion about ordering and in this
video we're going to look at comparable
and add comparator interfaces
so first I'm going to create a list of
numbers
and
I'm not gonna
I'm gonna get a multiple list so
Multiple List off and I'm gonna
Define some numbers here not in a
specific order
so we type two let's say five
one
let's say
40.
20.
100 let's say
60. now what if I want to
order the numbers that I have inside our
list numbers to do that you just need
you type numbers
Dot
and there is a function called sorted so
if I type number that's sorted now our
number on our numbers are going to be
sorted so if you type here for each
put in the line
it
so now if you run this
even though we didn't type our numbers
in ascending order there will be sorted
and as you can see they are sorted we
have one two
five twenty forty six three and one
hundred so they are sorted by this
function called sorted and why this is
working
it's working because if you click on
this sorted function
what a
actually if you type here let's say
let's say that I put the type here
and
if I click on the type
this tie this type integer this class is
implementing this thing called
comparable and this comparable has a
function called compare to so when we
actually type numbers that are sorted
what what internally was happening is
that the integer class was using the
compared to function which is which is a
function which you want to you need to
implement if you implement the
comparable interface to compare if
to compare our numbers and to based on
that to to sub them to to sort them
and now let's say that I have or let's
say that I have a data class
called laptop
and it's gonna have a
variable called brand it's going to be
of type string
another variable called here this could
be the the year one one this specific
version was released on int
also need
and the wall
let's say um
price also an integer
right now if I create here a list of
laptops laptops
equals to Multiple List of
and I type here laptop
let's say that I type here Dell
and I put the year let's say 2021
the ram let's say that is four gigabytes
RAM and the price will say that is
600 okay
comma I'm going to create another laptop
here
so another object I'm gonna type here
let's call it
Acer
is going to be let's say the year um
let's put 20
20.
the para is let's say the ram let's say
that is eight gigabytes Ram
and the prices say that it's 100 dollars
comma and let's create another laptop
object so we type laptop
and create an Apple laptop which is
which you're gonna for which you're
gonna choose the
the year let's say
um
Tony
and
for the ram let's say they're choose 16
gigabytes RAM and 1 000 for the price
now if I type here laptops
that sorted let's say that I want to
sort the laptops as if you can see while
on time pink the IntelliJ is not giving
me any hints to have this function
sorted
as a true fill in that function because
that function is not working on our
laptops list and why why is happening
that
that is happening because the IntelliJ
doesn't know
how we want to sort this laptop list
that we have here because you want you
can sort it in many ways you can sort it
by the name you can sort it by the year
you can sort it by Dynamic and sort it
by the price so when you say laptops are
sorted the IntelliJ is not it's not
annoying
what do you mean because previously it
was working with our integers or and
without integer class because the
integer class if you type if you put the
type here
back integer
the integer class or the int class what
I was doing actually it was inheriting
from this comparable interface and it
was implementing the compared to
function which is used when you call the
sorted function and inside this
comparative function it has defined its
own Logic for comparing integers for
comparing whole numbers and what we need
to do in order to be able to
sort our list of laptops is we need to
implement the comparable interface and
you need to Define our own logic which
is going to determine
how our list is going to be awarded by
by which uh property by the Year by the
ram by the price so this is what you
need to do and to do that just put here
a colon and we'll implement the
interface comparable so we type it
comparable and we have a suggestion you
should choose this one
we put angle brackets and here we type
laptop because you want to implement
this we want to compare laptops so
laptops so this swipe water level there
then you put curly braces and now we
need to implement the function so click
on that it says Implement members you
have the compare to function now
you don't need to Define our logic which
is gonna determine what makes uh uh zero
the final logic which is going to
determine how our elements is going to
be watered by what criteria and I'm
gonna order the the laptops first by the
price and to do that to do that just
type if and to type this and we type in
this because this is going to be called
on an inst an instance of our laptop
left of class is going to call the
compared to function and it's going to
compare with another argument so if this
dot price we say here
is greater than other
that price
we we return as positive number so we
type return one and a positive Value
Plus simply shows that the receiver
object so the objects
this object is greater than the the uh
the object which was passed so this is
what this means this one else lcf is the
receiver object is not so if this dot
price is less than other that price
let's say then gonna return
-1 a negative number so I'm going to put
here minus one and what this basically
logic is I'm just going to swap them so
it's going to swap the elements based on
this logic else I'm going to return 0
and that is going to mean that they are
equal so if you type here return 0. and
if you click here it says that you can
write this in a different way so if you
click on this
and let's add the print line to see that
our if if uh are called so if I type
here print line
I'm gonna say
in if statement
dollar sign
actually let's type swapping
this dot brand name
with
dollar sign
other
dot brand
so let's add this print line also in our
lcf
and I'm not gonna add in inside the ears
because our we don't have Elements which
are equal but
you can add that if you want now if I
type laptops that's sorted now I have a
suggestion and if I type for each
print line it so print the element
now if you run this look you're gonna
see the elements sorted and uh ascending
order by their uh their price so you see
that we have first the brand the brand
name Dell and we have price 600 then we
have
the price uh you have laptop Acer and we
have eight hundred dollars and have left
to apoll the brand and you have the
price one thousand dollars so the
nearest so now they are sorted using our
own logic which was defined inside this
comparable interface and which was
defined inside the which was defined by
this comparable interface and which was
defined inside this function compared to
that we've overrided inside our client
and as you can see
if uh you look you see here that he says
if an if statement swapping Acer window
so the elements are swapped based on our
road in if statements it says swapping
apple with Acer so they are they are
swapped based on our logic
so this is how you can use the
comparable uh interface but what if I
want now to compare by the
let's say uh RAM what can I do I can't
implement the comparable interface again
here and I can't uh
I I can I can add the that property here
but that is gonna conflict with my logic
with for the price so what can we do and
here comes into action comparator
with comparator you can compare your uh
your list you can you can uh com you can
order actually I should say you can sort
your list using multiple properties so
you can order it by the uh brand name
you can order by the year we can already
buy the ram you can already buy the
price and with compare because with the
comparable interface
we can do that just only by one property
and that is pretty uh inflexible and
it's not what you want and how how to
use this comparator to use the
comparator we just type here
class
I'm gonna call it
comparator let's say Ram
and it's gonna extend
from comparator so type comparator and
you have the type and for the type here
we want to compare laptop so you type
laptop here
angle brackets curly braces and press
enter
and now we need to override
the
compare function inside our class so you
override that function and here again
let's change those to laptop one
so no now we have laptop one and laptop
two
and we Define
the same logic so we type here uh
return
if because you need to return an integer
if
this dot Ram
actually not this that ram laptop
laptop1.com
is greater than laptop 2.
Ram
and we need to delete this nullables
because you need to
have some errors there
and put curly braces return one else if
else if laptop
one dot Ram
is less than laptop 2.
laptop two dot Ram then gonna return I'm
gonna put curly braces I'm gonna type
return
minus one else
we're gonna return
zero now if I want to now to compare our
let's add the space here now I want to
sort our elements based on the RAM and
another print line here to add a space
so I'm gonna have the biggest photos in
also here one
so go quickly space it here
should be print
and now what we can do is we type
laptops Dot
and we type here
sorted with and which is we choose this
one which has the parameter Define a
comparator and we're going to pass our
comparator that we defined here with the
comparative function so I'm gonna pause
I'm going to type sorted with and we
type comparator
foreign
our class
and
create an instance and within the type
dot for each now this one
for each print line
it
so now if you run this you're gonna see
them sorted by their border Ram
so if you run this
as you can see uh if you look at the
if you look at the first there are they
are First Source did by their price we
have 68 800 and 1000 dollars and then we
have them sorted by the ram so we have
four for the four which is the dell and
then we have the Acer which is uh eight
gigabytes around and you have the Apple
which is 16 and uh if you look uh
actually they are in this order in the
list so let's change this to to let's
say to 16 and these two to wait
to
to make it more clear so let's run this
again
so as you can see they are still started
so we have first the Dell which has four
gigabytes of RAM then we have the Apple
which is eight then we have the Acer
which is 16. so this is why so now it's
sorting our list this sorted width using
comparator Ram that we defined we
created and then we Loop through all our
all elements because that Returns the
list so this is how you can use
comparator and if you want to uh to to
sort of let's say now the list by the
year you just create another comparator
so you type class
comparator let's say here
and it's also going to extend comparator
comparator
is going to have for the type laptops
because it's gonna Source laptops curly
braces we implement the function compare
and to define the logic for comparing
elements using uh using the ear so let's
delete this nullables
let's type here laptop one
and here laptop too
and I'm gonna copy this chord
I'm gonna paste it here
but I'm going to change this from Ram to
here
so here
also here
again
and we have an error here
missing so let's add the curly brace
here
all right so now if I want to to have
the element sorted by the year we just
type here
let's put a space Also print line
quotation marks for us this run and
found the laptops to be sorted by the by
the by the year I just like laptops that
sorted with
and this expects a comparator so I'm
gonna call our comparator that we
created comparator here comparator
here
an instance of that then for each
now this one again for each
print line
it
so if you run this
now we're gonna see the last element
sorted by their ear I have as you can
see
you have uh we have them sorted by the
ram so this is from this one
and now it's using comparator here so
you're sorting the embodies we have 20
20 21 and 2022 so this is just not like
the order that they are defined in uh in
the list so this is how you can use
comparable and comparable but if you
think about there is a lot of code here
to just have to have our
our list so that you have to we found
to
you have to you can use the compare the
comparable and with the comparable you
can use it with just one property and if
you want to use it with another property
you have to create those comparators
which gives you some flexibility but
still you have a lot of code and we can
remove all of this code
and use Lambda
functions
so I can delete all of this
all of this comparable that we have here
and instead of using those comparators
and all of this stuff what I can do is I
can delete all of this
I can little or this also
now what I can do is I can add here
laptops dot sorted
with and here
so we choose this one sorted with which
has this parameter comparator press
enter and here we type
compare
by
and here we type and this line of code
that we have here we it what it actually
is doing is creating a comparator but is
creating a comparator using a Lambda
expression so here you can type it dot
it's dot let's say uh price
right and then for each print line
it so this is equivalent to creating
that comparator here and inheriting from
the comparator interface and defining
the logic for uh uh or ordering for
sorting them so now if you if you run
this this will have the same effect like
the comparator price that we have
implemented previous as you can see they
are ordered now by the price and I can
do
now on another line of code Source dot
laptop dot sorted weight
and we type here compare by we type it
dot let's say uh
Ram
dot for each
print line
and it
now if you run this I'm gonna have the
same output let's add the space between
them print line
so let's add the space to see them to
see the code more clearly
and now as the as you can see the first
they are sorted by their price and then
they are sorted by their uh their RAM
memory so this code is equivalent to
creating what we had previously with the
comparator and implementing the dotting
interface and the function and actually
there is a shorter way even to do this
we can delete this let's say so the
sorted with and compare bear compare by
and we can just type here sort by
so this this will create internally the
same thing that we had previously so if
I type it dot ROM
and I can do the same thing here I can
delete all of this and I just
could type here selector the sort by
eat that price now this will have the
same effect like all the code that we
had previously but now it's extremely
concise and easier to read you just say
laptop sorted by sorted them by their
price so the elliptos by the ram so if
you run this code
you'll see the exact output in the
console because what this function is
doing uh actually we should Loop through
them so let's add the print line here
print line it
so let's put here for each
put into line
it
so now if you run this you will see the
exact same output we just this simple
line of code
so as you can see you have the same
output we have them sorted divide their
price first and then they are sorted by
their RAM memory and if you hold Ctrl on
this sorted by function
as you can see this actually internally
calls the sorted width which receives
the comparator and is calling the
compound the compare buy so this is like
a syntactical sugar for us which makes
the code more concise but internally
it's using using that sorted weight and
uh if you want to use the salt to do it
one advance for using a sorted with
let's say that I type here another print
line to add a space
let's put photos lesson
should be in quotation marks
forward slash n one
good thing about the sorted width so
let's type laptops
Dot
sorted weight
and here we type
compare by
let's say it dot year one thing that you
can do with the sorted with if you call
specific restorative function you can
put that and then buy so it will sort by
year and then by I know let's say uh it
dot price so this is what you would get
what you can do with the sorted with you
can sorted by year first and then by uh
by the price so if you run this
as you can see they are sorted first by
the year so
and then buy their uh their price so
this way we get this in the output
now I'm gonna end this video and uh you
should you should use this uh this one
always because it's
concise monitable yeah very easy to to
to read and to and to type is
in contrast with what we had previously
with the or creating that comparators
and implementing the comparator
interface or the comparable
this is a lot a lot more concise and
easier to read so this is our discussion
about the comparable and comparator
interface so this line of code I repeat
this line of code that we have here
this sorted by it does RAM is creating
internally that comparator that we
talked about
the node we're just using this Lambda
function
so I'm going to end the video now and
see you in the next video so there is
one mistake that I did previously so if
I press Ctrl Z to have this code uh when
I run this code you you didn't sound
output then the list sorted by the year
and then by the price and that is
because I forgot to add the four each
to Loop through our elements so if I add
the four each and now if I run this now
we're gonna see them
sorted first by the year and then buy
the price because previously it wasn't
so this is why it wasn't now if you look
they are sorted by the first by the year
so we have 2020 2021 and 22 and then buy
uh by their price so this is why
previously you saw this one this output
and also I saw this output that but uh
some way I uh I didn't uh didn't saw
that I forgot to add the foliage here so
this is how you can also sort the sorted
width you can um sort it by more
elements you can put here I think
another
then buy
not here
we can put another so
dot then by you can put another then by
here if you want so eat that so let's
say your RAM
so you can add more more than buy if you
want so
now I'm gonna end with the video see you
and see you in the next video now it's
time to start a discussion about binding
the search but before you look at binary
search you're going to first look at
linear search to see why a binary search
works better so I'm gonna type a
function here I'm going to type private
fun it's going to be called search
element
and you're going to type search elements
so this parameter is going to be the
element that we are searching for
and it's gonna then another parameter is
going to be a list
of numbers so it's going to be a
multiple list
of ins
and it's going to return a number the
search element or minus one if you don't
find the search element
and here we're going to Loop through our
release so I'm going to type for number
in our list of numbers
if
at a particular iteration or number
it's equal to the search
element that means that we found the
element that we found the number so
we're going to return number
else if you come down here and after we
Loop and we did our if checks we didn't
return the number that means we didn't
find a number we're going to return
minus on here
now I'm gonna add the print line here
and I'm gonna type search
element because this is going to return
an element and then you're gonna output
with the print line dot in the console
and I'm going to type here 27
and for the next parameter I'm going to
define a list of numbers one time
Multiple List off
and here I'm going to define a number
from 1 to 30 so I'm going to type here
the numbers one
and our last element 30.
now if you run this code you're gonna
see in the output 27
so we get as expected 27 but let's
declare a variable here I
to number the number of iteration it
took it took to find the elements I'm
going to assign 0 to it
I'm going to increment it every time you
Loop so I'm going to type Val I'm going
to type I sorry plus plus
and I'm gonna print line here
and I'm gonna it's gonna say search
number
colon
dollar sign I
so now if you run this we're gonna see
how many iteration it took to found our
element
and if you look at the console as you
can see it took 27
27 iteration before we found our element
because the way the linear search is
working is it's going through all of the
elements is checking out each iteration
if the number of that particular
iteration is equal to the search element
if not it's going to loop again and
again again until it reaches 27 then it
found that element and it Returns the
element and you get that element
outputted here in the console
so this is what we call a linear search
and this is not particularly good
because imagine if you have 1 billion
elements or 10 billion elements and you
need to find I don't know
maybe the 7th billion element in the in
that array that is going to be very hard
and it's going to take a
time and memory and because of that we
have another
data structure for a searching element
and that is called binary search and I'm
going to type the code for binary search
here and also you're going to see the
number of iteration it tooks to
find element and also I'm going to
explain how binary search works so I'm
going to delete this
I'm going to type here VAR low I'm going
to put equals to zero
VAR
High equals to
numbers that size minus one I'm going to
explain the code immediately
here I'm going to type while
low is less than equal
to high
here I'm gonna type Val mid so now we're
going to get the middle element so I'm
going to put parenthesis slow
plus High divided by 2 and that's going
to give us the middle element 15.
then
I'm going to type Val comparison so I'm
going to type CMP
equals to numbers
dot get the middle element compared to
we're going to compare the middle
element with the search element
then I'm going to type here if
now I'm going to type if
comparison is less than zero
then I'm going to type here low
equals to
mid
plus one
lcf
if comparison is not less than zero
so it's greater than zero
I'm going to type here that
low
is equal to
High
sorry
is equal to my mid
-1
else
when I type here return
numbers
dot get meet and that is going to give
us the middle element
now if I declare here a variable
VAR
I and if I assign 0 to 8
and if I increment that I at each
iteration
and if I add a print line here
search
number
dollar sign I
now if you run this you're gonna see uh
you're gonna actually I should return
minus on here
because uh if at the end of our looping
and after we checked our all of our list
and we didn't find the number then we
determine this one meaning that we
didn't find the element
so now if you run this again
we get
search number one two three and then we
get 27 and as you can see this is
significantly different from our linear
search because now we only took three
searched and then I found the he found
our element previously we had to search
through all of our elements
through our elements until uh the number
27 to to get the number seven but now we
only get the
three iteration and we get the number 27
and how is that possible this is because
now we're using what is called the
binary search and how this binary search
works I'm going to explain it now so now
let's see how the code works
so first we have a variable declare code
load which assign a value of 0. then we
have another variable called height
which assign number the PSI minus one so
we assign the size of the array to our
high
then we have a variable called I to
which you assign 0. then we have a while
loop and we start looping by this
condition while low is less than equal
to high
then we increment our I to keep track of
how many iteration it takes before we
find the element and without any console
search element and the number at that
iteration
then we have a variable called mid and
this is going to give us the middle
element and to get the middle element we
add the lower lowest element plus the
highest element so yeah we'll add here 0
plus 30 divided by 2 which is 15. so
this is the
middle element
then we declare another variable called
comparison and we type here numbers that
get the middle element which is 15
compared to search element and if the
middle element is less than the search
element that means that the search
element is on the right of the numbers
which come after the 15 and because of
that this is gonna return because our
middle element is less than the search
element is going to return a negative
number so this is going to be true
comparison is going to be less than zero
and then I'm gonna assign low equals to
Mid Plus on so now
the low variable has the value 16 all
right now it will loop again it will uh
it will uh do it will have the I
incrementally it will
do the while loop it will increment the
I again and it will output into I in the
console now here now it will calculate
again the middle element and it will it
will add now 16.
Plus
30 divided by 2 and that is going to
give give us 23.
all right
now that is the middle element now and
what we do now here is we again uh I
have our variable comparison and we get
numbers that get 23 so we get the 23
element and we compile with our search
element which is 27.
and again because our middle element
is less than the search element this is
going to return on any negative number
so this shift check is going to be true
again now what is gonna
happen is that now low
is going to be equal to Mid
plus 1 and the low previously was equal
to 23 so now I'm going to have 23 plus 1
which is 24 all right
now this will loop again
or loop again so
as you can see this basically breaks the
the list in half at each iteration and
now this will loop again it will
increment the eye to Output I and now it
will calculate again the middle element
now the middle element is 24.
and the high element is 30 and we have
24 plus 30
divided by 2. and that is 27 the exact
number that we are searching for so this
is how binary search works it will
compare the middle element with the
search element if the middle element is
less than the search element that means
that your element is on the right side
of the element which come after the
middle element so all the elements from
the left are going to be excluded and
it's going to search only on the on the
right side
then it will split the list again in
half if the middle element again is less
than the search element it will go to
the right again it will speed the least
in half I need to sooner or later it
will find the element to to to the right
or to the left
so this is how one research version is
very powerful because for a very big uh
list you can use binary search and it's
more effective that uh only the linear
search
and uh this is the code that I type but
it doesn't you don't need to use this
code because uh I only type this code to
show you how the binary search works but
usually you'll use the binary search
function provided by The Collection so
you will just type here return
numbers
we're gonna put square brackets and I'm
gonna type binary I'm going to type here
numbers again binary dot binary search
because the binary search function
provided by The Collection only return
the returns the index so if I
search for the 27 element
that is going to return the index 26th
and the index 26 then it's gonna be the
number 27 from our numbers list so now
if you run this you'll see 27 output in
the console
so get 27 and we did this one with one
line of code you can even remove this
and just have a
single expression function so we can put
here
equals
so just by that it will do the same
thing that we did previously with all
the code that I typed
so this is our discussion about binary
search and see you in the next video but
before I end the video I should say that
binary search only works with the order
collection of elements so your elements
need to be sorted in order to for the
binary search to work and in our case we
look we used integer numbers and it was
easy because we typed elements in a in a
sorted order
but uh if the elements are not sorted by
by research is not going to work also if
you have your own class so you have your
own objects and you search with using
one research uh through a list for a
specific element in that case your class
has to implement the comparable
interface or it has to to to to use the
comparator interface and I'm going to
show you how to do that in the next
video so see you in the next video
so now it's time to start a discussion
about genetics so what are genetics
genetics allows us to give to the
compiler some hints about what kind of
objects you are dealing with and this
helps the compiler to figure out some
errors at compile time and it also helps
us to write more consistent and better
code and we already use genetics when we
look at collections so every time you
use an array and you you specified in
the angle brackets an INT or a double or
a class that you created an object what
you actually did there is that you use
generic you set the compiler that that
is the kind of data that specific
collection is gonna store so if you have
something like this while let's say
numbers
and
we put equals is equals here and type
array of
here you can put angle brackets
and you can specify a type here let's
say in because
I'm going to put numbers here and now
this helps the compiler to figure out if
let's say we want to add here let's say
a string so if I type here numbers
equals let's say your
some text let's put in quotation marks
some text as you can see you have those
underlines red which says if you hover
over here
first it says that Val cannot be resent
so let's change this to VAR to get the
error that I want so let's put VAR here
so we get here type mismatch required
and found string so here we are using a
generic type and the generic type is an
integer and because we said explicitly
here that this array is only going to
store integers we cannot go down here
and assign some string but
as I said at the beginning
genetics are only a compile timing
feature they don't make it through the
runtime and again we're going to come
back to this later because this has some
implications
now let's uh delete this and let's
create our own generic class to see how
it works because here we're passing in
but if you click on this array of
you see that you don't have here any an
intest the type that we SP we
specifically decided to pass to this
array but if you look here inside this
library.kt and if you go to array here
you see you see that we have VAR Arc
elements and we have this t
and T is a genetic type and the specific
type that is going to be passed here is
the type that we pass when we create an
arrays when we want to store some
numbers or some strings and now now
let's see how we can create a similar
thing that we have here with our with
our own code so I'm gonna delete this so
again generics are there to
to to help the compiler to figure out
errors and it also they are there for
helping us to write better and
consistent calls so that you you don't
add let's say uh strings to to an array
which is meant to store only numbers so
first I'm going to create a class and
it's going to be an Open Class
and it's going to be called player
and it's going to have a property called
name so it's going to be a Val name
we're going to Define this in the
primary Constructor it's going to be a
string
now I'm gonna create
open class here
and down here I'm going to create two
classes first is going to be called
football player so football
player
and this is gonna have a name and it's
gonna be a property because you're gonna
gonna extend from our player class we're
gonna derive from our operator class I'm
gonna pass this property to the dot
parameter name to our property name from
the superclass so if we type here player
because we were in inheriting from it
and here first name
so you pass your name
next I'm going to create another class
called baseball player so we type here
baseball
player
and this is also going to have a name
also only a parameter because the
property is going to be ultimately
defined by the
superclass by the class from which we
are inheriting from so here we're gonna
inherit put the colon to inherit from
our player player class and here we pass
our name parameter that we defined here
we pass it here to the primary
Constructor of the base class from which
we are inheriting from
all right so now I'm gonna go up here
and now I'm gonna create a class called
team
and this class is going to represent a
team and this thing can be a football
team or a baseball team and here we're
going to create the class called team so
we type the keyword class I'm gonna call
it team
and now here we put angle brackets and
inside the angle brackets we're gonna
Define the generic type t
and you can use a different letter here
if you want but usually and generally
use the T because it stands for the for
type parameter
next to put parenthesis to define the
primary Constructor and for the primary
Constructor I'm going to define
a Val name and this is going to
represent the name of the theme and it's
going to be a string and next I'm going
to Define also valuable this is going to
be called players and it's going to be a
multiple list
of also of type T so we type here
Multiple List
and we put here t
right
now I'm going to put curly braces
because I'm going to define a function
inside our class team so here we type
fun and I'm going to call this function
add
players so this function is going to add
players to the team
we put parentheses and here we Define a
parameter called called player and it's
going to be of type T so it's going to
be
should put
a colon here
and we put curly braces
and this is going to receive a parameter
of type T and this type T that we Define
here and here and here is going to be
the type the specific type that we gonna
pass when we create an instance with our
class team so
first here we're gonna check if
the
players
so our list of players contains this
player that is passed our ad player
function because if or you already have
that player in our list We're Not Gonna
add it to our list so if player and to
check if that player is in the list we
call the contains function on our uh on
on our uh
Multiple List so here we we type players
that contains player the argument
and if that is true I'm gonna put curly
braces
and here we're gonna output something
because to the console so we type here
print line
quotation marks and we type player
colon and then we put dollar sign curly
braces
and here we need to do something which
is called casting and casting casting is
used when you want a variable to be
treated as a certain type of variable so
when you want a variable to be treated
by the component by the compiler as a
certain type of object or or a class so
we type here player
because let's let's let me show you why
we need to do that because if I type
here player now I want to get the name
and if I put here dot name as you can
see we don't have any name here because
because this type because this T and
this T that we have here is generic the
compiler has no idea if this T that is
going to be passed here so this piece so
if you pass here
a baseball player or football player it
has no idea if at this moment now if
that is gonna have uh is gonna have a
name property on it this is why when you
type here that's name we don't get
nothing and to solve that we can say to
the compiler for them to the compiler to
treat this parameter here so this is
going to be a value pass to this
parameter as a player and in that sense
in that in that way you can get access
to the name property so we type here
player and
to cast to cast a variable to a certain
type we put as so we put
the keyword as and the type player
and we put this in parentheses so we
surround our expression in parentheses
inside the curly braces
and now here at the end of of the of the
end of the enclosing parentheses you put
that and now we have access to name
because we settle the compiler hey treat
this player variable I don't know
because I don't know if this is going to
be it's going to be a player
a player object passed here or a
baseball player or or a football player
treat this player variable that is
passed here as because here we have
teeth so we don't know what it is three
display to display a variable as a
player so you can use the name of a
variable and we're gonna say is already
in the TM and we can put here
the team and we can type here dollar
sign this Dot name so the name of the TM
else if if our player is not in the team
we put else
we're going to press enter to add the
right curly brace we're gonna add this
player to the list because if the if
fails that means that the player is not
present in our list so we type here
players
our
Multiple List dot add this player that
is passed player and we're also going to
output something to go to the console so
you add here print line
and uh
I'm gonna copy this because I'm just
gonna change the text a little bit
so let's delete this
player and so here is we're gonna say
instead of it's already
I'm gonna say it was
added
in the team
now let's create some objects with those
classes that we have here so first I'm
going to create some some players so I'm
going to create first the football
player so type here
Val for the ball player equals football
player
and
for the name I'm going to use a generic
name I'm gonna type just football
player
one
and I'm gonna press Ctrl D to create
another football player so football
player two is going to be called
and I'm gonna create two baseball
players so we type here Val
baseball player equals
baseball player
and we type here
baseball
player one and I'm gonna call Press Ctrl
D here also I'm gonna
call this baseball player 2 and I'm
gonna change this to 2.
now I'm going to create an instance of
our team class so we cut we type here
Vault team and this is going to be a
team of football players so we type Val
team
equals
and hero type team
and we put now because as you can see
it's expecting a type here and the type
is going to be
football player so it's gonna be a team
with what it's gonna be a team with the
football players and you're gonna Define
a name
also generic name football
team is going to be called
and they also need to pass an array
there
and for this array I'm gonna type just
uh
mod multiple array of
we can't
foreign
list of
and here I'm gonna pass our
football player I'm gonna pass only our
first football player here
now I'm going to create another team Val
team uh let's actually call this first
team football team so let's type here
food bowl
football team
now if you run this code
we don't get it on any output because
our ad player's function wasn't called
but if I
type here a football team
foreign
actually here football team
that
add players and I'm gonna add football
player too
now if I run this code
we get football player two was actually
here should be added
football player 2 was added in the team
football team so our code works well and
we use generic types for our classes
here we specified only the T and this T
that we have here was replaced with
football player that we Define here and
um
uh we're gonna do the same thing we're
gonna create another theme for the
baseball player and we're also going to
look at
how we can restrict the types that are
going to be passed to our generic type
here
so now I'm going to create a baseball
team so I'm going to type here Val
baseball team
put equals then you put Here theme
and here we type for the generic type T
baseball player because this is gonna
store baseball players and we Define a
name here the name is going to be
baseball team or generic name
and uh also you need to type to pass a
multiple list so type Multiple List
and we pass here a baseball player
but as you can see
here for the type
the type here is great oh that is
because
here we pass the football player
uh object that we create then here we
pass the baseball player
because kotlin has Type inference it can
infer the type as being a team of
football players so we don't need to put
here for the player we can delete this
you can delete all of this
and now our code still works and you can
see we have this type here which says
team football player so it's a team of
football players and it's uh inferred
it's inferred automatically by quoting
for us and you can do the same thing if
here for a baseball player so I'm gonna
delete this
as you can see now we also have the hint
team baseball player now let's add to
the baseball player
let's call the baseball player function
let's put here a
so we type here base bullet
team let's call the function dot add
players and hero type baseball player 2
because first one was added there
so now if you run the squad
not debug so run this code
let's increase this
we get let's actually decrease this so
let's put here we get player football
player 2 was added to the team football
team so we have this code here
which is called and it says that the
the football player was added to the
team and the name of the football team
and then we have player and we have
baseball player player two
so this
this one
that we have here
that we pass here
baseball team that was this to the
baseball team as you can see it says
player baseball player 2 was added to
the baseball team
and what generics helps out to do
because I said they can help the
compiler to figure out errors if you try
to
pass here baseball TM Dot
add football player so we type here
football player
now you get an error because
the generic type enforces the type on
the the
on the class because here we said
explicitly that this is because this was
inferred to be as a baseball player if
you cannot pass here a football player
in our baseball team because this is in
first because you said Siri here
explicitly explicitly because first
because this was inferred from here so
we have team baseball player so we
cannot add here a football brain inside
our team football player and this is
very very
powerful for us because in this way we
don't do things which doesn't make sense
and the the same is true about our
football team so if on our football team
so if enough of working with a football
team
dot add
and here to put baseball player
we get an error because we specified we
specified that because the generic type
was
in fair to be a football player so we
cannot put a baseball player in our team
of football players so this is what
generics is doing is figure out those
errors for us at compile time and this
is very powerful because we cannot we
can run our code and we don't get in
those some
scenarios where we have a bay of
baseball player added to a baseball team
or maybe other examples there so I'm
gonna delete this
next we're gonna look at upper bounds
because
our upper bounds basically allows us to
restrict what kind of type is passed to
our generic type here so
and particularly gonna see how this is
gonna affect this code that we use here
to cast so to to add an upper bound so
to restrict what kind of type is passed
to this type we can put
colon so extends and here you can we can
type player
so what we are saying here is that
every
type that is going to be passed here
when you create an instance like
we did here so but only that this was in
Fair here this type that is going to be
passed here needs needs to inherit from
the player class otherwise this type is
not going to work so because of that
because the compiler now knows that and
enforces this that this type that is
going to be passed here is is going to
be is going to inherit from the player
class we we can't delete this cast
because now it knows that that type is
gonna have uh it's gonna be it's gonna
inherit from the player class so it's
gonna have the property name so if I
delete this
and if I delete this so let's put name
here
now
so let's delete these two
should be player here
player
so now we have player the name because
it knows that this type so this type
that is going to be passed series is
going to inherit from the player cards
from the player class so it's gonna have
the property name so you don't need to
do this the weird this word cast is
overcasting so I'm gonna delete this
and now as you can see we don't have uh
any arrows so now we have the name here
because now it knows that whatever type
you pass here it has to inherit from the
player class so if I go down here and I
create another class called gamer
player so
we type here class
let's call it games player
and it's gonna have a Val
is going to be
actually let's define a parameter only
name
is going to be a string
and we will not inherit from our player
class let's see what happens so
if I um
if I uh create here another theme let's
call it Val
let's call it the game Steam
so I'm gonna
type here team and we're gonna specify
here
games player
now if if I put now the primary
Constructor here here we need to define
a name
let's call it
games
team
and
multiple list of
now
here we have an error and if you look it
says
expected player found games player and
this happens because our games player
that we have here is not inheriting from
the player class and because we said
here that the upper bound is this T that
is passed here so this T is this here
has to inherit from the player class
otherwise if you if you don't uh inherit
from the player class it will not work
because you said here that it it must
inherit from the player class now if I
change this to
if I change this down here to inherit
from the player class so it I hear
player
we type here name
now as you can see the error disappears
because now it's respecting the upper
bound that we set we set up here which
is T
meaning games player has to inherit from
the player class and down here it's
inheriting so this is our discussion
about how we can use generics and how we
can use how you can Define upper bounds
and in the next videos you're gonna look
at
um
type erasures and you're going to lose
what reified
a keyword and how you can inline our
function with because you need to inline
your function when the use refine the
keyword so see you in the next video
well actually before I end the video I
should say why this uh genetics is
important why
because if you think about because here
you can type we can define a generic
type we don't need to create
um a separate class for for every team
that that we want to use so we don't
need to create a football team we don't
need to create a separate baseball team
we don't need to create a
separate games team we we just create a
team we Define the generic type T and
here we pass our we pass our
our type and in this way we can use only
one class
and we can we can have all of those uh
those uh baseball team we can have the
football team we can have just by having
the the type here which is generic
otherwise we'll have to create separate
classes for each of those
teams so
see you in the next video and next video
as I said we're gonna look at type
erasers and refine the verified the
keyword and the inline functions and in
the next videos we're going to look also
at covariance and counter variance so
see in the next video